Ja, willkommen zur Freak Show, denn so heißt dieser Podcast jetzt. Und da gab es schon sehr unterschiedliche Meinungen dazu, ob das nun eine tolle Idee ist oder nicht. Aber wir können das Rätsel aufklären.
Und nun also Ronald Pofalla, der heute hier seit 10 Uhr Reden und Antwort gestanden hat und jetzt noch einmal vor der Pässe sprechen wird.
Auch alle recht herzlich willkommen. Wir hatten aus meiner Sicht eine informative und gute Sitzung, um das Ergebnis gleich vorweg zu nehmen.
Es ist eine tolle Idee, weil wir das sagen.
Das haben wir jetzt nicht nur mündlich, sondern auch noch einmal schriftlich bestätigt bekommen. Und wichtig ist in diesem Zusammenhang, dieses Schreiben ist vom britischen Außenminister persönlich autorisiert. Ja, offiziell.
Das ist gut. Ich schalte hier nochmal die Lautsprecher aus. Das macht sich gut bei der Akustik.
Überhaupt müssen wir hier so ein bisschen improvisieren.
Wollen wir die Fenster schließen oder wollen wir uns mit der ganzen Erratik, die von draußen dann so normalerweise hereinkommt, einfach abfinden oder?
Ach, wenn es zu viel Erratik wird.
Wir können ja vielleicht ein Entropieventil schließen hier.
Ja, ist auch besser als immer so blöd, wenn einem die Dackel die ganze Zeit ins Gesicht starren.
Ach, ich weiß nicht. Also wenn die da draußen erratischer sind als wir, können wir immer noch zumachen.
Wir lassen uns von dieser blöden Erratik nicht ins Boxhorn jagen, denn wir sind die Freaks.
Wir können das eh besser.
Genau.
116 Mal haben wir das dann, wenn wir das dann am Ende dieser Sendung unter Beweis gestellt haben oder auch nicht.
116 Mal unser Nerd gestanden.
Oh ja, den Freak erfüllt. Ja, genau und so sieht es aus und wir haben heute etwas begrenztes Angebot hier, was die unterschiedlichen Stimmlagen betrifft. Huckel ist da. Hallo Huckel. Endlich wieder Huckel.
Herzlich willkommen.
Du warst lange unterwegs.
Ich war lange unterwegs und habe voller Trauer die erste Sendung verpasst.
Ja, aber dafür hattest du ja allerlei zu tun. Also, ich meine, du musstest dich sonnen und kremen.
Ich habe mal Urlaub gemacht und es einkremen. Das war anstrengend, sag ich dir. Na, es war August und es ist Mittelmeer und nach jedem Baden, also der Nerd, der ungebräunte, unvorbereitete, ungestellte, bei den ersten Sonnenstrahlen, der sofort sonnenbrannt. Na ja, der Aluhut hat leider auch nicht genug Umfang.
Es gibt jetzt auch ganzkörper Aluhute.
Alu-Sombrero?
Haben wir ja hier letzte Sendung auch schon festgestellt.
Ich wusste, ich habe was vergessen.
Ist gestiegen, so wurden die auch immer. Also hast du das dann halt mit Creme gemacht.
50 plus, nerd approved, hat gehalten. Einmal habe ich es nicht gemacht, bang, sonnenbrand.
Ja, man muss natürlich auch irgendwie seine Programmiererbelässe erhalten. Sonst wird man unglaubwürdig.
Hier an den Armen, da bin ich so ein bisschen gebräunter als sonst.
Stell mir vor, wie das jetzt ist, wenn man in die Drogerie geht und dann irgendwie so mit dieser Sonnencreme fruchtelt. Sagen sie mal, hilft das auch gegen NSA?
Zum Thema Sonnencreme irgendwie. Ich kann mich erinnern, in meiner Kindheit, in meiner Jugend war irgendwie so.
Gab es das nicht?
Na doch, gab es schon, aber da war so Faktor 4, war viel und Faktor 8, da war die Skala zu Ende. Und jetzt gehst du in den Laden und kriegst 25 oder 50. Also ich meine, haben die irgendwie die Messmethode geändert? Oder ist das Ozone auch wirklich schon so weit? Oder was ist da passiert?
Also eine Sache finde ich auf jeden Fall sowieso schon mal mega faszinierend. Du trägst da so eine dünne Schicht auf, also die du ja auch gar nicht mehr siehst. Das ist ja wirklich so, du cremst dich ein und es sieht aus wie vorher. Und es schützt einfach vor diesen aggressiven, nerdfeindlichen Sonnenstrahlen.
Ich hab gerade von irgendeiner wissenschaftlichen Studie irgendwas gelesen, wo sie wieder irgendwelche Tiere analysiert haben oder zumindest vor hatten das zu tun. Was waren denn das?
Fische?
Keine Ahnung. Es gibt auf jeden Fall so Viecher, denen macht einfach die fucking UV-Strahlung nichts aus. Verdammt, ich hab vergessen, was es war. Es war ein Tier, was jeder kennt.
Südamerikanische Kollegen von mir haben auch gar keinen. Denen ist dieses Konzept Sonnencreme zwar bekannt.
Nee, die sind ja auch durchpigmentiert. Aber unser eins hier in den hohen Breiten, wo normalerweise irgendwie kein UV-Strahl die Straße betreten durfte, die Zeiten sind vorbei.
Aber ich hab mich echt komisch gefühlt. Ich war mit denen so am See einen Tag und dann komm ich hier so an mit Zztzzt und hier voll Body-Armer und so weiter und die so, ja hier ist es wohl.
Das ist so, wie wir uns halt dann so Japaner belächeln, wenn sie Alkohol trinken.
Und so jeder so seine Insuffizienzen.
Haben die auch Alkoholschutzcreme, die Japaner?
Nichtsdestotrotz, es ist absolut schon faszinierend. Irgendwie so eine unsichtbare Schicht, die dann komplett irgendwie alles abhält.
Ja, das ist alles schon ganz toll. Ja, Roddy ist auch da, ihr habt es schon gehört.
Hallo.
Du warst nicht im Urlaub, oder was?
Nicht in den letzten zwei Wochen, nein.
Zu dem Urlaub kann ich übrigens auch gleich noch, kann ich auch übrigens eben Nerd empfehlen. Ist so ein wandschönes...
So Urlaub machen meinste.
Da können wir auch gleich mit anfangen. Ich wollte nur mal kurz darauf hinweisen, denn es ist nicht da aus technischen Gründen.
Wir sagen nur Kalender.
Genau, aus Kalendergründen ist Denis nicht da. Und Clemens schippert jetzt gerade irgendwo an einem fernen Ort, aber seine Aussage nach mit guter Internetversorgung. Also hört er uns jetzt wahrscheinlich auch. Wollen wir mal kurz zuwinken?
Ich wink nicht ins Internet.
Das darf man jetzt auch schon nicht mehr machen.
Ich grüße.
Das dramatisch wie der Nutzen des Internets gerade unheimlich abnimmt. Hätte man das so gedacht, dass Webseiten anfangen, einfach komplett zu schließen? Nach dem Motto Goodbye Internet?
Was tut ihr eigentlich die ganze Zeit?
Da übt jemand Gitarre. Ich würde sagen, hat es nötig.
Okay, das ist die Erratik.
Das sind halt die ganzen Fehlermomente der Außenwelt, die jetzt hier auf uns einfließen und uns zu Fehlentscheidungen oder so was bringen möchten. Unsere Bits kippen nicht so ohne Weiteres. Ja, jetzt habt ihr mich gerade aus dem Konzept gebracht.
Ich glaube, wir haben uns alle aus dem Konzept gebracht.
Du fängst an von Websiten zu schließen.
Genau, ich weiß nicht, ob ihr das mitbekommen habt, hier mit GrogLaw. Das ist so diese Webseite, die sich seinerzeit einen extremen Gruppennamen damit verdient hat, dass sie diese SCO versus Linux-Rechtsdrama über viele Jahre extrem detailliert begleitet hat und dann auch so in den letzten Jahren. Ich muss zugeben, dass ich da jetzt kein regelmäßiger Leser bin, aber sehr häufig kommt oder kam zumindest GrogLaw immer wieder auf und die wohl im Wesentlichen dort aktive Frau, die das so betreibt, die hat halt jetzt gesagt so, naja, hier Lavabit meinte ja irgendwie so mit E-Mails, wäre jetzt alles blöd und wenn ihr wüsstet, was ich wüsste, würdet ihr E-Mail nicht mehr benutzen und da meint sie, ja dann kann ich auch diese Webseite nicht mehr betreiben, weil ich einfach keinerlei Quellenschutz mehr in irgendeiner Form irgendwie noch sicherstellen kann und also ich glaube jetzt das Wort Quellenschutz in dem Sinne hat sie nicht in den Mund genommen, aber es floss meiner Meinung nach so zwischen den Zeilen relativ dickflüssig hervor. Und naja.
Internet.
Jetzt wird sie halt geschlossen. Ja, tschüss Internet. Ich meine, gut, das mag jetzt so eine Reaktion sein. Ich hab dann auch interessanter Podcast übrigens, falls jemand Lust hat, das mal nachzuhören. Jetzt müsste mir gerade noch mal einfallen, welcher das war.
Falls jemand auch mal Lust hat, einen Podcast zu hören.
Genau, falls ihr auch mal ein Podcast hören möchtet. Nicht immer dieses Gedude.
Moment, jetzt muss ich mal kurz in meinen Milliarden von Podcast-Subscriptions suchen.
Ja, jetzt muss ich mal gucken, ob mein Podcast-Klient eigentlich hier das entsprechende Feature hat, hat er. Es muss gewesen sein.
Ich hab's, Gott sei Dank.
Wir hätten sonst das Volumen unserer Stimmorgane nach oben geriegelt.
No Brainer. Es ist die letzte veröffentlichte Ausgabe von Off the Hook, dem Hacker-Radio, dem wöchentlichen von 2600 aus New York. Die Sendung vom, die haben ja immer keine Nummern, aber ich glaube, das ist die vom 14.
August genau. Also die von ziemlich genau vor einer Woche.
Heute wird wohl eine neue aufgenommen. Und da wird das auch alles ein bisschen diskutiert und unter anderem zu Gast Phil Zimmermann über Telefon. Phil Zimmermann, der Erfinder von PGP. Der Phil Zimmermann, der sozusagen den Crypto War seiner Zeit da gefordert hat. Und er äußert sich da recht ausführlich zu seinen Motivationen, warum er seinen Mail-Dienst nach Lavabit ja auch gleich seinen Mail-Dienst geschlossen hat. Ja, das ist mal ein sehr interessanter Einblick. So und diese Motivationen meint er halt auch so. Das wäre halt jetzt einfach, man hätte diesen Dienst so nicht mehr anbieten können und er bittet da auch für Verständnis für den radikalen Schnitt, den sie da gemacht haben, weil sie haben einfach alles gelöscht. Das ist natürlich schon ein bisschen hart, wenn du dann so Mail-Provider bist und dann so, zack.
Einfach so ohne Vorwarnperiode und so?
Naja, so im Wesentlichen.
Du bist ja bei solchen Leuten, hast ja deine Mail, weil du weißt, die machen das, wenn das der richtige Schritt ist. Alle anderen sind ja bei web.de oder bei Gmail.
Ja, na gut, also ich bezweifle, dass dieser Fall mit, wenn die schwarzen Hubschrauber kommen, löschen wir alles ungefragt sofort. Ob das jetzt so im Vertrag drin stand, da bin ich mir nicht so sicher. Aber ich schätze mal, seine Einschätzung ging eher so in diese Richtung mit, ich weiß genug über meine Kunden, um zu wissen, dass sie das lieber sofort gelöscht als kopiert haben wollen. Und das war an der Stelle die Motivation. Also sehr interessanter Podcast. Übrigens generell auf The Hook finde ich, ich höre es nicht regelmäßig, aber es ist halt ein Klassiker. Ich glaube, das ist das älteste Hacker-Radio, was es überhaupt gibt. Ich habe keine Ahnung, wann die angefangen haben, aber das läuft schon seit ich denken kann.
Schon als Amateurfunk ausgestrahlt oder was?
Amateurfunk, das läuft auf diesem freien WBAI, also W-B-A-I, Radiosender in New York, als UKW, wo die dann halt immer reingeschlutzt kommen und da eben ihre Stünde füllen. Ich war auf der Omen sogar zu Gast, als Off the Hook auf der Omen aufgenommen hat, aber leider scheint die Sendung entweder haben sie die nicht aufgenommen oder die Aufnahme ist ihnen abhanden gekommen, keine Ahnung, ist auf jeden Fall nicht im Feed. Da ist jetzt also so ein Sprung drin, das ist sehr schade. Das war ich ehrlich mal bei Off the Hook, die haben es nicht aufgenommen worden, super. Vielleicht die erste Sendung seit 20 Jahren, die nicht aufgenommen wurde, naja gut, war alles nicht so dramatisch.
Vielleicht haben sie auch beschlossen, es ist vielleicht besser, wenn es nicht veröffentlicht wird.
Jaja, so sieht es aus, alles schlimm. Solange das Internet allerdings noch existiert, senden wir noch weiter.
Also langsam müssen wir den jungen Herren da oder Damen oder wir auch immer...
Das ist geklampft, geht mir jetzt doch auf den Sack.
Ja, aber das war ja noch nicht so schlimm am Anfang.
Ja, es wird dann immer schlimmer halt.
Ja, aber sonst hat jetzt ja noch nicht so viel zugemacht, oder? Also sind die zwei auch so ein bisschen begegnet? Oder nee, der Lava-Bit oder dieser Mail-Provider, der ist mir begegnet, aber ansonsten...
Die beiden sind halt so diese Fälle, und jetzt ganz neu halt auch, sagen wir mal, so die erste relativ bekannte Webseite, die einfach sagt, wir haben das Vertrauen in die Internetkommunikation soweit verloren. Also wir sehen das so, dass wir noch nicht mal das Mindestmaß an Vertraulichkeit hier sichergestellt sehen. Und das bringt halt einfach alle in die Bredouille. Das ist halt auch so ein generelles Problem, was in dieser ganzen Debatte irgendwie überhaupt nicht da ist. Also es ist so, niemand sieht die Problematiken des Quellenschutzes. Also wenn du jetzt Journalist bist, und bist halt angewiesen auf Leute, auf Whistleblower, auf Leute, die dir halt einfach die schmutzigen Details darreichen und willst diese Leute schützen. Wie bitte willst du sie schützen? Unter zur Hilfenahme, also wie willst du das Internet noch als Tool, als Werkzeug einsetzen in einer Situation, in der du davon ausgehen musst, dass irgendwie deine komplette Kommunikation vollständig mitgeschnitten und im Zweifelsfall, wenn du halbwegs target bist, und das bist du einfach als Journalist, dann eben auch ausgewertet wird. Dann kannst du einfach diesen Job auch einfach sein lassen. Das ist einfach so das Kernproblem. Es wird immer viel von Freiheit und Freiheit und Freiheit geredet. Aber was jetzt eigentlich das Freiheitssichernde Moment ist, das finde ich in den Debatten relativ selten.
Ich glaube, dass die Leute, die da debattieren, das auch nicht immer unbedingt verstanden haben.
Ja, das kann sein. Ich will jetzt auch nicht unbedingt jedem unterstellen, dass er alles nicht verstanden hat. Manchmal ist es auch einfach sehr schwierig, dieses Gefühl des Wissens, was man irgendwie hat. Manchmal weiß man ja, oder glaubt man zumindest. Manchmal hat man das so, das ist so ein bisschen wie mit Computer erklären. Du kannst den Computer extrem gut verstanden haben. Du weißt genau, was die Auswirkungen von irgendwelchen Einschränkungen sind. Aber das dann zu erklären, dass andere das verstehen, ist sehr schwierig. Ähnlich ist es auch hier, weil du eigentlich ja auch einen Computer erklären musst. Dieses ganze Internet ist ein Computer hoch 1000. Und das macht die Sache halt einfach so schwierig. Die Leute verstehen einfach diese Auswirkungen nicht.
Ich meine, die meisten, also, ich hab ja schon mal gesagt bei mir, im Kurs sitzen ja auch heutzutage noch, Leute 25, 27, und die haben null Ahnung vom Internet, wie das funktioniert. Keine Ahnung über die Strukturen, wer da was kontrollieren kann. Nix, null, nada. Und dann sitz ich auch jedes Mal da und denk mir, ja.
27?
Ja, oder, weißt du, also die sind halt...
Wo sind die denn geboren worden?
Keine Ahnung, aber ich mein, heutzutage, also wir sind jetzt schon 13 Jahre im 21. Jahrhundert. Die benutzen das tagtäglich.
Wahrscheinlich können wir nur davon ausgehen, dass die 13-Jährigen, oder?
Ja, nee, also es gibt einfach immer wieder, also wenn man sich mit Nicht-Nerds unterhält, das ist schon immer wieder erschreckend, wie wenig sich die Leute auskennen. Ich war gestern was essen, und da saß so eine Frau an dem Computer da, an der Kasse und so, und dann hat die so zwischendurch gefragt, sag mal, ist das jetzt ein Tap, oder ist das ein Pop-Up? Und was ist denn der Unterschied? Und so auf dem Niveau ging das da so um diese Computer-Benutzung und Tap und Pop-Up, also weißt du so, wirklich Kilometer Dimension entfernt von dem, was da eigentlich da drunter passiert. Und wenn du mit solchen Leuten versuchst, dann so ein bisschen in die Tiefe zu gehen, technisch, oder was da so bestimmte Auswirkungen sind, ist ja komplett unmöglich. Und ich meine, hier im Kurs zum Beispiel, wenn ich denen dann erzähle, so hier, das ist ein Cookie und so werdet ihr getrackt und deswegen kommt eine Tonschuhe-Werbung auf der Hundefutter-Seite, wenn ihr vorher woanders und so weiter und so, ach und so, und Augen gehen auf und ich frage dann auch manchmal, ob jetzt so ihr persönliches Paranoia-Level nach dem Kurs irgendwie sich gesteigert hat und die meisten sagen dann auch, jo. Und ja, also, das macht halt auch insgesamt ein bisschen schwerer, da so eine gewisse Schwungmasse in der Debatte zu erreichen, die mal so gegenhält. War das eigentlich am Anfang dieser Pofaller wirklich die Stimme von dem? Ah, so eine creepy, also der sieht ja schon aus wie so ein creepy Schleimbeutel, aber er klingt auch so, ne? Ah, diesen Typ, also das ist echt so, ah, den, da kriege ich richtig Ausschlag, wenn ich den schon sehe.
Und dann noch der Name, also das ist irgendwie...
Ja, das ist wirklich so, wenn du ein Wörterbuch nach Arschkriecher nachschaust, da ist da so ein Bild von ihm, so ein Kupferstich oder sowas, ja. Als der hier schon irgendwie, ähm, der Merkel, der ist doch die ganze Zeit schon immer so der Wieselfling von der Merkel, ne, die ganzen Jahre, das ist auch wirklich, ah.
Vielleicht wird der der nächste Kanzler. Ich meine, die Merkel war ja mal der Wieselfling vom Kohl, ne?
Ja, stimmt, wenn du es so gesehen hast, ist es nicht weit weg, ja. Also Wieselfling, ja, Arschkriecher weiß man nicht so genau, ne, aber...
Naja, aber es hat ja doch sehr lange gedauert, bis sich die Merkel dann mal doch geäußert hat und was hat sie gesagt? Och, die Debatte ist jetzt vorbei. Fand ich auch sehr geil.
Ja, das ist irgendwie auch sehr schön. Das ist einfach alles so generell mit ja, was wollt ihr denn eigentlich? Es ist doch alles widerlegt. Obwohl irgendwie gar nichts widerlegt ist. Da muss man glaube ich auch wirklich aufrüsten, ne? Und man muss, also eigentlich zwingen sie einen total zum Populisten zu werden und auch einfach permanent nur noch beleglos zu übertreiben. Also ich hab das neulich irgendwie so auf dem Spielplatz versucht, die Überwachungsdiskussion mal so ein bisschen in so ein paar Eltern reinzuschieben, die so eigentlich auch ganz andere Nöte haben. Und da musst du schon mit Stasi 3.0 irgendwie lostrommeln und irgendwie Aktenberge vergleichen. Und ja, ist ja schlimmer als, was auch sehr schwierige Vergleiche sind, weil selbst wenn jetzt das Überwachungsmoment, also das digitale Überwachungsmoment, das natürlich der Stasi selbstverständlich bei weitem übertrifft, weil die hatte ja sozusagen dieses Internet noch gar nicht.
Andererseits könnte man aber sagen, dass die Stasi halt viel fieser war, weil du wusstest halt nicht, ob dein bester Kumpel, dem du gerade deine intimsten Details anvertraust.
Genau, das ist nämlich der Punkt. Natürlich war das viel creepier, weil es einfach viel mehr wirklich in deinem Intimbereich auch wirklich, also auch in dem realen Intimbereich vorgestoßen ist.
Aber gut, andererseits...
Weiß ja gar ja, wann jetzt die nächste News von Snowden kommt mit den ganzen Überwachungskameras, aber ich glaube, die Dimension haben wir an der Stelle noch nicht erreicht.
Na gut, aber andererseits auf Facebook erzählen sich auch die Leute die intimsten Sachen und schicken sich was weiß ich für Bilder hin und her und so weiter. Ich meine, also ja.
Naja, aber halt auch per Mail. Und inzwischen weißt du halt nicht mehr, wenn ich jemandem irgendwas per Mail schicke...
Wo es landet. Wo es landet.
Doch, du weißt jetzt, wo es landet.
Ja, genau. Also das ist der entscheidende Unterschied. Das lässt sich also sehr schwer vergleichen. Nur muss man jetzt eigentlich genauso populistisch da reingehen wie die anderen auch.
Ja, und eigentlich müsste man halt auch wie in... da müsste man eigentlich auch so die ganzen Fälle, wo es sozusagen mal so negative Auswirkungen gibt, auch gnadenlos sozusagen jetzt ausschlachten, ja. Und eben nicht so mal als Randnotiz nur erwähnt lassen und so weiter und so fort. Aber ja, ich hab, hatte ja schon, weiß nicht, hab ich glaube ich hier in dem Podcast auch schon ein paar Mal gesagt oder so. Ich würde mir ja wünschen, dass jetzt halt auch so die Politiker einfach mehr und mehr diese Auswirkungen am eigenen Leib zu spüren bekommen und alle schmutzige Wäsche, die die jemals gewaschen haben und jede Spendenaffäre und jeder komische Krummel, die einfach so da nach oben bubbelt, nach und nach. Dass dann sozusagen die halt auch mal merken, was das eigentlich so für reale Auswirkungen haben kann, aber bis jetzt ist es noch nicht passiert.
Ja, ich frage mich auch, wann denn da eigentlich mal irgendwas einsetzt bei denen. Das ist für mich ein totales Rätsel. Jetzt auch diese Nummer mit dem Guardian. Also das ist schon...
Also ich hab jetzt schon harte...
Da kommen wirklich die Jungs und sagen Guten Tag, wir sind hier um ihre Laptops zu schrillern.
Also ich muss auch ehrlich sagen, also USA und das British Empire sind so zwei Länder, wo ich echt ungern eigentlich jetzt noch einreisen will. So einfach so gefühlt so vom Bauchgefühl. Da fühle ich mich irgendwie nicht mehr so richtig.
Ja, was meinst du, wie ungern ich da Mitglied bin in dem Club? Das ist wirklich, irgendwann werde ich dafür nochmal Haftbar gemacht.
Aber die Briten sind da aber auch krass drauf. Also ich meine, das sind ja die, die auch diese ganzen Überwachungskameras aufgebaut haben, wie die Bekloppten.
Das ist das durcheste Volk überhaupt. Also die sind wirklich noch, die sind wirklich nochmal...
Aber woher kommt das? Also ich meine, du hast da wahrscheinlich auch keine Erklärung.
Insel, Inzucht.
Naja, ist ja, ich mein... Naja, ich will da jetzt nicht drauf rumreiten, aber es ist so, keine Ahnung, ich hab auch schon vor langer Zeit aufgehört, dieses Land einfach nachvollziehen zu können. Wenn ich es jemals hab nachvollziehen können. Was drehst du drauf? Also denen fehlt, denen fehlt irgendwas. Und zwar...
Wahrscheinlich fehlt denen, dass sie, dass sie noch eine Weltmacht sind.
das treibt sie da eher an. Jaja, also das ist, sagen wir mal, dieses... Ja, natürlich muss doch unser Geheimdienst alles wissen, damit wir die Welt noch unter Kontrolle haben, damit unser Empire nicht zusammenfällt.
Jaja, aber das gibt's ja nicht mehr.
Nein, das gibt's nicht, aber... They didn't read the memo.
So gesehen kann man eigentlich... Also, jetzt mal abgesehen davon, dass jetzt hier der Zweite Weltkrieg durchaus nicht als positives Ereignisfest ist, aber so für Deutschland sozusagen, dieses reinigende Gewitter so, dass hier mal irgendwie alle mal festgestellt haben, ach ja, vielleicht sollte man jetzt noch mal kurz nachdenken, wie wir das eigentlich alles machen wollen. Neue Verfassung, alles so mal ein Reset. Ich wär sowieso dafür, die Idee ist mir letztens gekommen, dass du so als Land einfach alle 50 Jahre oder was auch immer, oder 100, machst du so, guckst du dir mal an, so was war jetzt die letzten 50, 100 Jahre irgendwie, wir machen jetzt mal ein Reset, wir starten noch mal von scratch, setzen ein paar schlaue Leute hin und passen das mal alles an, die heutige Zeit nochmal an.
Alle kriegen 100 Mark Begrüßungsgeld und dann geht's los.
Überleg mal, so die ganzen anderen Länder, die jetzt nicht so das hatten, jetzt so einen kürzlich Reset, was die auch noch so für alten Mustern und was sich da für Gesetzesberge halt auch angehäuft haben. Da gibt es ja auch dieses Buch, was jetzt irgendwie auch mal immer wieder zur Sprache kam, dieses Seven Felonies a Day, hat irgendwie so ein S-Typie geschrieben, wo halt im Prinzip drin steht, dass jeder Bürger jeden Tag sieben Gesetze bricht, irgendeine Felony. Und es ist halt so, weil über die Jahrzehnte und Jahrhunderte sammeln sich halt so die absurdesten Gesetze, so wie du darfst keine Esel in der Badewanne waschen oder irgendwie. Die halt nicht irgendwie verfolgt werden, die aber immer noch irgendwelchen Texten stehen und wenn du halt einem was anhängen willst, dann findest du halt auch immer was sozusagen. Und ja, das ist natürlich dann auch nicht schön.
Nee, das ist nicht schön.
Das ist nicht schön, nee, nee. Deswegen so ein Reset wäre eigentlich total toll. Aber ja, wer weiß was sie dann für Ideen da reinschreiben, das kann ja auch wieder sein.
Aber ich meine, die Bedingungen, unter denen dieser Reset in Deutschland dann überhaupt erst möglich geworden ist, die wünsche ich jetzt eigentlich keinem so richtig an die Backe.
Das ist natürlich eine utopische Vorstellung, aber es wäre, mir kommt es halt tatsächlich so ein bisschen sinnvoll vor, aber naja. Das ist ja eigentlich auch so, dass auch so eines dieser Probleme, was halt auch viele Leute dann immer so vergessen, wenn sie sagen, ich hab ja nichts zu verbergen und so. Das Ding ist ja, wenn halt die ganzen Daten erfasst sind, jetzt sind die vielleicht noch nicht strafbar, aber wenn sich dann halt irgendwelche Gesetze ändern oder irgendwelche Regelungen und so weiter und so fort und dein ganzer permanent record auf alles, was du jemals getan hast, ist halt vorrätig und du willst irgendjemanden was anhängen, mundtot machen oder diskreditieren, dann hast du halt einfach so die Daten schon da und kannst dann sagen, ja ist jetzt hier, guck mal, ist jetzt nicht mehr erlaubt. Und hier gab es auch diesen schönen Spruch eigentlich vom CCC, den ich immer ganz nett fand, so, wo Daten gesammelt werden, dann werden sie auch missbraucht, früher oder später, also das Bessere wäre eigentlich so zu...
Oder wie Pfeife sagt, wo ein Trog ist, da kommen die Schweine.
Das fand ich eigentlich auch immer sehr schön. Ja, genau so.
Aber so dieses Prinzip halt, was auch der CCC immer so ein bisschen geprägt hat, so einfach eher Datensparsamkeit, also wirklich nur das minimale Set, was man wirklich braucht, eher aufzuheben, um halt auch diesen Missbrauch vorzubeugen.
Das habe ich ja letztes Mal schon gesagt, also ich glaube, der Zug ist aus der Halle. Der Kampf ist gekämpft, also mit Datensparsamkeit ist jetzt kein Schuh mehr zu gewinnen. Naja, ist doch so. Also ich meine, die Daten fallen an. Wir haben die Technologie gebaut, um all diese Daten anfallen zu lassen. Und das war's jetzt.
Die Geister, die ich rief.
Die Geister, die ich rief. Man muss jetzt gucken, wie kriegt man denn das jetzt unter Kontrolle? Diese Asymetrie zwischen dem Staat, jetzt mal ganz allgemein gesprochen, der viele Daten hat und dem Bürger, der nicht genau weiß, was über ihn gespeichert ist und der so Angst hat, dass es ihn jederzeit irgendwie treffen könnte. Ich glaube, das ist halt auch so eine Sache für die Juristen, die sich mal überlegen müssen, wie geht man denn damit um? Also früher war es halt so, da hast du halt Dinge gemacht, die konnten nicht verfolgt werden, weil sie dir nicht nachgewiesen werden konnten.
Jetzt, weil sie es dir auffanden, es dir nachzuweisen, wäre Quatsch gewesen.
Wäre exorbitant gewesen und heutzutage kann man dir aber ziemlich viel nachweisen. Da ist aber irgendwie die Gesetzgebung nicht hinterher, weil ja.
Wahrscheinlich könnte man mittlerweile jeder Manns Leben jederzeit ruinieren.
Wahrscheinlich schon.
Zumindest ausreichend aus dem Tritt bringen, dass es irgendwie alles keinen Spaß mehr macht. Tja, 32 Jahre her ist das. Das Kraftwerk Sang, Interpol und Deutsche Bank, FBI und Scotland Yard, Finanzamt und das BKA haben unsere Daten da. 32 Jahre ist das her.
Die hatten die NSA noch nicht auf dem Plan und dieses GCHQ, oder wie heißt das?
Scotland Yard, glaube ich, zählt da schon mal ganz gut.
Bisschen schon. Ich erinnere mich halt so nochmal an die frühen Tage, als ich so beim GCHT war, da gab es halt immer so Sprüche wie öffentliche Daten nützen, private Daten schützen oder der Staat sollte so transparent wie möglich gegen Bürger gegenüber sein und die Privatsphäre des Bürgers möglichst intransparent gegenüber dem Staat und so. Und solche Grundsätze... Die maschinenlesbare Regierung. Die klingen jetzt immer noch so ein bisschen im Hinterkopf nach, weil das ja eigentlich so an sich...
Ja, keine Ahnung, vielleicht muss man...
Der schönere Ansatz wäre, aber naja.
Muss man zu solchen Regelungen kommen wie, wenn jemand Daten über mich sammelt, dann muss er mir halt auch sagen, was es ist, was er von mir sammelt und wenn er die Daten aber, die er über mich gesammelt hat, gegen mich verwendet, dann kann ich ihn dafür verhaftbar machen. In beliebiger Art und Weise, oder so, keine Ahnung. Weißt du, so eine Art GAUK-Behörde für halt das, was die NSL so macht, ne?
Das GAUK, der richtige Bezeichner ist an der Stelle.
Ich sag ja GAUK-Behörde, das ja, über GAUK möchte ich jetzt eigentlich nicht reden. Aber so, keine Ahnung. Ich finde, da muss man irgendwie nach vorne gucken und sich fragen, wie kommt man eigentlich aus dieser Krise wieder raus. Weil den Ist-Zustand konstatieren, das ist zwar irgendwie lustig.
Naja, du, da machen ja erstmal schon erschreckend wenig Leute mit sowieso beim Ist-Zustand.
Ja, trotzdem finde ich das irgendwie, keine Ahnung. Wir haben jetzt alle irgendwie mehrere Wochen gelitten, im Ist-Zustand konstatieren, jetzt wird es langsam langweilig. Und wir müssen uns jetzt überlegen, was wollen wir denn als nächstes fordern, damit dieser Ist-Zustand halt irgendwie erträglich wird?
Ja, ich fordere, dass ich Brummfondl heiße.
Brummfondl? Was für ein Film war das jetzt wieder?
Ich bin ja unbelesen, ich kann nur ein Buch zitieren, von daher zitiere ich eigentlich immer das gleiche, aber es ist so reichhaltig, dass ich das Gefühl habe, es reicht bis zum Ende der Tage.
Was war denn Brummfondl nochmal?
Der gute Douglas.
Ja, aber wie war die? Habe ich schon wieder vergessen. Es ist mal wieder Zeit, Hitchhiker's Guide to the Galaxy zu lesen.
Bei mir ist es jetzt auch ein paar Jahrzehntchen her.
Ja, das sind diese ursprünglichen Programmierer von Deep Thought.
Ah, hieß das in Englisch auch so?
Weiß ich nicht.
Hast du das auf Deutsch gelesen?
Deep Thought hieß Deep Thought, natürlich.
Nee, aber Bromfondel?
Ist egal. Vielleicht habe ich es auch nur schlecht transferiert, ist auch wirklich Wurst, aber die Forderung bleibt trotzdem aufrecht.
Haben wir also auch wieder...
Jetzt haben wir schon wieder darüber geredet.
Jetzt haben wir das schon wieder darüber geredet, ja.
Ich versuche gerade ein bisschen parallel unsere Themen zu sortieren.
Mach doch mal was Technisches.
Jaja, das wird schon die ganze Zeit mit Computern und so vorgeworfen.
Ich versuche gerade noch mal so meine alten Sachen. Sprich.
Du warst auf einem Segelschiff?
Ja, genau.
Mit Nerds?
Nicht nur, aber die Elisa, die da mit diesem Segelboot umherfährt, die das von ihrem Vater geerbt hat und da um Sizilien, Malta, griechische Inseln im Sommer die ganze Zeit rumsegelt.
Die Elisa?
Unsere.
Der Vater hatte so ein Segelboot, das liegt da in Sizilien, und dann hat er da immer so Freunde und Bekannte mit rumgeschippert und den Liegeplatz damit finanziert, über den Rest des Jahres und Reparaturen und was auch immer. Und jetzt macht sie das mit ihrer Schwester weiter. Und verbringt da dann Monate einfach im Sommer da unten auf dem Boot. Und hat so wochenweise halt so Freunde, Bekannte, Freunde von Freunden oder auch manchmal random Strangers da für eine Woche auf diesem Boot. Und da kann man sich auch einmieten. Die machen das glaube ich dieses Jahr noch bis Oktober. Ich weiß aber nicht, ob da jetzt noch Plätze frei sind. Also für nächstes Jahr kann sich das mal der eine oder andere Nerd überlegen. Oder auch nicht, das war nämlich tatsächlich einer der besten Urlaube, die ich so bisher hatte, wenn man halt Bock auf draußen und maximale Entspannung und amtliche Szenerie hat sozusagen. Sind da halt um Sizilien rum gesegelt, sind an aktive Vulkane quasi angedockt und haben dem Lava-Spektakel in der Nacht zugeschaut und so irgendwie mitten im Meer, Kilometer von der Küste entfernt, planchen gegangen, sag ich mal, mit Delfinenbegleitung und dem Ganzen, alles, was man sich so vorstellt. Auch Boot, 50 Grad im Wasser und ordentlich Schmackes irgendwie durchs Wasserpeitschen. War richtig gut.
Auch über der Rehling gehangen?
Nee, ich hab's, also einmal wurde mir ein bisschen übel, aber es hat, ich hab's überlebt und ich musste nicht brechen. Aber der Skipper meinte, er hat schon alles gesehen, es haben auch schon Leute im Hafenbecken schon gekotzt von den leichten Schwingungen, die da so durch die Wellen passieren. Und meistens ist es aber immer nur einmal und dann haben sie sich dann auch wieder beruhigt. Der Magen kennt das dann. Ich guck grad mal, ob es die Seite gibt. Die haben nämlich eine Webseite, wo man sich auch über das Boot ein bisschen... Matenka heißt das? Jetzt findet ihr das hier nicht. Ach, scheiß Facebook. Ach, das ist Polnisch natürlich. SV Matenka, genau, jachtmatenka.com. Aber ich glaube, das ist noch die alte Webseite. Die ist nämlich nur auf Polnisch, wenn ich mich richtig entsinne. Aber da sieht man mal das Boot. Ich paste das mal in den Chat. Lange Rede, gar keinen Sinn. Ihr könnt da auch mitfahren. Es gibt auch ein Flickr-Fotoset. Warte mal, ach, jetzt bin ich hier ganz... Ach, wir haben jetzt einen neuen Channel auch, ne? Freak Show, da bin ich noch gar nicht.
Bist du im falschen Chat oder was?
Bin ich im falschen Chat?
Alter, Moment. Slash-Join, so war das.
Auch schuldig für den Alltag.
Sagst du mal, sind sie im falschen Chat oder was?
Hier gibt es mal ein Fotoset auf Flickr, wo ich mal ein paar Bilder von mir sozusagen reingepastet habe. Da könnt ihr euch mal angucken, wie hübsch das alles aussieht.
Alter, du bist so post-privacy-mäßig.
Ich mache halt auch so ein bisschen Werbung für ihr kleines Unternehmen. Sie musste ja auch das Boot und die Reparaturen und alles finanzieren. Das war halt ein echt cooler Urlaub. Und man ist da schon mit sehr entspannten Leuten unterwegs. Und das kann man einfach mal machen. War jetzt auch nicht teuer. Wer weiß, wie viel es nächstes Jahr kostet, aber ich habe 250 Euro für eine Woche und dann noch Verpflegung bezahlt. Und das hat sich auf jeden Fall vollkommen gelohnt.
Oh, korrekt aus.
Da gibt es hier rechts dieses dunkle Foto, da ich versucht, mit meinem iPhone digital an den Lava-Ausbruch zu zoomen. Der Vulkan Stromboli spuckt alle 15 bis 30 Minuten ein bisschen Lava raus und es fällt dann auf der einen Seite runter und man kann dann in 1 km Entfernung von der Küste zu gucken, wie das da so runter... Also, wer mal segeln will... Genau, ich habe auch Geoinformation ins Flickr reingepumpt bekommen, nach Langen suchen, das heißt, ihr könnt doch unten dann irgendwo auf der Karte gucken. Ich glaube, du musst runter scrollen oder so. Da ist dein Stromboli da.
Ist die Exif-Info reicht nicht?
Ich glaube nicht. Nee, nee, in der Exif-Info steht das nämlich nicht drin. Ah, da kann ich gleich noch zu iPhoto und diesem ganzen Kram was erzählen.
Also, es steht schon drin, aber man kriegt es nicht gemapped mal eben so.
Wenn du zurückgehst und unter das Foto scrollst noch ein Stück, dann gibts da Scrolls, Scrolls, Scrolls. Sissel, nee, warte, irgendwo, genau, Castella, Mar del Golfo und wenn du da drauf klickst, dann kriegst du die Map.
Und man kann nicht mal eben eine Map mit all diesen Fotos im Set oder so.
Flicker, Yahoo, Maps und so, ne.
Das war hinterfällig für mich auch so ein bisschen scary.
Und langsam ist es auch, ach Gott, genau.
Und wenn man rauszoomt, dann sieht man auch die anderen Punkte und so. Ja, also, die müssten das echt wirklich von diesem ganzen Yahoo-Interface wegkrempeln, dann wäre das Flicker eigentlich ganz schön. Aber naja, wie dem auch sei, 290 Seemeilen sind wir gefahren. Ach, die anderen Punkte zeigt er jetzt doch nicht, oder was? Na ja, gut, könnt ihr euch selber durchklicken auf den Bildern. Ja, das war's dann eigentlich auch schon. Ach nee, hier eine wichtige Frage. Netzemfang auf dem Boot. Wir hatten die meiste Zeit Internet, tatsächlich. Weil auf dem Meer, also wenn man so ein paar Kilometer oder Seemeilen von der Küste entfernt ist, GSM 3G ging immer, tatsächlich. Also wir waren einmal genau zwischen Stromboli oder Stromboli und den Sizilianischen Inseln. Und haben also kurze Zeit von keiner Seite Land gesehen. Und da gab es kein Internet, aber der Skip war trotzdem eine SMS bekommen. Aber man fährt ja immer so doch in Küsteny oder dockt mal wieder an und es gibt immer mal wieder Internet so für Twitter, Facebook, E-Mail, den ganzen Kram reicht das locker. Nee, ich hab am Flughafen, hat die Telekom mir gesagt, ach übrigens wir haben jetzt gerade Urlaubsgeschenk, so dieses Weekpack einmal gratis. Du kriegst 150 Megabyte für eine Woche kostenlos. Normalerweise kostet es halt 5 Euro noch irgendwas.
50 Euro, 150 Megabyte für eine Woche?
Ja, du kannst halt immer, normalerweise, normalerweise...
Wo soll ich den Vormittag mit hin?
Ich weiß, aber normalerweise... Die Leitung in dem Fall war halt eh nicht so schnell. Also du hattest zwar 3G, aber es ist halt auch Telekom Italia, weißt du, die haben halt keine Kapazitäten, nichts. Das ist ja da egal, selbst wenn du mitten in der Stadt bist... Also die Italiener, ich hab da auch gemerkt, warum in Italien das mit der IT nicht so ist. Ist einfach zu schön da, kümmert keinen.
Zu warm.
Ja, so weißt du, da ist halt einer mit dem Motorroller, wir so waren so gerade auf diesem Vulkan im kleinen Dorf und haben eingekauft und gehen so eine kleine, schmale, steile Straße den Vulkan runter und kommt so von hinten, so ein Motorscooter und macht so, mimi, guck mal so und der fährt halt einhändig, so mit Sonnenbrille und entspannt und dann fährt er so vorbei und ich sehe, warum er einhändig fährt, weil er in der linken Hand einen Espresso-Shot hat, während er so den Vulkan runter scootet so mit seinem Scooter und da wird einem halt klar, ja irgendwie ist den total schnuppe, was mit diesem Internet ist.
Oh je, da müssen wir gleich noch dieode dazuspielen hier.
Okay, reicht.
Wisst ihr nicht, was das ist?
Das ist Kanaltelemedial.
Sagt euch nichts?
Nee. Hornauer? Der Typ hat eine Oberscheibe, der macht so ESO-TV irgendwie. Irgendwie mit Borno und ESO. Macht ja irgendwie so seine Kohle, zieht die Leute an den Tisch. Das ist ein völlig verstörter, notorischer Kerl und such einfach mal nach Hornauer-Interview irgendwie auf dem Netz und bin dich aber vorher fest, weil es einfach... Das sind so Menschen, die versteht man nicht.
Aber das ist so, das hatte ich jetzt hier gerade noch am NSFW.
Roddy ist geschockt.
Aber nochmal kurz...
Heute entgleitet uns die Sendung, habe ich das Gefühl. Aber ist okay.
Aber um nochmal kurz darauf zurückzukommen, also ist jetzt auch nicht grundlos, dass ich sage, die Elisa, die hat ja auch mal beim Amsics gearbeitet und hat so mit Peering und es gibt ja auch ein Podcast hier im Chaos...
Wollte ich gerade plagen. CRE144, die Internetwolke ist mit Elisa.
Und die hat ja sozusagen Hands-on- Erfahrungen und die hat gemeint, die Telekom Italienetze, die sind halt alle ausgelastet und die kümmern sich nicht um neue Kapazitäten und egal, wie gut dein Empfang ist, egal, wie dick deine DSL-Leitung ist, du kommst halt nicht schneller in die Welt rein oder raus. Und das merkst du da halt auch. Und deswegen, wie gesagt, für alle textbasierten Dienste und auch für ein bisschen Facebooken und Bildposten und so, dafür reicht das alle mal. Und ich hatte eigentlich die ganze Zeit Internet, aber man ist halt auch auf dem Meer und am Segeln und am Baden und am Chillen und am Essen und am Genießen, deswegen war das mit dem Internet auch gar nicht so oft.
Das ist bei Jamaikaner nicht viel anders. Man muss die Elisa wohl mal CAE 166 hören, weil da geht es ja um dieses Thema, so Nerd aufs Segelboot, der Segelpodcast und auch diese Fragestellung von wie kriege ich Internet auf dem Ozean?
Genau. Sie will ja auch Atlantik-Überquerungen ein paar Jahren machen. Aber du kannst ja mal nächstes Jahr mit deinem Podcast-Equipment quasi auf das Boot reisen, dann machst du da quasi Hands-on-Podcast auf dem Boot. In einer einsamen Lagune.
Genau, und vier Wochen später ist dann auch schon die erste Minute hochgeladen.
Also vermutlich.
Das war halt echt ganz witzig, weil da war ein Typ, so ein amerikanischer Hacker, und der musste noch ganz dringend, bevor es losgeht, musste der halt noch so eine Präsentation hochladen, die er halt auf der Omen nicht geschafft hat, fertig hochzuladen, was auch immer. Und dann war halt das Internet gerade, wo er ankam, immer sehr schmal und wir sind auch schon losgefahren und dann musste er mal warten bis zum nächsten Ort. Dann waren wir halt an dem ersten Vulkan, Vulcano heißt der einfach nur, kommt so ein bisschen Schwefel oben raus, ganz putzig. Und in der Lagune Netz 3G furchtbar. Und es war langsam. Und dann mein ich so, ja okay, weil er halt, er musste das rausschicken, mein ich so, okay, wir können jetzt hier mit dem Schlauchboot einfach, ich fahr dich mal kurz an Lanter zu dem Café und so weiter, vielleicht haben die ja so richtiges Internet. Dann hatten die noch WLAN, aber es war halt genauso schnell wie das 3G und neun. Also deswegen, man muss da schon seine Erwartungen ein bisschen runterschrauben, wenn man da so um die, durch die Gegend segelt, aber es geht. Man ist nicht ganz abgeschnitten. Nerds on a Boat.
Nerds on a Boat.
Es gibt ja auch das Nerdboot, ne? Macht da nicht FH irgendwie sowas hier, so mit so einem großen Dreimaster oder so, zwei Tage rumsegeln und Lightning Talks und so.
Ich weiß von nichts, aber ich würd's ihm dazu trauen.
Ich hab das gesehen, war noch mal Nerdboot, Nerds on a Boat, irgendwie sowas. Egal, könnt ihr ja immer selber googeln und in den Chat posten, wenn's euch begegnet. Irgendwie gab's da was. Ja, so viel zum Bootfahren.
Genau. Wir sollten mehr über...
Ja, was eigentlich?
Ja, was eigentlich? Wir haben ja noch so einiges, vielleicht die allgemeinen Debatten. Wir können uns ja mal so ein bisschen hier dem aktuellen Frischobst-Universum zuwenden. Wir haben schon so lange nicht mehr darüber geredet.
Wie hießen die nochmal?
Zwei Wochen schon nicht.
Irgendwas mit Obst. Nun gibt's ja wohl relative Klarheit darüber, wann hier der nächste iPhone-Zyklus durchrauscht.
Zumindest, wann er angekündigt wird.
Ja, aber dann wird's wahrscheinlich auch schon schnell anfangen loszugehen. Also ich kann mir zumindest nicht vorstellen, dass sie sich noch sehr viel Zeit lassen.
Wahrscheinlich nicht, nee.
Also die Ankündigung gibt's noch gar nicht. Es gibt nur bestätigte, also von Apple unbestätigte, aber von anderen Leuten, die gerne bestätigen. Selten danebenliegenden Quellen, bestätigte Termine der 10. September.
Der 10. September, ja. Jetzt kommt wieder die Kalendertechnik ins Spiel.
Na, mein fantastiker ist hier sofort am Start und sagt dir, welcher, welcher? Zehntag?
Ist ein Dienstag, ja.
Ja, und ja, hätten ja auch am Mittwoch nehmen können, haben sich wieder nicht getraut.
Am 11. September?
Na ja, gut. Ich meine, die Frage ist natürlich jetzt, was kommt. Und ich find mittlerweile so diese Gerüchtelage, die sich so verdichtet, find ich so halbwegs plausibel. Also ich will nicht sagen, so wird's kommen, aber ich find das zumindest so nachvollziehbar. Also, ich muss mal kurz zusammenfassen, darf ich meinen Worten? Also ich denke, was so derzeit der Straßenkonsens ist, es wird ein neues iPhone geben.
Es wird zwei neue iPhones geben.
Es heißen, dann wird's das alte iPhone 5 weiterhin geben und dann wird's vielleicht noch ein zusätzliches iPhone 5c geben, was quasi das iPhone 4S ablöst. Und das 4 wäre wahrscheinlich sowieso abgelöst worden. Und dann gibt's irgendwie sozusagen so einen anderen Entry-Level für das iPhone.
Ja, irgendwie in Farbe, ne? Irgendwie wurden da mehrere verschiedene Farben gehandelt. Also ich hab Fotos von gelben Brückcovers gesehen und irgendwie ein blaues und so ein Zeug.
Kann sein.
Man munkelt ja, das C steht dann für Color.
Oder Consume.
Oder für weniger als S, ja. Ja, keine Ahnung, was das C heißt. Heißt halt C, sind halt so Buchstaben.
S-Klasse, C-Klasse.
Ja, also ich kann mir das irgendwie ganz gut vorstellen. Die eigentliche Frage ist natürlich, was bauen Sie jetzt bitte in dieses neue Telefon ein, was mich dazu bringt, sofort auf den Kaufbutton zu klicken. Und eigentlich gibt's gar nicht so viel, was mich jetzt...
Also gerüchtet wird ja so eine 8-Megapixel-Kamera, die ganz toll sein soll. Und gerüchtet wird der Fingerprint-Sensor, wo man halt nochmal Stirn runzeln kann, wenn man denn will. Na ja, so quasi statt kurz drückst du halt mit deinem Daumen auf den Homebutton und dann erkennt dein Telefon deinen Daumen und entsperrt oder so.
Ja, aber dieser Button ist doch viel, viel, viel kleiner als ein Daumen.
Ich sag ja nur, was gerüchtet wird. Ich sag ja nicht, dass das sinnvoll ist, was die Leute da draußen behaupten.
Also Kamera geht immer besser. Das ist auf jeden Fall, da wird sich keiner beschweren. Also ich hab jetzt hier mit dem iPhone 5 hatte ich jetzt ja das erste Mal wirklich so Fotos eigentlich gemacht. Ich mach ja nicht so viele Fotos mit meinem Telefon. Aber das hat sich ganz gut bewährt, könnte aber...
Könnte noch besser sein.
Könnte immer noch besser sein.
Könnte vor allem noch im Dunkeln noch mal viel besser sein.
Ja, sehr viel besser.
Aber ist auch bisher immer schon sehr viel besser geworden. Ansonsten, ich interessiere mich eigentlich nur für einen Feature wirklich. Und das ist, dass der Lightning-Connector besser hält und dass das Teil einfach mal doppelt so viel Akku-Laufzeit hat.
Wasserdicht fände ich ganz schick. So aus eigener Erfahrung denke ich mir, das wäre gar nicht schlecht.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das überhaupt erzielbar wäre.
Vielleicht nicht so häufig in den Fluss schmeißen.
Aber Elisa hatte ihr iPhone die ganze Zeit in so einer etwas dickeren Hülle als du jetzt hast und komplett umschlossen. Und dann konnte man auch noch durchtouchen, weil ihr oder...
Ich weiß nicht... Wasserdicht.
Genau, die kann ja mal da am Ufer auch beim Aussteigen nochmal ins Wasser fallen und dann hält's wohl auch.
Hilft aber nur, wenn's auch schwimmt, weil sonst ist es trotzdem weg.
Beziehungsweise, wenn's halt in so seichtem Wasser passiert. Also klar, wenn du da irgendwie auf dem Ozean nur zwei Kilometer tief bist, dann...
Meine Erfahrung ist, dass ein halber Meter tiefes Wasser einen schon vor ganz schöne Probleme stellen kann, es wiederzufinden. Also ich hab so, naja, gefühlt eine halbe Stunde, aber es waren wahrscheinlich real fünf bis zehn Minuten gebraucht, um das iPhone wiederzufinden. Ja, in der Ufergemenge Lage zwischen dem Schilf und dem... Das Wasser war halt trüb. Ja, aber... Die Sicht drei Zentimeter.
Aber im Mittelmeer, da kannst du ja... Da siehst du ja alles.
Na ja, war ja nur so eine Idee, dass mit dem Wasser dicht kommt, bestimmt nicht, aber...
Ja, das ist klar, immer. Hier mit der iOS-Beta, die ersten Meters, irgendwie hatte ich so den Eindruck, oder die letzten jetzt, die vorletzte oder so, da irgendwie gegen meinen Akku, da konntest du zugucken, wie der auch beim Nichtstun einfach so weggelud.
Also jetzt die neueren sind okay.
Genau, jetzt die letzte.
Die allererste war ja eine Superkatastrophe.
Aber ich weiß nicht so, die vorletzte oder so, da war das auch immer noch so, dass irgendwie meine Batterie extrem schnell leer ging. Ich dachte schon, ist jetzt mein Akku irgendwie am Ende oder so, muss ich den jetzt schon tauschen lassen? Oh Gott, oh Gott! Und jetzt so mit der letzten oder vorletzten ging es dann los, dass jetzt mal wieder so ein Tag auch mal hält oder ein bisschen mehr vielleicht.
Die letzte Beta, der war irgendwie nur 16 Megabyte groß. Irgendwie und dann irgendwas mit Shop und Musik aus dem iTunes Store runterladen und so weiter. Das fand ich sehr strange. Vor allen Dingen musste man dann so ein komisches Profil runterladen. Und installieren, dann hast du in den Preferences einen zusätzlichen Button bekommen. Wo dann drauf stand, jetzt die iTunes Bibliothek löschen. Dann drückst du da einmal drauf, dann ist die weg und dann machst du einen Neustart und dann hast du geupdatet. Irgendwie das war sehr strange. Du, keine Ahnung. Vielleicht haben sie ihr DRM auf...
Ich hab noch gar nicht die 6. Gerade mach ich mein Telefon an, dann kommt Beta 6, ist now available.
Beta 6, Beta 7, keine Ahnung. Vielleicht kommt auch gerade irgendwie eine neue Beta. Aber die letzte Beta, das fand ich ein bisschen strange. Vielleicht haben sie auch das DRM irgendwie auf einen neuen Level gehoben und haben das aber kurz vorher noch gemacht, um es noch zu testen oder so. Ich weiß es nicht, also... Naja, nee, Software auf dem aktuellen Stand. Also so richtig viel kann man dazu nicht sagen. Ich fand das interessant, dass sie zumindest in der Telefonumgebung jetzt mal Buttons hatten. Aber das hatten sie glaube ich schon, da haben wir schon letztes Mal drüber geredet, dass sie irgendwie...
Ach so, dass sie jetzt so Ringe um diese frei fliegenden Icons gemacht haben.
Erstens Ringe um die frei fliegenden Icons und zweitens mal so dieses, ich habe hier nur einen großen roten Balken, wo ich dann swipen muss. Den haben sie halt kleiner gemacht und abgerundet und sieht halt jetzt wie ein Button aus. Und nicht mehr so große Flächen, sondern es sieht halt irgendwie aus wie ein Button. Also es ist wirklich nur in der Telefonoberfläche. Woanders gibt es noch keine Button, aber es ist so der erste Dammbruch, habe ich das Gefühl. Der Button kommt doch noch. Ich sag's dir, der Button kommt doch noch.
Ich glaube auch, der Button ist noch nicht tot.
Revenge of the Button. Ja, ja, Designer Flowers ergänzt Zombie-Buttons.
Ja, und ich meine manchmal, ich meine, Oepel hat ja immer schon so ein bisschen versucht, designmäßig so ein bisschen mit dem Kopf durch die Tür.
Genau, und dann haben sie so im Schneckentempo zurückgerudert.
Ich meine, überleg mal, wie Mac OS 10 am Anfang aussah. Pinstripes.
Pinstripes und diese aufgesetzten Biene-Maija-Tautropfen auf der Blüte-Mattens.
Ja, genau, das war schon so ein bisschen creepy auch teilweise.
Wenn man heutzutage Bilder davon sieht, dann glaubt man nicht, dass man das benutzt hat.
10.0 hat man auch nicht benutzt.
Ich hatte direkt die Beta drauf gemacht. Da gab es so eine Developer-Beta, die konnte man offiziell kaufen. Und die hatte irgendwie dieses absurde Feature, das sie extrem schnell in den Sleep-Modus gegangen ist. Aber eigentlich auch nur, weil der Sleep-Modus kein Sleep-Modus war, sondern nur den Bildschirm dunkel gemacht hat. Also da war der halt da, bevor du aufklappen konntest.
Ja, aber das war's dann also auch schon mit den, ja, das ist schwer, ne? Also eigentlich bin ich auch mit dem iPhone 5...
Na, ich hab ja noch keine iPhone 5. Ich hör von allen immer nur, dass sie sich darüber beschweren, dass irgendwie das Gehäuse so leicht Kratzer bekommt und Dellen und so weiter.
Das ist halt ein Gebrauchsgegenstand. Also ich hab ja damit kein Problem. Ich stell mir das ja nicht ins Regal irgendwie.
Also ich würde mir zutrauen, mit dem iPhone 4 Essen Bier aufzumachen, aber mit dem iPhone 5 würde ich es glaube ich lieber nicht probieren.
Also kratzermäßig, das finde ich auch schon problematisch. Ich hab Meins, wo ich die ganze Zeit im Gummi schlüpfe und das hat Kratzer. Also es ist einfach, wenn es mal runterfällt, dann...
Na ja gut, ich meine, Meins ist jetzt außer Konkurrenz, weil es jetzt nur ein paar Wochen alt ist, aber...
Ja, aber ich muss sagen, ich finde zwar das 5er schick und ich finde es auch auf jeden Fall das zu bevorzugende iPhone einfach von Speed und Bildschirmgröße und besserer Button und einfach besser, so. Nur dieses Dirtiness, diese unglaubliche...
Robustizität.
Robustizität, genau. Die sehr fluppiglich ist. Die gefällt mir einfach. Ich fand, muss sagen, also als ich dieses iPhone 4 das erste Mal gesehen habe, das war für mich ein richtiger Design-Schock. Weil da hab ich, und zwar nicht so ein Design-Schock wie iOS 7, sondern so ein... Schock ist nicht das richtige Wort.
Wow, ein Design-Wow.
Ja, genau, es war so ein Design-Wow. Also so dieses dunkle Glas, das nennt man ja so for granted jetzt irgendwie, aber alles so dunkles Glas und dann dieser Stahlbügel da drumherum. Das ist einfach, ja, also einfach allein schon dieser Mix der Materialien, geil. Fand ich einfach geil. Und da ist so das neue Ding, das zwar irgendwie okay, so ja, und es sieht auch nett aus, so, aber dann, was haben sie sich da ein abgemeiert da mit ihren spiegelnden Kanten und so? Macht da halt dann so einen Gummi-Schlüpfer drum und dann seh ich das halt auch eh nicht mehr. Von daher ist das auch eigentlich irgendwie Schnurz. Wahrscheinlich könnte ich sogar mit einem 5C leben. Nur, dass es wahrscheinlich irgendein tolles Feature nicht hat.
Ja, oder ein langsamer Prozessor oder was weiß ich nicht.
Ich hätte bloß ganz gerne mal wieder ein Telefon, das eine Woche hält. Ich weiß, da sind wir noch weit von entfernt. Aber mal ehrlich, wenn du irgendwie aus der Tür rausgehst und du benutzt das Teil die ganze Zeit, das hält doch keinen halben Tag.
Weißt du, wann du das bekommst? Wenn die ganze Smartphone-Welle durch ist und der nächste heiße Scheiß ist nicht mehr das Telefon, sondern das Smartphone ist jetzt auf dem Laptop-Status. Weißt du, so wie hier, Laptops sind jetzt, da passiert jetzt nicht mehr so viel, da kann jetzt Apple anfangen, mal Batterielaufzeit anzubauen.
Also, wir haben halt jetzt den Is-Zustand, das wird immer kleiner und deswegen ist mehr Platz für die Batterie.
Ja, aber solange der Markt so heiß umkämpft ist und jeder den heißesten Scheiß haben will, fällt die Batterielaufzeit hinten immer wieder runter. Und wenn das vorbei ist...
Das ist nie vorbei, der heißeste Scheiß wollt immer alle haben.
Ja, nur wenn sich der Markt auf was anderes konzentriert, was weiß ich, Variables um Handgelenk oder auf der Nase oder so. Keine Ahnung, was da alles so Schlimmes kommen soll und wird.
Hier so ein kleines Ding, was durch die Hese auf die Nase sitzt, so eine kleine Nasenklammer, die dir in die Retina dann so Head-Up-Display-Google-Glass-Information reinprojiziert. Das ist das nächste Ding.
Augmentierte Realität.
Genau, das hat dann die Batterielaufzeit, wo du sagst, ja, früher unsere Telefone, die haben noch eine Woche gehalten. Aber das Nasenfahrrad ist nach zwei Stunden alle.
Augmented Reality, das ist doch das, was unsere Bundesregierung gerade macht.
Also ich finde ja, dass die genau das Gegenteil machen. So Dis-augmented Reality. Ja, also irgendwie hab ich das Gefühl...
Nee, die reichern es einfach um die Metadaten an und zeigen einfach an, hier ist die Situation. Es ist alles in Ordnung.
Also ich hab eher das Gefühl, dass sie abreichern. Aber bitte. So die Realität abreichern. So wie Problem. Was? Nee, wir haben doch drüber geredet und wir haben schriftlich, dass jetzt alles okay ist.
Dass wir uns alle an den Händen halten und...
Also ich finde, das ist abgereicherte Realität nicht angereichert.
So kann man es natürlich auch sehen.
Naja, sind wir mal gespannt, was sie dann aus dem Hut zaubern werden und mit welchen tollen, shocking News sie uns da hinter dem Ofen vorlocken wollen.
Gibt es eigentlich Show-Notes-Schreiber und hassen die uns schon bei unser Hin und Her-Springen von Themen?
Wir springen nicht hin und her.
Wir sind sehr konstant.
Wir springen eigentlich von Baum zu Baum.
Von Baum zu Ast zu Ast.
Ja, wieso? Wir reden hier über das iPhone und was jetzt so kommen könnte. Und es fällt einfach ums Verrecken. Mittlerweile kommt noch ein Feature an.
Doch ein echtes Feature wüsste ich noch. Neue Icons.
Ich rede von der Hardware. Nehme ehrlich, ich meine, was bitte fehlt?
Dann könnte ich endlich mit NFC irgendwie bezahlen. Ja, du, das war ja auch... Aber weißt du noch, wir alle geschrien haben und NFC, ich sehe es nicht. Nirgends benutzt das irgendjemand ernsthaft.
Also Near Field Communication hat auf jeden Fall Zukunft, nur nicht unbedingt diese bekloppten Frequenzstandards, die sie sich am Anfang haben einfallen lassen, sondern es wird halt auf Bluetooth 4 hinauslaufen.
Ich hab übrigens jetzt Passbook das erste Mal benutzt.
Really? Es war ja fantastisch. Ich hab bei der Lufthansa den Flug nach Sizilien gebucht, weil die ausnahmsweise mal die billigsten waren. Und dann war da so in dieser SMS da für das Ticket hier, klickt mal dein Ticket so, war so ein Link für hier, mach doch in dein Passbook rein, so ein Button drin. Und dann hab ich das ins Passbook gemacht und dann dachte ich mir, okay, gut, kannst ja mal ausprobieren und rausholen und so weiter. Und dann war ich am Flughafen, dann war das schon auf dem Screen. So, war schon nicht schlecht. Und dann so, kannst ja einfach jetzt swipen ohne den Passcode einzugeben, dann kommt das auch gleich. Wobei mir irgendein Kollege sagte, eigentlich soll das so sein, wenn du am, das ist die ganze Zeit dann auf dem Log-Screen, wenn du in der Nähe des Flughafens bist. Das verschwand auch wieder, als ich dann vom Zielflughafen mich entfernte. Also es war alles...
Damit hast du auch eingecheckt.
Damit hab ich auch eingecheckt. Aber dann im Zukunftsrausch, ja, hab ich dann vergessen, dass ich ja noch meinen Ausweis trotzdem noch dazu zeigen muss. Und wenn so ganz liger irgendwie alles hier in irgendwelche Taschen steckt... Da hab ich so hingeschlendert, hier mein iPhone mit dem Passbook. Und es war auch ja hier und so, aber den Personalsausweis brauch ich trotzdem noch. Und dann muss ich doch nochmal wühlen und die Schlange ein bisschen aufhalten. Aber das hat dann doch ganz gut funktioniert. Also ich hab ja auch die ganze Zeit so Passbook. Da dachte ich so, wer braucht das? Aber das war sehr praktisch.
Ja, mir ist das letzte Mal fliegen, als ich versucht hab Passbook zu benutzen, aber das weder von Delta aus noch von KLM aus irgendwie sinnvoll funktioniert hat, ist mir auch aufgefallen, dass es Passbook auf dem iPad nicht gibt. Gut zugegebenermaßen, vielleicht ist das iPad auch ein bisschen groß, als dass man es dann unter den Scanner legt, aber irgendwie, das war mir vorher gar nicht aufgefallen. Lame. Es hat ja auch ewig gedauert, bis das iPad irgendwie einen Wecker bekommen hat. Weil, wer könnte denn auf dem iPad einen Wecker gebrauchen?
Gibt es mittlerweile einen Taschenrechner auf dem iPad?
Nee, immer noch nicht. Drittanbieter, bis der Arzt kommt. Also fast mehr als Taschenlampen, aber alle hässlicher als die Nacht und natürlich mit Werbung. Aber keinen eingebauten, nee. Ein iPhone in Gold, ja. Ich glaube, darauf hat die Welt gewartet.
Das passt auch zu der Farbe von dem Lufthansa Passbook-Ticket.
Du, keine Ahnung, Steve ist jetzt weg. Wer weiß, was da passiert. Vielleicht bieten sie es auch mit Straßsteinen an.
Swarovskis.
Ich hätte gerne so ein Miss Kitty.
Dann musst du doch ein C nehmen.
Genau, Miss Kitty. Ich hab glaube ich zwei Sachen zusammengeworfen. Es gibt da noch so ein Miss... Ja, mehr Magic. Ich hätte gerne mehr Magic in meinem Telefon. Das definitiv, da ist noch einiges zu holen. Ich weiß nicht, ob ich iOS 7 mag.
Ich bin damit cool.
Überzeug mich mal.
Ich muss sagen, dieses Design, damit hab ich noch nicht abgeschlossen. Ich komm damit noch nicht 100% zurecht. Es ist okay, ich vertrage es inzwischen.
Du bist über 40, Roddy.
Aber...
Ich glaube, das ist die Grenze.
Und jetzt machen wir mal so einen kleinen Themenwechsel. Wenn man sich beta.icloud.com anguckt und irgendwie, keine Ahnung, man braucht ja glaube ich einen Developer-Invite oder irgendwie sowas. Auf jeden Fall, die haben ja jetzt diese iCloud-Web-Apps in beta.icloud.com umgestellt auf den Look von iOS 7. Und da habe ich das erste Mal das Gefühl gehabt, ich verstehe das Design so ein bisschen, wie es gedacht ist. Also wenn man sich da das Mail-Programm anguckt, das sieht schon nach was aus, was man vielleicht doch benutzt. Ja, das ist ja, wenn du bei iOS 7 das sich bewegende Wallpaper auswählst, auch so.
Aber jetzt bewegt es sich nicht mehr. Ist das so eine kinetische Geschichte, wenn ich das anklickte, dann bewegt es sich wieder?
Ja, keine Ahnung, vielleicht wackelt doch mal an deinem Mac Pro. Also alles in allem habe ich das Gefühl, da sehe ich so ein bisschen durchscheinen, wie dieses Design gedacht ist und kann mich damit anfreunden. Aber auf dem kleinen iPhone hat mich immer so erschlagen.
Aber was heißt denn, wie ist es denn gedacht?
Na ja, so reduziert.
Dieter Brahms.
Dieter Brahms?
Brahms.
Also ich kann es dir jetzt natürlich auch nicht erklären, aber ich habe das erste Mal das Gefühl, das ist stimmig. Während ich das auf dem iPhone hatte, ich nie das Gefühl, dass das Design stimmig ist. Irgendwie, das war so, keine Ahnung, wie es auf dem...
Was macht es denn jetzt so stimmig?
Mach mal Kalender.
Ich fand das jetzt vorher gar nicht so unstimmig.
Das alte Design war auch nicht unstimmig, aber das... Ja, ich kann es nicht erklären, aber ich hatte das erste Mal...
Siehst du mal, da ist es wieder, dieser Effekt. Du hast das Gefühl, es passt, aber du kannst es nicht erklären.
Nee, ich kann es nicht erklären, aber ich habe das erste Mal das Gefühl, das Design passt. Das hatte ich auf dem iPhone nie. Also diese ganzen Betas, die waren eher widerspenstig.
Es ist auf jeden Fall, im Vergleich zum vorherigen Design, ist das ja sehr viel moderner und schlichter und zeitloser. Weil dieses alte Design, das wirkt halt dagegen, wenn ich jetzt wieder so ein iPhone mit einem alten iOS in der Hand habe, denke ich mir schon, habe ich schon diesen Effekt? Oh Gott, was ist das denn für ein irgendwie altgebackener Scheiß und so? Also das wirkt schon alles sehr viel moderner. Genau, und das ist im Vergleich sehr viel eleganter, moderner, leichtgewichtiger. Du bist halt irgendwie weniger voll. Und ich meine, was du jetzt beschreibst, ist ja der Effekt, dass du vorher dachtest, auf dem iPhone jetzt mit dem neuen Design, ist das jetzt in sich halt nicht konsistent oder stimmig. Oder das, was ich dir da ausgedacht habe, ist so eher mit der Brechstange reingehebelt, statt irgendwie jetzt wirklich ein elegantes Konzept zu verfolgen. Und bei den Apps, da ist es halt in sich geschlossen und stimmig. Da passt irgendwie alles so zusammen und ist aufeinander abgestimmt. Und da gibt es halt auch nicht so einen fetten roten Balkenquäl übers Interface, um einen Call zu beenden.
Ja, der ja keiner mehr ist, aber...
Aber bei den ersten iOS 7 Betas ist es halt alles ein bisschen grobschlechtiger gewesen, muss man schon sagen. Und die sehen jetzt schon ein bisschen geschliffener aus.
Ja, sie haben an iOS 7 selber ja auch ein bisschen gefeilt, aber...
Aber hier zum Beispiel die Maps, also bei Find My iPhone, das war ja vorher auch so geomorphistisch, wie auch immer, hier bei iCloud kommen und das haben sie jetzt auch irgendwie, alles so, alles so, das ist geomorphistisch. Weißt du, hier mit genähter Lederkante und so. Wie heißt das noch was?
Das ist geomorph, aber ja, nicht alles, was irgendwie mit Realismus daherkommt, ist zwangsläufig auch die Nachbildung eines... Das ist geomorphismus, also manche, also dass du wirklich ein konkretes, reales Gerät, ein Interface nachbildest, was du so auch in der Realität benutzt. Das hast du natürlich an der Stelle nicht. Da müsstest du schon den Dirke-Welt-Atlas irgendwie da hinzaubern.
Aber Taschenrechner-Applikationen sind üblicherweise geomorph. Auch wenn sie jetzt nicht direkt nach einem echten Taschenrechner aussehen, bedienen sie sich halt genauso.
Das ist ja auch nicht immer falsch.
Ja, sagen wir mal so. Ich meine, man kann auch darüber nachdenken, ob es nicht sinnvoller ist, halt die normale Tastatur zu verwenden, um seine Rechnungen einzugeben und warum man jetzt irgendwie in einer Taschenrechner ab irgendwie 90 Prozent des Platzes für Tasten belegen muss. Kann man hinterfragen. Zumindest.
Aber da macht die Analogie jetzt...
Macht mehr Sinn. Wenn du so ein Ding hast, und so eine Formel-Eingabe fällt wie bei Excel, das ist nichts geomorph.
Nee, aber nichtsdestotrotz, ich finde eigentlich auch, dass sie da auf dem... Also da haben sie es ziemlich gut getroffen, schon komplett. Bei iOS ist es halt immer noch hier und da... Da sind sie noch nicht ganz fertig, bzw. wissen nicht genau, wo sie hin sollen.
Diese IWorks-Apps sehen noch alt aus. Das ist...
Ich bin so ein großer Freund. Das muss ich auch mal wirklich mal eine Lanze brechen für das Alte. Ja, ich meine Zukunft meinetwegen so. Ich finde das ist so geil abgehangen. Diese Gradienten, diese Buttons, diese definierten Umrandungen, diese sanft reingestanzten Buttons, auf denen mal klar ist, wo sie anfangen...
Ja, wenn sie das mal überall so machen würden.
Dann so ein Blau, was einfach so ich bin, der default ausstrahlt. Was am Anfang noch dieses blubbernde Geblinke war.
Aber das hier ist ja schon eine krasse Ausnahme, wenn sie das mal überall so konsistent, schwarz, schick, elegant machen würden. Das sieht ja täglich Mac oder iOS-Brot irgendwie ganz anders aus. Das ist jetzt ja hier auch die Web-App, die jetzt so gerade mal besonders schick, da elegant daherkommt. Aber auf dem iPhone...
Sieht auf meinem Mac OS X genau so aus.
Das Ding ist natürlich, dass du jetzt in so einer Web-App oder überhaupt auf dem Rechner kannst du natürlich raumgreifender designen. Also eine iPhone-App hat halt immer ein Platzproblem. Das ist irgendwie... Ob das jetzt durch die neue Optik irgendwie weg ist oder nicht, das...
Du brauchst doch eh den Text dastehen. Also ich meine, die Button-Beschriftung ist doch nicht weg. Nee, da ist ja nur noch die Beschriftung.
Ja, der Button ist weg.
Ja, aber dadurch nimmt es ja nicht weniger Platz ein, weil du brauchst ja eh Abstand zum nächsten Wort, sonst kleben die ja Pixel an Pixel und kleben teilweise auch schon sehr nah aneinander, dass ich überhaupt nicht mehr weiß, wo überhaupt irgendwas anfängt und wo was aufhört.
In der WWDC Talks argumentieren die ja dadurch, dass sie die Rahmen um die Buttons weggemacht haben, können sie die einzelnen Button-Elemente näher aneinander bringen und haben dadurch mehr Platz. Außerdem haben sie ja diesen neuen Zeichensatz, der halt sehr skinny ist und mir immer ein bisschen zu dünn ist.
Und jetzt gibt's nämlich halt resolution-independent interfaces, weil halt der Button kann kein Image oder sonst was mehr ist, der eskaliert werden muss, ist einfach nur noch Text.
Also in der einen WWDC Talk sagt der Typ tatsächlich, man soll sich doch jetzt überlegen, mal von den ganzen Icons wegzugeben und nur noch Text zu machen. Halt dich für Unsinn. Also gerade, wo halt alle anderen Sprachen als Englisch halt irgendwie mehr Platz brauchen. Besonders Französisch ist immer sehr raumgreifend.
Ich find's auf jeden Fall gut, ich hab mich da vollkommen dran gewöhnt. Ich find jetzt alte iOS schon hässlich und altbackend aussehend und würde auch nicht mehr freiwillig zurückgehen wollen und deswegen warten wir mal einfach ab, bis Tim irgendwann auch das iOS 7 drauf hat, zwei Wochen damit mal intensiver gespielt hat und dann reden wir weiter.
Ja, ich weiß gar nicht, ob ich mir das installieren will.
Na, ich sag mal so, wenn die ersten Apps kommen, die dieses unterliegende System wirklich auch ausnutzen, dann willst du das schon. Also die haben sich da schon, also gerade die Technik unten drunter haben sie sich einige coole Sachen einfallen lassen. Und, naja, dieser neue Zeichen...
Ja klar, ich meine, dieser ganze neue Background-Processing-Kram wird natürlich seine Ergebnisse bringen, die man auch haben will, das ist ja vollkommen.
Na ja, es gibt kein Zurück, also ich meine...
Vorwärts immer, rückwärts nimmer.
Außerdem, wir können ja immer noch auf iOS 8 hoffen. Mac OS 8 war doch auch super. Oder so.
Haben wir denn noch irgendwas rund um iFoo?
Ein paar Apps könnte man noch, aber ich meine, das machen wir eigentlich immer erst später, üblicherweise.
Ich meine, passt doch. Zum Segeln, ich bin heute furchtbar früh aufgestanden und bin gerade nicht ganz so...
Solltest du vielleicht nicht Bier trinken, lieber Tim, sondern Kaffee oder dir die Mate in die Venen pumpen. Hier fürs Segeln, da gibt es irgendwie, wenn man mal so ein bisschen gucken will, wo man gerade ist, als Interessierter Beobachter auf dem Boot, gibt es zwei Platzhirsche, eigentlich gibt es den einen Platzhirsch, Navionics oder so heißen die, verkaufen dann auch die Karten für teuer Geld und so weiter und sind aber ganz genau. Dann gibt es noch Ice Sailer, das ist ein bisschen günstiger und man kann selektiver seine Karten da kaufen. Und weiß dann auch so ein bisschen Bescheid und kann so ein bisschen mit Skipper spielen. Fand ich ganz gut, habe ich mir mal installiert, brauche ich jetzt, aber wo ich nicht segel?
Also es gibt da noch OpenSeaMap, was halt OpenStreetMaps benutzt. Da habe ich irgendwie vor ein paar Jahren mal den Entwickler auf einer Konferenz kennengelernt, ganz netter Typ. Ob das jetzt so was taugt, wenn man dann tatsächlich mit dem Boot unterwegs ist, kann ich nicht beurteilen.
Ja, das Ding ist, also ich vermute, wahrscheinlich reicht es nicht ganz, weil auf diesen Seekarten sind ja dann auch so wirklich die Wassertiefen und irgendwie Hafeninformationen und sonst irgendwelcher Kram.
Das sind aber auf den Seamaps auch.
Du kannst dich halt nicht darauf verlassen, dass es vollständig ist. Wenn du halt Geld für eine Karte ausgibst und so, dann weißt du zumindest, dass da schon mal einer vielleicht dafür gesorgt hat, dass da die konsistenten Informationen vorliegen. Tim geht schon unter den Tisch schlafen.
Ich verbessere die Akustik.
Ich weiß nicht, ob wir schon mal drüber gesprochen haben, was ich seit einiger Zeit benutze.
Hab ich schon mal erwähnt. Wollte ich auch gerade sagen.
Supertoll von Forever Map 2.
Ja, ist geil.
Das ist schon ziemlich cool. Vor allen Dingen, weil du halt ganze Länder runterladen kannst.
Und schnell.
Und relativ schnell. Und es ist, es ist, es rendert schön.
Was ist das?
Also es ist halt so eine Offline-Map-Geschichte.
Für Open-Street-Map.
Für Open-Street, ja. Die benutzen Open-Street-Map-Daten, rendern aber selber eine Vektorkarte.
Genau.
Das ist richtig geil.
Die Vektor Open-Street-Map?
Ja. Und das sieht halt so ein bisschen aus wie Google Maps.
Ach so, von diesen Scobbler Leuten.
Das Einzige, was ein bisschen nervt, ist, dass die diese typische Android-Navigation haben, wo du dann so links oben so ein Menü-Button hast. Und dann, wenn du da draufdrückst, klappt das Menü, also klappt halt so links was rein. Und dann hast du so ein Menü, das allein wäre ja nicht so schlimm, aber du kannst halt durch eine Swipe-Geste vom linken Rand aus dieses Menü aufklappen. Das Ganze gibt es auch vom rechten Rand. Aber, also eine Karte, auf der man nicht schnell rumswipet, um irgendwo anders hinzukommen. Und du klappst immer diese Menüs aus. Es nervt ohne Ende. Und das kann man nicht ausschalten. Das ist der einzige große Haken an dieser App.
Aber das passiert mir nicht.
Das sind diese gnadenlos schrecklich immer ausklappenden Menüs.
Ja, aber das ist wirklich das Schöne daran, dass es schnell rendert, die Downloads sind schnell, du kriegst auch alle Zoom-Stufen, weil sie eben nicht das ganze Bildermaterial runterladen müssen. Ich hab die auch alle vor meinem letzten England-Urlaub nochmal durchgetestet, diese Offline-Maps, und das war das Einzige, was Sinn gemacht hat. Und performt und auch deinen GPS-Fix relativ schnell auf eine Karte rendert. Und auch die Adress-Suche funktioniert. Und er kann sogar Routen machen, also auch sinnvolle Routen. Das ist ja bei Open-Street-Map-basierten Sachen immer so, naja, manchmal nicht so gut. Und du kannst irgendwie sogar, was halt manchmal ganz praktisch ist, Koordinaten irgendwie direkt eingeben und dich da hinbringen lassen. Das geht nämlich auch bei den wenigsten, oder ich weiß gar nicht, ob es bei irgendeiner anderen in so einer Map geht. Manchmal hat man nämlich nur die Koordinaten. Das gibt es auch. Wenn es gerade mal so um irgendwelche Party-Locations oder sowas gibt, habe ich auch schon dafür benutzt. Points of Interest und so. Die haben also echt schon ganz viel Kram drin. Und wie gesagt, der Download, echt auch immer blazing fast von diesen Maps.
Ja, irgendwie, du kriegst irgendwie ganz Deutschland für 600 Megabyte. Also das ist irgendwie... Also das ist echt ein No-Braner. Du fährst in irgendein anderes Land, lädst das ganze Land runter. Das ist dann egal, weißt du? Diese anderen Offline-Maps, wo du dann irgendwie... Wo du dann...
Meinst du, ich kann so Holland mal runterladen?
Auf jeden Fall.
So richtig komplett.
Karten-Download.
Länder. Karten-Download.
Nee, wahrscheinlich irgendwie Niederlande. Neuseeland.
Jetzt hätte ich fast Biederlandisch.
Niederländische Antennen. Nein, Niederlande. 205 Megabyte. Also ich mach das jetzt nicht, weil ich will nicht nach Holland in nächster Zeit.
Ach, naja, also kann man schon nochmal hinfahren.
Ja, ich sag ja nicht, dass man da nicht hinfahren kann. Aber ich will dann in nächster Zeit nicht hin. Also ich hab nix gegen die Holländer und so, aber ich hab nix in Planung. Ja, das Camp ist mir von dir erst vermisst worden.
Ja, man kann ja auch hier kiffen.
Boah, das hab ich weitestgehend aufgegeben.
Ja, aber das war zum Beispiel auch total gut in Italien und so weiter, immer mal zu gucken, wenn es gerade kein Internet gab und so, wo bin ich gerade? Da konnte ich nämlich nicht die iSeller-App gleich im ersten Hafen und so runterladen, das war da zu langsam. Grunzen. Man muss ja auch mal grunzen. Und da hab ich auch mal mit dem Forever Map dann geschmult, wo wir denn jetzt gerade sind. Aber hatte ich glaube ich auch schon mal erwähnt hier.
Das kann gut sein.
Das kann sein, aber ich hab's mir noch mal aufgeschrieben, gehabt, das kann ich jetzt mal abhaken.
So, hat sich nicht auch irgendwas geschoppt, wo wir gerade bei den Ups sind. Ich glaube ich war nicht so glücklich mit all dem, was ich so...
Man shoppt ja immer irgendwas.
Jaja.
Gibt's hier nicht im App Store recently purchased oder sowas?
Eigentlich schon.
Ja, auf dem iPhone kannst du das machen. Du gehst auf Updates und dann gekaufte Artikel und dann alle. Ja, ich bin da nicht sehr umfangreich vorgegangen, aber ich hab nach einiger Zeit mal wieder geguckt, wie es denn so mit Flipper Software aussieht, weil das finde ich so eine der geileren Spielkonzepte, auf die ich auch abfahre.
Crystal Caliburn, oder wie auch immer das hieß.
Ja, auf dem C64 war ich auch immer schon ziemlich hooked auf Flipper. Flipper fand ich schon immer eine der cooleren Spielanwendungen. Ich kann dir nicht erzählen, warum, aber es ist so schön monoton. Ich mag ja so Spiele, die man immer so endlos spielen kann. Es geht nur irgendwie um die Zahl. Also ich will halt im Wesentlichen abschalten. So diese ganzen Herausforderungen mit baue deinen Weltraumprogramm und erkunde ferne Welten und baue eine Zivilisation auf und plane eine Stadt.
Schieß mit Vögeln auf Schweine.
Das wiederum geht schon dann eher. Also das ist dann schon wieder dumpf. Ja, also ich will das gar nicht kritisieren. Das ist super, toll. Ich finde es geil, dass es intelligente Software gibt da draußen und Leute, die sich über komplexe Simulationen Gedanken machen. Und das macht einen bestimmt auch zum besseren Menschen, wenn man das gespielt hat und auch spielen möchte. Aber ich, keine Ahnung, ich habe da, glaube ich, vermisst da irgendwie einen Gen gekippt oder so.
Du bist für die schnelle Arcade zwischendurch.
Ja, weißt du, die kosmische Strahlen, die Millionen, da fällt ja immer mal wieder was ab.
Also ich habe ja auf meinem ersten Computer den...
Moment.
Pinballs.
Da hatte ich ja Crystal Caliburn, oder so hieß der glaube ich. Und den habe ich auch wirklich sehr, sehr viel gezockt. Also das war auch so, weil auf dem Mac gab es ja eh nicht viel Spiele, und vor allen Dingen wenig gut produzierte. Und das war einer der Flipper, der so richtig Spaß gemacht hat.
Auf dem Apple II gab es auch so einen Flipper, der war total cool. Der war irgendwie nur so in schwarz-weiß beziehungsweise grün, schwarz-grün.
Genau, Little Wing Pinball, genau so war er.
Jetzt kommen sie wieder, die Erinnerungen.
Gibt es für iOS auch?
Ja, stimmt, ich habe das sogar gespielt auf dem iPad, glaube ich.
Best Simulation auf 1993, na super.
Heutzutage mit diesen 3D-Flippern und fremden Welten, gibt es ja alles, was du gerade gesagt hast, Zivilisation, Städte bauen und so, das haben die ja alles in diese Flipper, in irgendwelche Subspiele eingebaut. Da musst du halt auf die Rampe zweimal nach links und dann hast du irgendwie was auch immer für eine Story anlockt und Indiana Jones fängt die Kugel oder was auch immer. Aber der Crystal-Candy-Brain, der ist da noch relativ simpel gestrickt, ja. Ja, der hatte nämlich...
Da kann ich nicht mitreden, so Flippern, das hat mich dann nie so lange fasziniert.
Naja, auf jeden Fall, der kostet auch einfach nur Geld hier, ich kauf den mal.
Genau, der hat keine Nerf-Features und so.
Genau, die meisten sind jetzt alle komplett auf dieses Fremium oder In-App, wie man das auch immer nennen möchte, Modell.
Wo du dann Schlumpfbeeren kaufen musst, um weiterzukommen.
Also an der Stelle muss ich sagen, finde ich das auch irgendwie okay. Du kaufst quasi die Engine und kriegst in der Regel einen oder vielleicht auch mehrere verschiedene Flipper und dann kaufst du dir quasi nochmal komplett neue Flipper in dieselbe Engine. Ich hab jetzt nicht viel gekauft, aber ich hab jetzt mal ein paar runtergeladen, ein bisschen gespielt und miteinander verglichen, wie die so, ich hab jetzt auch nicht höllisch viel Zeit damit verbracht, aber ich war schon erstaunt, dass man die Unterschiede noch so deutlich spürte. Also, dass es schon doch sehr viel ausmacht, wie so ein Teil programmiert ist, wie diese Physics Engine ist, wie diese Pedals sind, auch wie der Sound ist und so. Ich mag zum Beispiel, hab eher sowas für diese trockenen, klar klackenden Pedals und alles, was so ein bisschen gummiartiger ballistisch ist. Da hüpft mir immer noch zu viel. Man muss so eine Kugel auch irgendwie gut auffangen können. Man muss so richtig aus dem Handgelenk den richtigen Kick mit so einem halben Schlag geben können. Und das hatte ich jetzt so nur bei, moment, wie hieß das Teil? Also es gab da verschiedene. Es mag da auch noch sehr viel mehr geben. Also getestet habe ich Zenbin Pinball.
Einer der Bekannten, ja.
Oh Gott, der eine hab ich wieder gelöscht, oder was?
War der so schlecht?
Ich weiß jetzt nicht mehr ganz genau. Dann müsste doch hier eigentlich Zenbinball und dann Age of Pinballs, genau, der sich besonders diesem 70s-Flipper-Style verstiegen hat. Was ich eigentlich an sich auch ganz interessant finde, weil ich finde auch so, eigentlich war in den alten Flippers im Wesentlichen alles drin und diese 1000 Bonus-Level und Peng und Puff und Magic und Spiralen und nochmal drei Etagen, die Google übereinander und so weiter. Erstmal rockt das auf so einem iPad eh nicht so und ich finde, das macht jetzt auch nicht so den Reiz aus. Es gab da zwar schon auch so in den 80ern ein paar interessante Flipper, was weiß ich hier, so Terminator und Indiana Jones und so. Ja, da gab es mal so eine Phase, wo so Baldy so richtig ein Score nach dem anderen gejagt hat, also so den Highscore bei ihren Kunden, meine ich. Die komischerweise, gibt es die eigentlich auch? Dann habe ich jetzt noch gar nicht geschaut. Wie auch immer, was ich am besten fand bisher, ist ein Pinball, der heißt einfach Pinball Collection HD. Pinball HD Collection, genau. Was halt auch mit so verschiedenen Leveln ist und ich habe wie gesagt nur den Default Level gespielt, da kann man aber auch die anderen auch alle anspielen.
Ich meine jetzt, das bist du mit dem iPad oder was?
Oh mein iPad hat sich mit meiner Boombox verbunden. Ah, interessant. Ja, kann man das jetzt hier auch mal im Hintergrund.
Genau. Achso, hier muss ich ja drauf arbeiten, nicht auf der Tastatur.
Ja, das ist halt hier so ein richtiger Flipper irgendwie, der klingt auch geil.
Also zur Erklärung, wir sehen jetzt auch nichts.
Hier kann man auch irgendwie, war das nicht so, genau, hier kann man auch so mit zwei Daumen Bewegungen die Zoom-Level irgendwie ändern, was auch sehr ganz gut ist, dass du diese Ansicht so dynamisch ändern kannst, je nachdem, wie du sie gerne hättest. Aber das klingt doch schon richtig nach Flipper, oder?
Ja, ich weiß nämlich noch, als ich das erste Mal Flipper in echt gespielt hatte, also ich hab ja Flipper erst natürlich nur auf dem Computer gespielt, natürlich. So in meiner Generation war das nicht so üblich, dass da überall Flipper-Maschinen sozusagen an jeder Ecke rumstehen. Und dann, als ich das erste Mal vom echten Flipper stand, dachte ich so, oh, das ist ja komplett was anderes, so Physik, Stahlkugel, irgendwie, da passiert ja richtig was, weil bei Crystal Caliburn jetzt zum Beispiel, der ist jetzt nicht so der Allerrealistischste von der Physik her.
Ja, und da konnte man dann auch immer noch gegen treten, um die Kugel zu retten. Und wenn man das zu stark getan hat, dann war sie trotzdem weg, ne?
Ah, der ist auch so schön trocken.
Das ist Crystal Caliber.
Das sieht aber schon ein bisschen anders aus. Man merkt, dass sie mehr Pixel benutzt haben als auf dem C64.
Ja, als auf dem Mac, mein ich.
Ja, aber der...
Ich kann's noch.
So viel gespielt, das verliert man nicht.
Das ist geil, oder?
Dass man da so ein Muscle-Memory hat nach 20 Jahren. Excalibur is lit. Die Sounds der Kindheit.
Aber stimmt, daher kommt auch der Ausdruck Tilt. Vom Flipper.
Ja, woher sonst?
Ja, aber daher kommt daher der.
Was war das für ein Spiel gerade?
Keine Ahnung, ich hab da so einen Link aus dem Chat geklickt.
Genau, jetzt hier. Mach ich ja normalerweise nicht. Aber heute ist so ein Tag, wo ich es dann doch mal mache. Und zwar ist heute jetzt gerade ein Spiel von VUGA rausgekommen. Und es ist zwar so ein Freemium-Spiel, aber das ist so eins, was relativ human ist, was so diese Sache angeht. Nee, es nervt nicht zu sehr eigentlich. Es ist ein Puzzle-Spiel, es heißt Jelly Splash. Und es ist eins der Spiele, was ich als Back-End-Envogler nicht mit diesen Social Games oder diesen Freemium-Spielen so verbunden bin. Aber das ist ein Spiel, das in der Firma fast jeder wirklich schon bis in die 100er-Level reingesuchtet hat. Es ist so ein kleines Puzzle-Game. Es ist jetzt auch nicht ein komplett neues Spielkonzept. Aber es ist sehr schön umgesetzt, wie ich finde. Das kann man ruhig mal pluggen. Und ich bin auch total einverstanden damit, wenn ihr nicht irgendwie Schlumpfbeeren kauft und es einfach so gratis spielt.
Verbindet Jellys gleicher Farbe.
Aber sie haben wirklich so grafisch und soundtechnisch und so von dieser ganzen Haptik und so. Das haben sie schon ganz cool gemacht. Und auch so die Challenges da drin. Ich hab's jetzt auch, glaube ich, ich bin jetzt Level 94 oder so. Und es bleibt irgendwie doch immer noch interessant.
Bei solchen Spielen ist für mich immer entscheidend, kann man die im Liegen spielen, ohne das Telefon bewegen zu müssen?
Du meinst, es ist kein Tilt- und Shake-Game?
Kann man sich sozusagen abends beim Einschlafen während man einen Podcast hört, sozusagen.
Das hab ich schon ein paar Mal gemacht und bin dabei dann auch so, noch eine Linie!
Genau deswegen, also das... Ich würde das jetzt nicht...
Ich würde so eine eigene Kategorie im App Store geben, die sozusagen nur solche Games enthält.
Einschlafspiele.
Ja, so Spiele, die unabhängig von Bewegung und von Ausrichtung sind.
Und immer unhektischer werden, wenn der Spieler langsamer wird.
Man könnte sich ja da schon was einfallen lassen. So dass du dann ganz lang... Es gibt einfach so Spiele, die kannst du halt nicht so spielen. Also was weiß ich hier, so diese... Wie heißt die noch gleich hier, dieses Hobbs-Teil da? Du musst halt dein scheiß iPhone immer gerade halten, damit er nicht irgendwie da links...
Aber nee, das ist ein Spiel, das nur mit Finger auch zu steuern und im Liegen. Und ich würd's dir jetzt auch nicht erwähnen, wenn ich nicht selber das schon gesuchtet hätte, sozusagen, ja.
Also gut, dann kann ich ja auch noch zwei Spiele placken. Und zwar das eine heißt Tiny Thief. Und ist irgendwie bei den Jungs erschienen... Ist bei den Jungs erschienen, die die Vögel und die Schweine gemacht haben. Ist allerdings nicht von denen. Und da spielt man... Das ist so ein bisschen so ein Rätselspiel. Also du musst immer in einem Level bestimmte Dinge kombinieren, um an dieses Ende von dem Level zu kommen. Also der Dieb muss erst irgendwas klauen und dann muss noch sein Frettchen irgendwo angetippt haben, was manchmal hervorlugt und so weiter. Und zum Schluss hat man dann so ein Level fertig. Also es ist mehr so ein Puzzle-Rätselspiel. Aber so ein Teil zwischen so eine Plattformer und so ein Rätselspiel. Und es ist eine ganz lustige Geschichte, wie er irgendwie dann die Königstochter natürlich rettet und so. Also das eine und das andere, was völlig absurd ist, das heißt Icebreaker. Und ist so ein Spiel, da spielt man irgendwie einen Wikinger, der immer Eisblöcke zerschlagen muss, um andere Wikinger zu retten. Und man macht die aber klein mit so Swipe-Gesten, die Eisblöcke. Und also das ist wirklich sehr strange, das Spiel. Aber es macht unheimlichen Spaß. Es ist auch so ein Puzzle-Rätsel-Spiel, wo man halt irgendwie gucken muss, wie kriegt man diese in Eis gesottenen Wikinger da raus, ohne dass sie dann irgendwie bei einem Troll hängen bleiben und von dem gemampft werden oder so. Also das fand ich auch sehr nett.
Dein Jelly-Splash erinnert mich übrigens an ein anderes Game, Extrem. Das ist, was ich schon auch bis zur Vergasung gespielt habe. Und zwar, das hab ich bestimmt auch schon erwähnt.
Was ist denn das für ein Ausdruck?
Ich hab auch gerade, ich meine, der ist halt so in die Umgangssprache reingebrannt, aber eigentlich, wenn man so drüber nachdenkt, fragt man sich auch.
Das ist nicht ganz so korrekt.
Nee, das ist so nicht so PC.
Nicht so PC.
Ja, bis man halt so weit erhitzt ist, dass man halt in gasförmigen Zustand ist.
Jaja, schon, klar.
Scheiße, okay, das war's mit der Podcast-Karriere.
Naja, auf jeden Fall heißt das Monster Soup und das funktioniert so ein bisschen ähnlich wie dein jellies Clash.
Wie gesagt, das Spielprinzip ist jetzt auch nicht total innovativ. Monster Soup?
Monster Soup, finde ich cool, weil da steigen die Fischer nämlich dann irgendwie auch immer ganz dramatisch nach oben und zerschellen irgendwie oben an einem oberen Rand und dann wird das irgendwie immer schneller und hektischer und du wirst irgendwie verrückt. Also das finde ich ziemlich lustig. Monster Soup ist auch ein ganz großes Keynote.
Ja, das ist jetzt hier, also das ist halt... Dieses Jelly Splash ist halt total unhektisch. Also du hast alle Zeit der Welt, um das Level zu lösen, sozusagen, da kann man schon auch ein bisschen nachdenken. Das finde ich eigentlich auch mal ganz nett.
Also hier noch der Link für Icebreaker.
Also nicht nachdenken, aber so seine Moves so ein bisschen überlegen halt und nicht so von der Hektik in Fehler getrieben werden.
Ach ja, bei Icebreaker ist es auch ganz nett, das hat doch ziemlich viel Humor, weil sie sich immer selber auf das Schippen nehmen, was jetzt gerade in der Story passiert und warum das passiert. Und das ist irgendwie, hat auch eine merkwürdige, so ein bisschen 8-Bit, 16-Bit-Pixel-Optik. Also das ist... Das ist nicht ganz einfach, aber macht unheimlich Spaß.
Gut, weil jetzt haben wir hier den Original-Sound.
Zu was?
Zu den Monsters, beziehungsweise allem, was ich jetzt hier irgendwie aufrufe, sozusagen. Macht auch so schöne Plop-Sounds, ganz toll. Ich war jetzt erst mal daran interessiert, überhaupt hier erst mal den Sound-Verletzungsstatus zu machen, weil ich habe nämlich noch einen coolen Tipp. Das ist wahrscheinlich schon jeder, aber muss ich einfach mal kaufen. Heißt Storm Sim.
Storm Sim.
Kenn ich nicht.
Das klingt nach Abzocke, wenn du mich fragst.
Health and fitness. Was ist das?
Das ist einfach Storm Sim. Also es ist einfach genau das.
Integrierte Stürme, Downpour, Epic Thunder, Just Rain.
Na, was ist da so ein Multitrack-View irgendwie auf deiner einzelnen Effekte? Da ist halt irgendwie Regen und verschiedene Blitzer. Und kannst sie dann zur Not auch noch irgendwie direkt anklicken?
Also es ist dieses von Obsolete Software.
Ist das Obsolete Software? Das weiß ich jetzt gar nicht.
Ja, ok, ja, doch, doch, ich seh's.
Storm Sim.
Die Free-Variante.
Genau, und dann kannst du ja auch so verschiedene Packs von Zeug dazu kaufen. Ja, das ist jetzt so, hab ich mir glaub ich so ein bisschen selber zusammengebaut, da kannst du dann auch so verschiedene Wind-Sachen dazu machen, so Züge, die irgendwie auf irgendwelchen Brücken fahren. Und es ist einfach nass.
Ist gut für so eine laue Sommernacht.
Die nasseste App überhaupt.
Ich fand vor allem dieses Preset Falling Asleep schon mal ganz gut, weil ich hatte auch gerade das Problem, dass ich unbedingt einschlafen musste. Ich hatte immer so eine Nacht, wo ich einfach partout einfach nicht zur Ruhe kam, kennt ihr das? Und hab irgendwie alles probiert. Podcast hören, waren alle viel zu interessant. Dann halt irgendwelche Videopodcasts noch angucken, hat alles nicht funktioniert. Dann hab ich es natürlich auch noch damit probiert. Das Problem war, das war natürlich so interessant, mit diesem Programm umzuspielen, dass ich dann auch ordentlich eingeschlafen bin.
Also ich müsste da auf die Dauer eher aufs Klo, als dass ich irgendwie dieses Gewürzel im Hintergrund...
Musste von der Regen draußen aufs Klo?
Ne, aber der ist ja echt, außerdem wird's dann kühl.
Ich mach mal The City.
Genau das, dann nehm ich hier auch so Regen auf Asphalt und all so was.
Da hat einer wirklich viel Zeit mit Mikrofonen und Aufnahmegerät verbracht, oder?
Ja, das find ich einfach auch mal ganz geil. Also du kannst auch einige nachkaufen.
Sturm zurücksetzen.
Eris-Effekte, Donnerpaket 01, Nebelhörner, Wasserpaket 1, hol dir 16 Wassereffekte wie Bach, Plätschern, reißende Flüsse und traumhafte Wasserfälle.
Mir läuft das Wasser schon in die Unterhose.
Also ich find das auch so ganz entspannt jetzt eigentlich. So jetzt muss man auch nicht mehr so viel erzählen. Jetzt kann man einfach so zuhören, ne?
Okay, wenn wir jetzt schon bei sinnlosen Apps sind, dann kann ich ja hier noch, wie heißt das, Spectrum View von Oxford Wave Research empfehlen. Spectrum View von Oxford Wave Research.
Ja. Zeigt dir Real-Time-Sprache an.
Zeigt dir Real-Time ein, wie heißt das so schön, ein Spektrogramm an.
Ja, von dem, was da jetzt gerade über Audio innen kommt.
Also, kostet auch nichts und man kann da gucken, also man kann da Stunden zubringen und in das Ding reinsprechen und pfeifen und tun und machen, weil es einfach super aussieht.
Da gibt es so eine App auf Mac, die ich mir letztens mal installiert habe, um so ein Audiosignal mir anzugucken. Und wie hieß das? Irgendwo in meinem Launchpad war das mit drin. Komm, Launchpad sei einmal nützlich. Einmal nur. Es ist nicht da.
Ich hab's doch gekauft.
Ach nee, was? Impulse Response Utility? Nee, das war es nicht. Das ist was anderes, oder?
Das ist ja gratis.
Ja, du kannst dann noch irgendwie Pro freischalten und dann kannst du irgendwie reinzoomen und aufnehmen und so ein Zeug irgendwie machen. Aber einfach mal irgendwie Spektrum gucken, das ist schon ganz nett.
Soundview hieß das. So war das.
Schön, also ich hätte jetzt dieses Storm-Sim hätte ich ja ganz gerne.
Storm-Storm-Sim. Also wirklich. Aber das ist die ultimative Wetter-App, das muss man mal sagen.
Ich hätte das aber ganz gerne noch in so einem Dschungel-Modus, dass man also auch so irgendwie in so einem tropischen... Genau.
Auf Jamaika gab es so komische Frösche, die haben gepieps wie Vögel. Ja, und dann denkst du, was sind das für komische Vögel? Aber das sind Frösche.
Da werd ich eher gedacht, was ist das für komische Frösche?
Hier gibt es auf dem Mac Soundview, das hab ich mir mal installiert, das sieht so aus. Da kannst du auch Spektrogramm und Blablabla und Waveformen und kannst halt für Audiosignale, ich brauch da das mal, um zu gucken, wo irgendwelche Frequenzen gerade rumbrummen.
Was greift der ab? Greift der nur Audio in oder kann der aus?
Du kannst in das, was du im System denkst, als Input wählst.
Aber kann nicht sich in irgendwelche gehygaggen, dann müsste man mit Audiohygag wahrscheinlich sich noch was bauen oder Soundflower oder so.
Wie heißt das Ding?
Soundview. Wenn die Leute da im Chat oder so noch was besseres haben, aber ich fand das erstmal ganz gut. Das hat zumindest für mich so das Problem sozusagen gelöst.
Soundview für den Mic?
Genau.
Gibt es das im Stor?
Das gibt es im Stor.
Von Rare Works?
Ja, warte ich guck nochmal.
Das Icon sieht ein bisschen so aus, als würde da irgendwie jemand...
Also available for iOS-Devices.
Welche Frequenz hat meine Stimme?
Ich hab das halt mal gebraucht, weil ich irgendwie ich musste mit dem Equalizer mal irgendwie so einen Brumm oder so rausfinden und dann konnte ich damit irgendwie mal so ein bisschen gucken, wo das herkommt und dann war das ganz gut.
Cooler Tipp?
Ich hab zu Hause ja noch ein analoges Oszilloskop. Das ist richtig mal analog, richtig technisch.
Ah, das kommt ungefähr gleich bei mir beim Start.
Ach, hm.
Also wie gesagt, wenn da Leute Alternativen wissen, da wär ich auch immer noch interessiert, aber es war relativ schwer im App Store nach sowas zu suchen.
Ah, ich weiß auch, was der Fehler ist. You don't have permission to save the file downloads in the folder lalala.
Man möchte irgendwo...
Irgendwo gerne was speichern.
Ja, kommt mit meinem geänderten Downloads-Folder nicht klar. Wie soll die WDR, wer soll mal in meinen Downloads-Folder reinlegen? Es gibt so Programme, wie konnte das in den... Crashed jedes Mal, weil irgendwie der Downloads-Folder nicht klar ist.
Hat jemand ins Spektrogramm ein Bild reingerendert.
Ja, dafür suche ich ja eigentlich auch noch so ein bisschen so ein Tool, dass man mal so ein Bild wieder zu einem Sound macht. Also ich meine, das kann nicht so schwer sein, aber...
Also wenn ihr, liebe Hörer, ein Tool habt, um ein Bild zu einem Sound zu machen oder ein Sound zu einem Bild, dann sagt Bescheid, wir wollen sozusagen ein Foto von uns in einen Sound konvertieren, damit es in einem Spectrum Analyzer dann wieder das Bild macht.
In so einem Spektrogramm, genau. Ich sag ja, das ist dann irgendwie Satanismus 2.0.
Jetzt zoppelt das hier auf jeden Fall ganz ordentlich auf dem Bildschirm, ist schon mal ganz gut.
Das ist aber jetzt nicht der Regen, den wir hören, sondern nur die Stimmen, oder ist der Regen damit dabei?
Das sind nur die Stimmen. Mach doch mal das Spektrogramm auch hier rüber. Irgendwas ist da.
Wieso sind das nur die Stimmen?
Oh Mann. Kannst du mal wieder besseres Wetter machen?
Kann man bei dem Tool nicht irgendwie den Sound-Input? Nehmt der immer den Default-In oder was?
Der nimmt das, was du in den System Preferences einstellst.
Das ist doch beknackt.
Ja, deswegen, wie gesagt, ich bin wirklich ernsthaft an Alternativen, die das gleich betonen. Aber wenn man es halt mal braucht, dann ist es zumindest mal ein erster Anhaltspunkt.
Ja, ich verstehe das.
Was ist denn mein Input hier überhaupt?
Nicht jetzt alles...
Können wir den Abteil vielleicht mal abbeabeln?
Ich glaube, ja.
Soll ich das ausmachen?
Ja, jetzt so langsam.
Ja, mach mal Sonne an.
So langsam können wir wieder ein bisschen sonnigeres Wetter vertragen.
Jetzt müssen wir mal gucken, wie das geht hier. Es faded auch aus. Jetzt können wir uns wieder abtrocknen.
Sehr gut.
Hier gibt es ein paar Tipps. Vielleicht kannst du die mal kurz im Chat nachgehen. Die Gelegenheit würde ich dann mal kurz nutzen, dieses Sound-Device, was wir jetzt im ersten Teil mit dem Flipper kurz gehört haben, das nochmal vorzustellen. Das finde ich nämlich ein ganz spaßiges Device. Das habe ich mir jetzt geschoppt, nachdem ich es auf der OMM kennengelernt habe. Und zwar handelt es sich dabei um einen portablen Lautsprecher, der sich als Bluetooth-Audio-Device ansprechen lässt und selber auch einen eigenen Akku hat. Das Teil ist sehr kompakt. Das ist nicht mal so lang wie ein iPhone. Ist auch so breit wie ein iPhone.
Aber doch ein bisschen tiefer.
Ein bisschen tiefer als ein iPhone. Auf jeden Fall so eine Hand. Ich weiß gar nicht, was ist denn hier ein guter Vergleich für diese Größe? Hier ist es ein bisschen schwer. Was ist denn so groß? Ich würde mal sagen, so zwei Zigarettenpakete übereinander.
Die langen Zigaretten aber.
Genau, genau. Und das hat jetzt einen ganz korrekten Sound. Das ist auch so vom User-Interface her alles ganz okay. Also das besteht im Wesentlichen eigentlich nur aus einer Bluetooth-Pairing-Taste auf dem Deckel plus Lautstärke, lauter, leiser. Du kannst das ein- und ausschalten, du kannst über USB laden. Du hast auch Audio-In. Also du kannst es auch mit einem normalen Audio-In-Kabel noch betreiben, was ich für sehr sinnvoll erachte. Und der Rest ist einfach nur Lautsprecher. Und das Teil ist einfach so super mega kompakt. Und wenn es geladen ist, kannst du es einfach auch komplett ohne irgendwelche Kabel einfach so noch mit einstecken. Also was weiß ich, vielleicht noch einen kleinen Stöpfer drumherum, das so ein bisschen zu schützen. Aber im Wesentlichen kannst du das so mit einem Rucksack reinstecken, wenn du mal irgendwo hingehst und du der Meinung bist, du könntest da vielleicht mal Amplifikationen brauchen. Und das ist ja gerade für so Reisen, Kurztrips oder was weiß ich, wenn man mal schnell irgendwo auf dem Kaffeetisch was präsentieren soll, was ordentlich Sound braucht. Man möchte sich halt auf seine Laptop-Quaken nicht verlassen. Dann hast du halt klar, es gibt da eine ganze Menge von diesen Lautsprechern. Ich hab das alles schon irgendwie mal ausprobiert. Die brauchen dann aber auch nochmal Strom oder Brüllwürfel. Brauchen Batterien und müssen dann nochmal die Batterien nochmal separat geladen werden. Kannst halt nicht im Gerät laden. Und hier kannst du das Ding einfach mit USB anschließen und dann wird's eben geladen. Und macht ganz ordentlich Sound. Roddy, du hast das hier vorhin nochmal vor der Sendung auch gehört.
Also dafür, dass das Teil wirklich extrem klein ist, macht das einen extrem fetten Sound. Also das muss man mal sagen. Das ist wirklich erstaunlich, das Ding.
Das ist erstaunlich und jetzt kommt auch die Auflösung, wie es heißt. Das ist nämlich die Logitech Mini Boombox. Und zwar UE ist die Variante, die ich da habe. Also da gibt's auch irgendwie noch eine ältere. Bei Logitech wird ja gerade irgendwie alles auf UE noch mal so als Subbrand umgestellt. Und diese Mini Boombox ist halt vor allem mini und macht irgendwie ausreichend Boom.
Die macht ausreichend Boom.
Ja, so kann man das glaube ich sagen.
Und kostet 99 Euro so zumindest hier bei Amazon. Hat auch schon jemand den Link in die Webseite geworfen?
Ja, kann man sich mal merken. Ja, 99 ist ein stolzer Preis, aber...
Er löst halt so ein Problem.
So ein Mr. Wolf.
Ja, ich löse Probleme.
Aber ich könnte mir trotzdem vorstellen, dass man es für den Preis kauft, also...
Ja, wenn man das Problem hat, dann könnte man es für 99 Euro auch mal kaufen.
Nur ist es doch so als Audio-Abspieler eigentlich ganz gut, um sich so irgendwie in die Küche zu stellen oder so.
Genau.
Wo wir gerade bei Verkaufen sind, da fällt mir noch was anderes ein. Ich verkaufe nämlich gerade mein MacBook.
Du willst Hardware loswerden?
Genau. Mein eBay. Ich habe mein altes MacBook Air hier auf Ebay. Das ist jetzt hier Shameless Self-Plugging in der Metaebene. Haben wir da nicht sogar einen passenden Sound dazu?
Ja doch, da war doch was.
Solche Dinge werden mir irgendwie zugeschickt.
Ich weiß auch nicht warum.
Hast du den Link jetzt mal gepostet? Ah ja, hier.
Genau.
Kauft alle irgendwie, falls irgendjemand noch ein metaebenesbezogenes Andenken oben drauf haben will, schreibt es dazu.
Gibt es einen Aufkleber dazu oder was?
Keine Ahnung.
Die Leute kommen ja auf die merkwürdigsten Wünsche. Ich würde mich da auf jeden Fall erkenntlich zeigen.
Apropos Andenken, die Homebrew Gläser sind gekommen. Von dem Homebrew Kickstarter. Die habe ich jetzt. Da gab es, wenn man ein bestimmtes Level...
Da sind wir schon wieder bei Bier irgendwie.
Nee, nee, wenn man ein bestimmtes Level gebackt hat, hat man da Gläser bekommen. Und ich wollte natürlich die Gläser haben. Und jetzt habe ich sie und die sind super.
Und apropos verkaufen.
Was für Gläser waren das nochmal?
Also eigentlich hieß es Pintgläser, aber es sind glaube ich ein bisschen weniger. Ich weiß nicht, ob es mit Pint reinpasst. Vor allen Dingen sind sie nicht diese dünnen Pintgläser, wie man sie aus England kennt, sondern die sind relativ stabil. Da steht auf der einen Seite Homebrew und auf der anderen Seite steht Hard Brew SH oder so. Gibt es sowas?.sh als Top-Level-Domain? Ja, Brew SH http://brewsh steht da auf der anderen Seite.
Voll altschulig hier das http:// davor zu sagen.
Ja, sonst könnte es ja auch ein Shell-Skript sein. In dem Sinn macht das schon Sinn.
Ja, die meisten Leute nehmen sich heutzutage nicht mehr die Zeit.
Lattenzahnausrufezeichen.
Aber hier, wo wir gerade von Verkaufen sprechen, das ist ja sehr erfrischend, dass hier mal jemand was verkaufen will, denn das ist nicht überall so. Und am allerwenigsten ist das so in einem Ort, wo man denkt, es geht eigentlich die ganze Zeit ums Verkaufen. Und der Ort, von dem ich spreche, ist der Just Music Store in Berlin.
Du hast ja irgendwie einen Narren gefressen in diesem Ort.
Ja, ich hab ja da jetzt Sachen auch gekauft, unter großen Bühnen. Das war die erste Male noch nicht so schlimm, aber jetzt war ich noch mal mit anderen Menschen da, die jetzt auch nicht so eine gewisse...
Du hast doch schon dieses Verkaufsprozedere da mit diesen komischen man muss da dreimal anstehen oder warst du das?
Ich hab das erzählt, dass ich wollte eigentlich nur Kabel haben, also so normale Audio-Kabel, XLR-Klinke und dann gab es irgendwie, es gab so die eine Wand mit den ganz teuren Kabeln, die irgendwie alle einzeln noch mal in so eine fancy-Pub-Verpackung eingepackt waren und in Bund und so. Und dann gab es die billigen Kabel irgendwie und die waren alle nicht ausgepreist, komplett gar nicht. Und dann bin ich halt mal zum Tresen und mal so gefragt, ja, was kosten denn die Kabel? Ja, welches denn? Ja, die da drüben, die haben alle keinen Preis. Ja, das müsste ich schon genauer wissen. Dann habe ich halt so ein paar mal zusammengesammelt und dann hat sie also angefangen, da die Preise nachzugucken. Ich weiß nicht, ob auf der eigenen Webseite oder auf der von der Konkurrenz. Ich weiß es nicht, also auf jeden Fall.
Und das Ding ist halt, ich weiß, also das haben wir jetzt ja, diese Prozedere haben wir schon, mit der Rohrpost haben wir glaube ich auch schon erzählt, wie bekloppt das ist. Du bist schon da, du hast das schon in der Hand, dann nimm das dir wieder weg, kriegst den Zettel, musst runter, musst noch mal anstehen. Dann steht da eine Schlange, ein Typ langweilt sich, sie machen keine neue Kasse auf und so dieses ganze Ding.
Anders als das Zeev Jobs gemacht hat, haben sie bestimmt nicht vorher diesen Laden schon mal getestet. Erinnert ihr euch an die Historie, dass sie wirklich den ersten Apple Store komplett aufgebaut haben und mit Leuten getestet haben und dann immer wieder verworfen haben, bis es irgendwie gekassert hat?
Also die haben das Gegenteil gemacht. Die haben das irgendwo in irgendeiner Cut-Software zusammengeklickt. Und das sah an den Renderings alles ganz schön aus. Und hey, cool, wir haben eine Rohrpost und so. Die Prozesse sahen wahrscheinlich in der PowerPoint-Presi total sinnvoll aus. Aber in der Realität ist es halt einfach so der Fail. Und dieses Personal da... Also am Anfang ist es mir noch nicht so aufgefallen. Wahrscheinlich hatte ich Glück, so am richtigen Tag in der richtigen Stimmung geraten zu sein. Aber die wollen nicht verkaufen, die können nicht verkaufen und die wissen auch nicht, wie man verkauft. Also, erstens wollen nicht verkaufen, also du musst schon irgendjemanden erst mal so finden und dir überreden, überhaupt Produkte zu geben. Auf der Webseite steht, das und das wäre im Laden. Dann gehst du da hin, ja, ich hätte das jetzt gern mal ausprobiert. Also, es ist nicht hier im Regal und es könnte sein, dass wir es nach zwei Monaten, seitdem wir in diesem Laden sind, auch immer noch nicht ausgepackt haben. Aber ich such mal. Okay, wir testen erst noch was anderes. Kannst ja dann einfach vorbei bringen, halbe Stunde später. Er kommt nicht vorbei, ich geh noch mal hin. Ja, wie sieht es denn aus? Hast du das Gerät jetzt gefunden? Ah, das Gerät, ne, ich hab noch nicht geguckt, müsste ich jetzt noch mal. Also, gut, dann hat er noch mal geguckt, hat festgestellt, ja er findet es nicht. Es müsste zwar da sein laut Webseite, aber es ist wahrscheinlich noch nicht ausgepackt. Gut, nächste Station, eine Etage tiefer. Wir wollten eine DI-Box kaufen für den Wasser. Wir wussten, was wir wollten. Wir haben es schon im Regal gesehen. Es ging auch vergleichsweise schnell, bis dieses Gerät so schon mal auf diesem Tresen lag. Dann stellte sich aber raus, dass die Adresse, die sie von mir hatten, noch eine alte war. Und die musste jetzt noch mal geändert werden. Und keiner von diesen Personen hinter dem Tresen wusste, wie das geht. Die saßen dann so vor dem Computer und wir standen echt, wir hatten das Gerät schon und es dauerte eine halbe Stunde, bis wir von diesem Tresen wieder weg waren und die Adresse geändert hatten und ihr die Straße buchstabiert hatten und was auch immer. Und die haben auch alle keinen Bock drauf. Die wollen auch gar nicht wissen, wie das funktioniert. Die kümmern sich nicht, die interessiert nicht, was die haben. Du musst dich schon fast überreden, dir was zu verkaufen. Und das ist wirklich extrem krass. Als ich in England war in diesem Endertons-Laden und es war so schön und das Paradies. Und die haben sich gekümmert und alles aufgedrängt. Hier probier doch, egal ob du es kaufst oder nicht. Wir haben gerade nichts zu tun, nimm einfach und spiel ein bisschen rum oder so. Oder hier in dem anderen Podcast haben wir auch schon ein bisschen drüber gesprochen. Der Felix, mit dem ich das mache, der hat von Tomann erzählt, wie so die Tomann-Experience ist da vor Ort. Und auch selbst im Apple Store, wo du ja eigentlich im Vergleich so den krassen Kontrast hast, wo da laufen einfach Leute rum, hier, ich hab so einen Adapter da im Regal gefunden, sofort bezahlen, selbst wenn der Laden knacke voll ist, bist du in 5 Minuten irgendwie raus, wenn du nur ein Adapterkabel willst. Zumindest ging es mir bisher immer so. Und da fängt schon alles an der Tür, wo dieser Security-Typ irgendwie erstmal rumlabert, dass du deine Tasche irgendwie in so ein Schließfach stecken sollst. Und diese ganzen Prozesse, dieses ganze Personal, das ist wirklich ein Zeitloch.
Aber da hatte ich ja richtig Glück, aber ich habe da ja auch was gemacht, das hat die Frau auch ziemlich zur Verzweiflung getrieben. Und zwar, ich wollte ein Kabel haben. Also nicht nur diese vorkonfektionierten mit den Steckern dran, sondern ich wollte halt eins von der Rolle haben. Und dann hat sie erstmal geguckt, was gibt es denn so? Ja, willst du das? Ja. Und dann habe ich gesagt, dass ich das Kabel will. Und dann ist sie dann auch nach hinten marschiert. Und hat halt die Rolle geholt mit dem Kabel. Und dann, ja, wie viele Meter willst du? Ja, so, ich weiß gar nicht, wie viel ich wollte. Sechs Meter oder acht Meter oder irgendwie sowas. Und dann fingen sie an, diese sechs oder acht Meter abzumessen an so einem Mischpult, was wohl, keine Ahnung, wohl ein Meter breit ist oder so. Und fing immer an, dieses Kabel an dem Mischpult ranzuhalten, um einen Meter und noch einen Meter.
Also das ist die totale Antithese des Geschäfts, wie man sich das halt so vorstellt.
Das allerbeste war, ich hatte dann den ganzen Kram zusammen, dann haben sie, also es war irgendwie im dritten, vierten, weiß ich nicht, Stock, und dann haben sie da hinter dem Dings, ja hier, wir müssen jetzt ein Angebot machen, blablabla, haben sie das alles eingetippt und haben mir dann so einen Zettel gegeben. So nach der Art, das ist jetzt der Zettel, damit geht man unten hin zur Kasse. Und dann ist so, ja okay, hab den ganzen Kram genommen, da standen da irgendwie so paar leere Kisten rum und dann hab ich das alles in so einen Karton rein. Und dann meinte die hinter dem Tresen plötzlich so, äh, äh, willst du nicht einen Einkaufskorb haben? Wir haben jetzt Einkaufskorbe! Und ich so, ja okay, dann nehm ich halt einen Einkaufskorb. Und dann hab ich halt den Einkaufskorb bekommen, hab da meinen Zettel reingetan, bin dann mit dem Einkaufskorb runter bis zur Kasse im Erdgeschoss und stell mich dann da an die Kasse und die Frau so, boah, du hast ja einen Einkaufskorb! Wir haben jetzt Einkaufskorbe!
Ja, die haben nämlich, das Personal hat jetzt von dieser Rohrpost.
Was glaubst du, wenn die sich als Freund für die Mitarbeitertoiletten einführen?
Das ist so, und der nächste ist so, wo bin ich hier gelandet?
Die haben nämlich mit diesem Rohrpostsystem, viele haben das schon aufgegeben, also diese DI-Box, die hätte locker in diesen Rohrpostcontainer reingepasst und der Typ meinte so, hier, geh einfach zur Kasse, so wie keine Rohrpost, ist schon okay, ne, einfach. Also das System, das fängt da wahrscheinlich, bläst wahrscheinlich hauptsächlich Staub demnächst, also nicht dagegen. Ja, oder die hatten auch so einen geilen, ich meine, das kann halt mal so technische Pannen, kann schon passieren, aber in dem einen Equipmentraum, wo du halt irgendwie Gitarren ausprobieren kannst, da ging die Tür nicht mehr auf, da war eine Frau drin, die hat irgendwie einen Bass ausprobiert und kam nicht mehr raus, da war kein Schloss dran und nix, die ist einfach zu und ging nicht mehr auf. Und da haben drei Typen, das war eine Glastür, die haben sich jetzt nicht getraut, da gleich die so mit Schwung aufzukicken oder so, haben da so drin rumgewirrt und die saßen eine halbe Stunde in diesem stickend heißen Raum und die haben die Tür nicht aufgekriegt. Naja, aber das so technische Pannen, das kann, das probiere ich jetzt mal noch so, da fehlt jetzt der richtige Millimeter. Juli, also 2 Monate. Aber trotzdem, also es ist einfach eine wirklich beschissene Einkaufs-Experience, das kann man nicht anders sagen. Und abschließend jetzt zu diesem Thema, um jetzt nicht da endlos drüber zu reden, würde ich jetzt auch hier nochmal ganz kurz wirklich sagen, Toman ist ja wirklich, also ich hab's ja schon getwittert irgendwie, ist unfassbar, wie gut der in Service ist. Irgendwie mein Focus-Ride, da ich hab ja die ganzen Kanäle da noch nicht benutzt, dann hab ich so festgestellt, beim 6. und 7. Kanal, da ist irgendwie so hintenrum fehlt so ein bisschen Gain im Vergleich zu den anderen Kanälen, also die sind einfach nicht so laut sozusagen, um's jetzt nochmal platt zu sagen. Und dann hab ich denen das halt so geschrieben, meinte so, meinte so... Und dann meinte sie so, schick mal zurück, hier hast du so einen Retourenschein, wo man halt auch nix bezahlen muss und dann hab ich so zurückgeschrieben, ja wie ist denn das jetzt, wie lange wird denn das so dauern? Und ich hab ja jetzt nicht dieses Außenrum-Verpackungsmaterial mit diesen Luftpolsterfolien und so weiter und überhaupt und sowieso, das dauert so 15 bis 20 Tage.
Und dann meinte ich so, wuuuuh...
Ich hab ja gelesen, ihr habt auch so diese Leihgerätsoption und dann irgendwie klingelte kurz später das Telefon, ja ihr werdet hier noch 25 Mal Mails hin und her schreiben. Wir machen das so, ich schick dir jetzt einfach so ein Leihgerät raus, dann nimmst du die Verpackung davon, schickst eins zu uns und wenn es fertig ist, dann schicken wir alles wieder zurück. Nächsten Tag, also war das wirklich der nächste Tag? Ich glaube ja, es war morgens früh und am nächsten Tag.
Was machen die dann auch gleich?
Genau, heute war das Gerät in der Post, also bei mir, da hab ich gleich Mails reingesteckt.
Und zwar ist es ein identisches Gerät oder was?
Ja, halt so eins, was sie mal B-Stock-Retour hatten oder so, aber ich hab gleich geguckt, irgendwie funktioniert alles talle los und jetzt habe ich für die 15 bis 20 Tage, wo mein Gerät da gecheckt wird, ob es jetzt ein Garantiefall ist oder was auch immer, hab ich jetzt einfach Ersatz da. Es hat mich bisher nichts gekostet. Sie haben halt gesagt, wenn irgendwie was nicht stimmt mit Garantie oder was auch immer, dann muss ich halt vielleicht nochmal das Porto zurückbezahlen oder irgendwie sowas, haben sie gesagt, aber es war jetzt alles bisher absolut zufriedenstand und ich hab gar nicht mich getraut danach zu fragen, so, ja wie sieht es aus? Ihr könnt mir noch ein Leihgerät schicken, dann nehme ich einfach die verpackten Seite und der ruft einfach so an, hier pass auf, wir machen es jetzt so, alles klar? Perfekt! Das war so die kundenorientierteste Lösung, die überhaupt nur hätte auftreten können. Also das macht dann doch irgendwie, freut man sich dann doch, dass es sowas noch gibt.
Dass es sowas überhaupt mal gibt.
Ja, wirklich, also ganz großes Kompliment. Und da bezahle ich halt auch manchmal bei Toman, das ist jetzt auch nicht immer der günstigste Laden. Also manchmal kostet es halt, also die sind schon immer gut dran, aber es gibt halt immer mal so ein paar, so 20, 30 Euro mehr, habe ich schon mal Preisunterschied hier und da gesehen. Aber ganz ehrlich, bei dem Service ist mir das scheißegal, die zahle ich dann im Zweifel gerne, damit ich an so einen Fällen halt irgendwie nicht so Häsel habe.
Wenn Sie sich nochmal irgendwann mal den großen Wurf bei Ihrer Webseite trauen würden?
Na, ich habe ja da so ein bisschen gemurmel gehört, dass Sie da schon drüber nachdenken, aber jetzt haben Sie wohl so ein bisschen zurückgesteckt und wollen jetzt nicht den ganz großen Wurf machen, sondern erstmal doch ein bisschen inkrementeller, erstmal vor allem die Mobile-Webseite und so, weil die ist ja auch usability-technisch eine Katastrophe.
Das Schlimmste ist dieser Warenkorb. Der Warenkorb ist in deinem Browser. Das geht echt überhaupt nicht mehr. 2013. Der ist in deinem Browser, der Warenkorb. Wenn du halt einen anderen Browser nimmst, oder an einen anderen Rechner gehst, hast du halt einen leeren Warenkorb. Gehst du dann wieder aber zum anderen, dann hast du halt wieder dieselben Produkte, die du schon mal zusammengeklickt hast, auch wenn du wahrscheinlich mittlerweile am anderen Rechner saßst, die dir ja dazu geklickt und bestellt hast, wenn du dann das nächste Mal wieder irgendein kleines Kabel bestellst, bestellst du die ganze letzte Bestellung gleich noch mit dazu.
Ja, aber du hast halt keinen Account da, also auch so in dem Sinne.
Doch, du hast da schon einen Account.
Habe ich mich jeweils bei Thomann eingeloggt?
Ja, du hast ja auch Merklisten, ja, stimmt, doch. Ja, kann man sich alles, nur der Warenkorb ist nicht im Account.
So ein Cookie oder sowas.
Sondern der ist halt, genau. Das war wohl irgendwann mal ganz modern und eine tolle Idee, dachte irgendjemand. Das war noch so dieses, wo es nur ein Programm gab, mit dem man das Internet benutzt hat, ja. Auf dem einen Computer, den man hatte. Aber heutzutage, ich wechsle irgendwie, ja, ich wechsle ja meinen Computer häufiger als, den Vergleich spare ich mir jetzt.
Ja, sieht man ja auf Ebay.
Aber ich habe auf jeden Fall jetzt schon gehört, dass sie das auf der Agenda haben. In der einen oder anderen Form werden sie da wohl jetzt schon mal ein bisschen was tun. Das haben sie schon gemerkt, dass ihre Seite da nicht mehr die aktuellste.
Ja, aber die haben natürlich Angst vor solchen Sachen, weil Payment, das ist immer so genau die Stelle, die änderst du immer nicht mal eben.
Den ganzen Shop änderst du nicht mal eben.
Mach mal den wahren Korb neu.
Aber was man ja als kleiner Pro-Tipp jetzt für alle, die sich vielleicht auch in so einer Situation mal wiederfinden, das A-B testet man ja auch. Und released so ein Feature nur an 0,1% der User und guckt erstmal so im kleinen Maßstab, wie es so funktioniert.
Ja klar, wenn du halt in der Lage bist, dein System da auch so zu splitten an der Stelle. Aber das sind halt schon so diese Dinge, die echt weit reichen. Na ja, wie auch immer, so oder so. Das muss geändert werden. Weil was bei den anderen ja alle wunderbar funktioniert, so vor allem bei Amazon, so dieses überall schlägst du was nach und machst deinen Warenkorb voll so über eine Woche. Und dann denkst du ja irgendwann so, will ich das jetzt eigentlich wirklich haben? Und wechselst halt die ganze Zeit die Devices dabei, schmeißt dann vielleicht vorher nochmal drei Sachen raus und den Scheiß kaufst du dann halt auch wirklich.
Ja gut, aber ich mein, es hat halt auch einen Grund, dass Amazon irgendwie die größten sind inzwischen. Weil die haben es halt am griffigsten.
Die haben es schon immer verstanden. Das ist einfach Internet-Checker, da kann man jetzt sagen, was man will.
Auch wenn sie sich jetzt Zeitungen kaufen. Nee, wie war das? Doch.
Naja, der Bezos hat sich eine Zeitung gekauft. Da haben wir letztes Mal schon ein bisschen druegel gerätselt.
Gerätselt ist der richtige Ausdruck.
Wie, ist das eine Kreuzwort-Rätsel-Zeitung oder was?
Nein.
Die New York Times?
Nein, nicht die New York Times.
Ach, ich kenne mich da nicht aus.
Naja, die eine ist in New York und die andere ist in Washington.
Ach so.
Wie der Name schon sagt.
Es wäre witzig, wenn es andersrum wäre.
Die einen schreiben über die Zeiten und die anderen über die Post. Ja, es ist halt dieser Bezos, der ist halt irgendwie so ein bisschen komisch, aber diesen Amazon-Laden, den hat er schon auf eine interessante Art und Weise entwickelt. Also ich weiß nicht, wie es euch ging, aber als ich das erste Mal auf Amazon stieß, dachte ich mir so, okay, die werden gewinnen.
Ja, die haben es verstanden so in dem Sinne.
Das war so mein erster Eindruck, so als ich dieses Thema das erste Mal habe zucken sehen. Ich weiß nicht mehr ganz genau, wann das war. Bestimmt waren ja erstmal nur in den USA so richtig, aber so mit 90s irgendwann dachte ich so, ah, okay, die haben es mit dem Internet verstanden. Gerade im Vergleich zu was du sonst so an Online-Shops und an Ideen wie man mit dem Internet Geld verdienen könnte, da herankam so, Ha, Ha, URLs, die sinnvoll sind, die nicht irgendwie sich alle zwei Stunden ändern und so. Da gab es ja allen möglichen Scheiß. Was damals auch noch sehr beliebt war bei diesen ganzen Shops war immer so, dass oben in der Zeile immer dieselbe URL steht und darunter in so einem Frame ist dann nochmal die eigentliche Webseite, weil die Leute vom Marketing der Meinung wären, oben in der Browserzeile müsste ja immer die URL, die eine, die Marke müsste ja da zu sehen sein und die einfach überhaupt nicht gescheckt haben, was eine URL ist. Ich hoffe, ihr seid irgendwann gefeuert worden, ihr Penner. Ja, weil so viele furchtbare tumme Entscheidungen in dieser Zeit, das kostet einfach alles so viel Geld.
Im Rausch der...
Das ist schlimm, oder? Also es ist wirklich schlimm. Mittlerweile habe ich so langsam den Eindruck, dass zumindest in dieser technischen Elite, also die Leute, die jetzt wirklich so programmieren und Webseiten machen, das, was so eine Webseite ist und wie sie so aufgebaut sein sollte und was so die Mindeststandards sind, hat sich langsam herumgefroren.
2013.
Ja, es gibt immer noch immer noch mal so ein paar Flash-Leichen und so weiter, und Hotels und Gaststätten sind noch ganz sauer.
Wir haben die gleiche Zeit, den gleichen Delay oder Offset, den es gebraucht hat, überhaupt ins Internet zu kommen. Denen gibt es jetzt auch hinten dran, um... Also, ja, die haben dann halt auch mal das Flash dann begraben, wenn dann schon nur noch drei Prozent der Leute überhaupt nur noch Flash ins Internet haben. Ihr habt auch dieses geile Diagramm kürzlich, irgendwie Usage of Internet Explorer and mortality rate oder so Mordopferrate oder irgendwie sowas. Und es ging halt so, die Kurve ging halt parallel runter, sozusagen.
Weil die Leute weniger Internet Explorer benutzt haben.
Warte mal, ich suche das mal gerade raus.
Es war auch irgendwie...
Also so herrlich, irgendwie, weißt du, keine Faktenunterfütterung, einfach so. Oder hier, ich pack's mal.
Bestimmt nicht.
Ja, was auch immer. Also hier, pack's in den Chat, klickt mal alle drauf. Da, bang, ist er auf Facebook. Habt er nur davon. So, da, klickt mal auf.
Facebook.
Einfach mal so kommentarlos Daten zusammengewürfelt.
Ja, ich meine, guck dir mal die Skala an, aber so ein bisschen, so ein bisschen wiederholt sich das ja bei den Mobile-Apps.
Das ist so geil und korrekt.
Ja, ich fand halt auch so eigentlich so die Daten, die sie da präsentieren, jetzt gar nicht mal so spannend, aber so irgendwie diese spezielle Komposition und dieses kommentarlos zusammenwürfeln, ist schon gut.
Wo wir noch bei Hardware und Spenden sind, ich hab ja neulich mal irgendwie über diese großartigen USB-Tastaturkabel...
Können die Leute jetzt aufhören, da trinkst du langsam?
Also wenn ihr noch welche habt, ich nehm gerne noch mehr.
Die Kabel mit den Sicherheitsnups, siehst du, damit man keine anderen Kabel reinsteckt und du wirkst sie trotzdem rein.
Ja, die passen super und die halten einfach fest. Ich meine, guck dir das mal an hier. Ich hab hier einfach so ein Kabel mit Teilen rein.
Ja, natürlich halten die perfekt.
Das ist auch ne geile Länge. Also das ist gerade so diese Netzteil-Länge. Also ich hab das zum Beispiel auch immer on the road immer dabei, so in meiner kleinsten Tasche. Also so mein Default-Ladegerät, was ich immer am Mann hab. Das löst einfach in dieser Länge genau, also normales Ladekabel plus diese Apple-USB-Verlängerung, die immer hält, nicht abgeht. Das ist so genau diese Distanz. Das weiß ich so, im Nachzug von der Steckdose, die irgendwie oben in der Decke ist, runter bis zum unteren Bett. Oder überhaupt von der anderen Seite des Betts bis dahin, wo du es brauchst. Immer diese blöden Situationen, wo du so wie ein Beklopter, kennst du auch diese merkwürdigen Stellungen, die man manchmal bereit ist einzunehmen, nur weil man sich irgendwie seinem Gerät widmen möchte, dieses aber geladen werden muss und die Ladequelle einfach nicht am richtigen Ort ist. Mit diesem Kabel sieht das schon mal ganz anders aus. Das ist einfach toll. Jetzt habe ich noch so ein Kabel entdeckt, wovon man mehrere brauchen kann und was viele Leute immer nicht benutzen.
Das ist auch so eine echt spezielle Kategorie, so ein kleiner Nischen-Betisch. Und worauf stehst du so?
Ich sammle Kabel, die andere Leute meistens nicht brauchen.
Jetzt habe ich gerade so ein unglaubliches Bedürfnis nach diesen Schuko MagSafe-Kabeln.
Schuko MagSafe?
Wenn du so einen Rechner hast, hast du seinen MagSafe und dann gibt es ja diesen kleinen Mini-Euro-Stecker-Schnupsi, den du so draufschieben kannst. Den benutzen ja echt viele Leute. Und dann gibt es dieses massive, dicke, schwere Kabel, mit dem Schuko-Stecker. Davon hatte ich auch mal so einen größeren Vorrat, aber den habe ich jetzt irgendwie aufgebraucht. Und davon könnte man irgendwie auch noch so ein paar gebrauchen. Also wenn ihr der Meta eben eine Freude machen wollt, so einen Kabeln stehe ich drauf. Aber diese USB-Kabel sind auch super. USB-Tastatur verwendet.
Jetzt schnuppst du mit dem Wiederhaken.
Ja, der ist wichtig, der wird dich entscheiden, weil damit machst du quasi eine echte Kabelverlängerung. Und nicht nur so ein komischer Stecker.
Eine Verbindung für die Ewigkeit.
Machst du auch immer den Themen-Tappich wieder, den Themen-Tappich wieder auf dem Schirm?
Richtig, ich muss dazu auch die Mörder-Rate hier mal entfernen.
Ja, machen wir die Mörder-Rate.
Dieses Audios brauchen wir jetzt auch nicht. Audio-Geblinke brauchen wir auch nicht.
Urlaubskabel.
Urlaubsfotos.
Schuko-Stromkabel hast du auch schon.
Hatt ich das mit dem Scan-Snap, das hatte ich vorhin schon erwähnt, oder?
Nee, das war noch in der Pre-Pree-Show.
Ah ja, genau.
Und zwar, wir hatten noch hier vor einigen Folgen recht epische, ausführliche Darlegungen, warum diese Scan-Snap-Scanner von Fujitsu eine tolle Anschaffung sind, wenn man da zu viel Papier und zu viel Geld hat.
Hast mir episch drüber gesprochen.
Also, wieso wie ich jetzt, weil ich hab auch einen bestellt, irgendwie erst gestern. Das hängt so ein bisschen mit der Steuererklärung zusammen, die ich gerade machen muss.
Hast du jetzt einen bestellt mit einem Jahr?
Wie, mit einem Jahr?
Jetzt hast du einen bestellt?
Ja.
Damit du...
Jetzt, an dem ich die Steuererklärung fertig hab. Du meinst, das ist kein guter Move?
Ich weiß nicht, wie das jetzt zusammenhängt.
Na, dass du dem Steuerberater den Kram nicht vorbeitragen musst, sondern hinschicken kannst per E-Mail.
Ach so, du willst das benutzen?
Ich dachte, du kaufst dieses Ding aus der Finanzstrategie.
Boah, sag das doch, dass du den auch benutzen willst.
Der moderne Familienbenutzer, die ganze Familie, trifft sich am Scanner.
Also ich hab mir den Nutze-Steuer- Abschreibungszwecken gekauft.
Papi, was machst du?
Ich muss was scannen. Kann ich mitscannen? Also große Familienparty mit Picknick-Kopf. Teppich wird ausgerollt irgendwie, noch mehr gekömpft.
Oh, leg's noch mal rein.
Genau, das ganze Familiengefühl hat man ganz ganz nahe. Welchen hast du hier gekauft, den ich hab?
Ich mach mal wieder Fenster auf Freunde hier.
Der 500. Genau, das ist The Device, würd ich sagen. Und als wir das ursprünglich mal hier besprochen hatten mit dem X500, wurde ja so ein Feature da gepusht, damit das Ding W-Laden hat. Und dann haben irgendwie alle festgestellt, dass man den vom Mac überhaupt nicht per W-Laden ansprechen kann. Und wahrscheinlich auch vom iPad, weiß gar nicht, hab ich nicht ausprobiert. Und das ist natürlich ein bisschen bekloppt. Und das hat wohl Fujitsu mittlerweile auch eingesehen. Und jetzt gab's vor einer Woche oder zwei einen Software-Update. Gut versteckt auf der Webseite, muss man so richtig danach suchen. Man muss wollen. Man muss auch wissen. Man kann halt Freak Show hören, dann kriegt man so eine Information natürlich frei aus.
Apropos Software-Update, ich hatte da ja so einen Freaking-Moment, als irgendwie sowohl der Drucker als auch die Airport extrem am gleichen Tag der Meinung waren, jetzt ein Software-Update laden zu müssen. Und der Drucker vor allen Dingen, als das dann getan hatte, irgendwie der Meinung war, er hätte kein Software-Update gehabt.
Das ist eine sehr spannende Geschichte.
Ja, ich weiß nicht, dass so mit NSA und so weiter plötzlich software-updates scary.
So, ich guck grad mal hier das Update.
Schnaps-Gun.
Das ist es nämlich nicht, sondern das ist nämlich...
Ach, nicht Settler-Programme, sondern Update.
Es gibt die Treiber und dann gibt's noch mal die Updates, gibt's noch mal in unserem eigenen Tab.
Ah, Betriebssysteme gibt's auch noch mal.
Das hab ich auch noch eine Weile gebraucht, bis ich das gefunden habe. Und ich liefer euch jetzt hier den Link.
Was gibt's denn bei Betriebssystemen bitte für Betriebssysteme? Was? Klick mal auf das Betriebssysteme Tab da oben.
Da kannst du ja noch ein Betriebssystem runterladen.
Das ist, also, das ist auch, da möchte ich gar nicht drüber reden über dieses Video, da fällt's hier.
Ganz viele grüne Haken, irgendwas funktioniert nicht unter XP.
Ja, wesentlich XP wird nicht mehr unterstützt. Gut, aber das hier ist...
Aber nur, aber nur für 64-Bit.
Auch diese Information kommt brüh warm für Freak Show-Hörer exklusiv auf die Trommelstelle.
Ja, da wir als Betriebssystem agnostisch sind, gebe ich das Update hier auch gleich nochmal für Windows mit in den Chat. So, und ich hab's kurz getestet, funktioniert irgendwie. Also man kann jetzt davon ausgehen, dass jetzt die ganze Familie von ihren eigenen Laptops ausgehen kann.
Das beim Scanner ist doch aber auch maximal bekloppt, weil du ja eh zum Scanner laufen musst, um das Papier reinzulegen. Also eigentlich ist es ja total sinnvoll, den Scanner neben dem Gerät zu haben, mit dem du ausscannst.
Ja, schon auch ein bisschen. Also ich würde jetzt auch nicht sagen, dass es besonders viel Sinn macht. Aber es ist halt so, wenn du mal aus irgendwelchen Gründen auch mal von deinem Laptop ausscannen möchtest, dann geht's halt. Du musst da nicht irgendwie USB umstecken oder sonst irgendwie einen Schnaps. Was sicherlich auch noch zu verkraften wäre, aber so ist es nun mal. Und ich bin mir sicher, dass sie auch noch 30 Security-Fehler behoben haben dabei. Wie das so ist.
40 neue eingebaut.
Solche Security-Fehler hat ja übrigens auch Apple eine ganze Menge dokumentiert, dass sie sie gefixt hätten für ihre Developer-Webseite. Nachdem sie jetzt irgendwie, wie lange? Drei Wochen in so einem halbfertigen Zustand war, haben sie es dann irgendwann mal wieder richtig freigeschaltet. Also es ging richtig lange.
Da hab ich ja auch noch einen schönen Nachtrag. Ich hatte kurz bevor der ganze Fu losging, lief ja mein iOS-Developer-Ding ins Aus. Und dann hab ich halt wieder mal die 80 Euro bezahlt und auf den Registrier-Link geklickt, damit irgendwie der Gutscheincode da akzeptiert wird. Und hatte das dann vergessen. Und dann ging halt diese ganze Webseite down. Und dann bekam ich regelmäßig diese Meldung, dass ja, ja mein Programm würde jetzt dann demnächst auslaufen, aber man würde es ja so lange verlängern, bis alles wieder geht und so weiter. Und dann hatte ich irgendwie schon Panik so nach der Art, also sobald es wieder oben ist, muss ich ganz schnell klicken, damit ich irgendwie da weiter Mitglied bin. Aber als es dann oben war, war es okay. Da war es dann noch über ein Jahr, weil es hat ja auch jeder noch einen Monat dazugekriegt, der irgendwie bezahlter, registrierter Entwickler ist. Da haben sie sich ganz fürchterlich entschuldigt und jeder hat einen Monat umsonst gekriegt.
Ja, das ist ja wohl auch das Mindeste, was sie da irgendwie tun können.
Ja, es war vor allen Dingen nervig. Also ich meine...
Bauen sie eigentlich die DT-770 Pro auch als Headset, weil diese Kopfhörer, die machen mich fertig auf meinen Ohren. Ich hab zu große Ohren.
Tatsächlich ja, mit einer Einschränkung. Also gibt es.
Bevor ich was Falsches sage, schlage ich das mal kurz nach.
Wir sind jetzt bei Bayer Dynamik.
Direkt von Apple zu Kopfhörern und Headsets. Jetzt muss ich mal kurz gucken, in welche komische Kategorie sie das jetzt wieder...
Studio, Intercom, Rundfunk, TV?
Studio und Bühne?
Nee, bestimmt Intercom.
Nee, das ist eher Studio...
Headsets für Live-Einsatz.
Nee, Live-Einsatz klingt...
Doch, da.
DT797 PV. DT790. Immerhin, das klingt genau...
Genau, hier das DT790. Das ist im Prinzip das DT770 mit Headset dran. Problem, fest angebautes Kabel. Du kannst das Kabel nicht konfektionieren, wie bei den, die wir hier haben. Und da... Aber du kriegst ja auch heiße Ohren.
Ja, aber die liegen halt so halb auf meinen Ohren. Das sind geschlossene Kopfhörer.
Die liegen auch auf deinen Ohren.
Nee, die liegen außenrum.
Bei mir sind die aus...
Die liegen auf deinen Ohren, die liegen nicht auf deinen Ohren.
Pass auf, ich hab den DT770 Pro, den kann ich den ganzen Tag aufhaben und den nervt mich nicht auf den Ohren. Die hier nerven mich nach einer Stunde halt einfach tierisch schon. Ich will die ganze Zeit so...
Großmutter, warum hast du so große Ohren?
Damit ich besser hören kann.
Ich hab mal auf der Musikmesse mit Bayern Dynamik Leuten gesprochen und fragte, ob sie erwägen, die vielleicht auch mal anders zu bauen. Und sie meinten, ja, sie würden das erwägen.
Gut, aber man könnte jetzt den bestellen, das Kabel so nehmen, wie es da ist, und sich hier auch so einen Stecker-Dingsbumms ja dann ranlöten, also macht man Schnipschnap.
Ja, muss er halt selber löten.
Macht man halt hier so... Macht man halt da so Schnipschnap und macht sich selber.
Also ich hab bei dem DT 770 auch mal das Kabel getauscht, nachdem es einen Kabelbruch hatte. Das ist nicht so fürchterlich schwierig.
Wie viel kostet denn der?
Also du schraubst das Ding halt auf und dann lötest du ein neues Kabel an. Also das ist irgendwie jetzt kein Voodoo.
Ja, wenn das schon in richtiger konfektionierter Form ist.
Puh, 229 Euro.
Ja, du kannst ja da das Kabel nachbestellen. Bei denen.
Kosten solche hältst du jetzt dann eben, ne? Ja, aber ein guter Kopfhörer mit gutes Mikrofon.
Ich meine, ich podcaste ja auch und so langsam nervt mich ja doch schon dieses Mikrofon, also dieses Setup, was ich da hab, mit dem Kondensatomikrofon sozusagen auf Stativ vor meiner Nase. Aber die hier, die könnte ich halt nicht ertragen, vielleicht probier ich ja den mal aus. Dann bring ich meinen eigenen Kopfhörer mit.
Also kannst du mit offenen Enden kaufen.
Na, ist kein Stecker dran sozusagen.
Genau, also mit Litze und dann bastelst du dir dann, also dann kannst du selber schnell mal da dein Dings ranmachen.
Du kannst natürlich auch den vierpoligen nehmen und dir einen Adapter-Stecker.
Ja, das wäre sehr damit. Stereo hast?
Vier ist allerdings wirklich ein bisschen strange.
Aber es wahrscheinlich...
Nee, irgendwo muss ja das Mikrofon auch noch durch.
Na, du hast wahrscheinlich, du hast wahrscheinlich zwei Pole fürs Mikrofon, die Masse am Gehäuse und halt noch mal zwei Pole für rechts links.
Ach so, die Masse machen sie nur über den Schirm sozusagen?
Möglicherweise. Also so würde ich es machen. Ob das so schlau ist, das ist eine andere Frage. Aber, also wenn er nicht mono ist, aber das kann ich mir nicht vorstellen.
Na ja, da wird es schon irgendeinen Weg geben.
Gibt es mit Limiter und ohne Limiter.
Was ist denn der Limiter?
Ein Limiter ist halt nochmal ein Limiter drin. Ab einer bestimmten Lautstärke macht er dicht. Das ist halt so ein Sicherheitsfeature, weil du in Environments bist, wo du nicht sicherstellen kannst, dass es da nicht zu laut kommt. Dass er einfach dicht macht ab einer bestimmten Lautstärke.
Wenn du deinem Tonmann nicht vertraust.
Ja, was weiß ich, oder deinem Equipment. Neuartiger drehbarer Schwanenhals-Mikrofonarm. Neuartig. Das ist der gleiche, den wir hier auch haben.
Naja, also das werde ich mal in Betracht ziehen.
Ich würde den auch gerne mal testen, aber ich kann mir doch auch vorstellen, dass der voller ist. Also stimme dir ja zu, der DT-770 ist ein ganz grandioser Kopfhörer. Ich hab den auch und sieht halt nochmal ein Zacken affiger aus, wenn du die Dinger aufhast.
Ja, aber ist halt bequemer.
Das hättest du nicht sagen sollen. Jetzt muss ich auch die ganze Zeit sagen.
Ich muss dir den Flo in den Ohr setzen, damit du natürlich diese Bestellung... zündest.
Wir sollten mehr über Macs reden. Hattest du nicht noch interessante Erkenntnisse zu Achtung, R-Quotes, Window-Managern?
Ah ja, genau.
Da gibt's so eine kleine Applikationsgattung auf dem Mac, um... wir nennen es jetzt mal Window-Manager, weil es auf dem Mac dieses Konzept ansonsten jetzt nicht so direkt gibt. Was die tun, ist halt, man kann sozusagen Fenster anordnen und seinen Screen-Estate maximal nutzen und man kann irgendwie mit Tastenkürzeln beliebige Applikationsfenster in Ecken schieben oder zum Beispiel so Halb-Halb-Aufteilung, also Anwendungsfall, man hat vielleicht zwei Terminals und man will genau 50% links, rechts diese Fenster mit einem Tastaturkürzel hinschieben oder will eine Applikation in Fullscreen machen oder man will halt irgendwie vier Terminals untereinander, quadratisch wie auch immer angeordnet und die sollen sich halt nicht überlappen und es soll schnell gehen, ohne mit der Maus halt die Fenster so zu verschieben, dann sind doch wieder ein paar Pixel nicht richtig und so weiter und so fort. Und da gibt es im Wesentlichen auf dem Mac drei ernst zu nehmende Vertreter. Es gibt noch viel mehr, aber ich finde die drei, die ich jetzt gleich nenne, sind die einzig ernst zu nehmenden. Es gibt zum einen, das heißt DIVVY, das gibt es auch schon sehr lange. Ich paste mal hier diese Links. Wo ist dieser OS X, wie finde ich das jetzt hier mal gerade?
Misage.
Das interessante an Divi ist, das gibt es, wenn ich mich richtig erinnere. Sogar auch für Windows. Erster Contender, DIVVY. Zweiter Contender ist SIZE UP heißt das, glaube ich. Ich gucke nochmal. Ist das die Webseite? Heißt die wirklich SIZE UP? Das sind aber auch immer so Namen. DIVVY ist wenigstens ganz gut zu finden. Da, von Irradiated Software. Und dann gibt es noch eins und das ist Open Source und lebt auf GitHub. Und das heißt Shifted. Und warum sind die die einzig ernst zu nehmen in meiner Wahrnehmung? Weil die so im Prinzip alle meine Feature-Wünsche erfüllen. Das ist zum einen, dass du mit Shortcuts halt die Fenster in alle möglichen Positionen schieben kannst. Zum anderen kannst du die Shortcuts editieren. Du kannst ja auch selber Presets definieren und sie kommen mit multiplen Screens klar. Weil es gibt einige von diesen Window-Managers, die immer nur einen Screen beherzigen. Oder du musst mit der Maus auf dem Screen sein, wo du gerade die Windows resizen willst und so weiter. Und die können halt durch Wiederholung des Shortcuts oder durch einen anderen Shortcut die Positionierung auch auf anderen Screens dann vornehmen. Und ich hab die alle eigentlich getestet, weil ich das schon immer eigentlich ganz cool fand. Und erst war ich mit allen irgendwie unzufrieden. Jetzt hab ich mich doch auf einen eingelassen, auf Dauer, und das ist Divi. Der Divi, der hat noch im Vergleich zu den anderen ein leicht anderes Konzept, weil da kann man erstmal seinen Screen in so einen Grid aufteilen und kann dann auf diesem Grid frei neue Presets definieren. Also alle Formen und Farben und so weiter, also Farben nicht, aber Formen kann man da schon mal sich vordefinieren und mit Shortcuts belegen. Und es kommt halt mit mehreren Screens klar. Und es ist der Schnellste oder der, weiß nicht, der am ersten irgendwie das machte, was ich wollte, ohne da groß rumzufrickeln. Und ganz oft bei diesen Window-Managers ist so das Problem, dass sie dann doch irgendwelche Margins nicht richtig machen oder dann doch wieder überlappt oder manchmal hakelts. Ganz komisch. Und der Divi ist der, der irgendwie am schmerzfreisten, am schnellsten und genau das tut, was ich will. Genau. Und das ist halt auch ganz praktisch, zum Beispiel bei Präsentationen manchmal, wenn man so irgendwie einen Beamer hat und man hat dann nur 1024 und jetzt muss das Terminal und der Browser irgendwie schnell mal eben perfekt angeordnet werden, dann kann man da mit diesem Grid, was man einblenden kann, eben auch mal eben schnell diese Fenster so platzieren, dass sie einfach da passen. Und du musst halt in diesem Modus, mach mal nochmal dieses Grid auf, Tim probiert das gerade auf, zieh mal einfach ein Rechteck daneben. Es gibt halt auch einen Shortcut, den du dir dann konfigurieren kannst in den Settings.
Genau, so macht man das.
Und wenn du dann auf dieses Rädchen klickst, da kommst du halt ins Menü. Also okay, vom User-Interface könnte man jetzt noch anmengeln, dass so in die Preferences da, dass das alles so in diesem Head-Up-Display lebt. Und nicht in so einem typischen OS X-Preference-Screen, aber ja.
Naja, das hat man bei Alfred ja auch.
Ich mag die Vise ja.
Ja, aber wenn das Ding hier aktiv ist, ist irgendwie die Maus super mega slow hier gerade.
Du kannst halt auch einstellen, normalerweise ist es halt eben so, der Resize da, wo deine Maus ist. Das heißt, du hast jetzt ein Fenster im Vordergrund, machst Divi an und da, wo die Maus ist, da packt er das Fenster hin. Aber du kannst in den Settings einstellen, dass du durch wiederholendes Shortcuts das einfach sozusagen auf all deine Screens cykeln kannst. Und Size Up macht im Prinzip das gleiche, aber das war halt so von diesen Margins und den Grid Spacing und so, das war halt mir zu unflexibel und dann war entweder waren die Fenster genau klatsch dicht aneinander oder zu weit weg oder dann hatten sie Rand am am Bildschirmrand und solche Geschichten. Also irgendwie so ein bisschen immer hat immer so ein bisschen nicht das gemacht, was ich wollte. Es hat mich dann am Ende in den Wahnsinn getrieben. Und Perfektionist. Wenn schon Screen Estate, dann aber auch richtig. Und Shifted ist eigentlich ziemlich cool. Dafür vor allen Dingen, weil es Open Source ist. Da hat gerade einer im Chat gesagt, dass man mal Shifted, ne, Tim hat die Regen ab wieder ausgemacht. Also das ist auf jeden Fall die Alternative, wenn man halt irgendwie nichts dafür ausgeben will und trotzdem viele Features haben will. Es ist halt auch nicht ganz perfekt und manchmal irgendwie auch ein bisschen hakelig oder langsam beim Fenster resizing. Deswegen habe ich es halt auch am Ende dann wieder nicht benutzt. Von den Features her kann es aber eigentlich alles, was man braucht. Das ist tatsächlich merkwürdig, den habe ich nicht.
Kleiner Nachtrag, ich habe hier bei Biodynamic jetzt nochmal ins Datenblatt geguckt. Und solltest du diesen Kopfhörer kaufen, willst du auf jeden Fall nicht den XLR4-Polic kaufen, weil der ist nur mono.
Tatsächlich?
Ja, nach der Verschaltung ist der ganz klar nur mono. Und Shield ist auch noch an der Masse dran. Das heißt, im Zweifelsfall brummt der auch noch. Also nimm lieber den, der die offene Litze hat und verkabel ihn richtig.
Wenn er genug Litzen hat?
Der hat genug Litzen. Also da kannst du richtig verkabeln. Dann kannst du den Mikrofon-Teil an ein normales dreipoliges XLR machen und den Kopfhörer-Teil an eine große Klinke oder whatever. Aber da unten diese vier Pole, das ist... Also ich weiß nicht, wer sich das ausgedacht hat, aber es ist Unsinn.
Na ja gut, wenn du halt nur ein Mono brauchst. Ich meine, hier der Podcast.
Ja, aber du hast trotzdem eine der beiden Signalleitungen vom Mikrofon hast du am Shield. Und das willst du eigentlich nicht haben. Weil dadurch ist dein Mikrofon nicht mehr symmetrisch. Ne, das Problem, also ich erklär's kurz. Das Problem, das Problem an dem, wenn das Shield und eine der Signalleitungen zusammengelegt ist, ist, dass wenn du eine Brummeinstreuung hast, dann wird dein Shield immer zu Masse gezogen. Das heißt, die eine Signalleitung kriegt einen Brumm ab und die andere Signalleitung wird aber zu Masse gezogen. Das heißt, du hast den Brumm und die zu Masse gezogenen Signalleitung hast du den Brumm drauf. Wenn aber beide Signalleitungen von der Masseleitung getrennt sind, dann ist die Brummeinstreuung auf beiden Signalleitungen ungefähr gleich groß und hebt sich deswegen auf. Deswegen willst du, das nennt man symmetrisch, deswegen willst du ein Mikrofonkabel immer so haben, dass es symmetrisch ist. Und nie, dass es asymmetrisch ist, sprich ein Pol an die Masse rangeklemmt.
Und wenn man das nicht hat, wenn es da erst mal noch eine Klinke gibt...
Und genau den Unsinn machen sie bei diesem vierpoligen XLR. Ne, das will man nicht.
Und wenn man es halt nicht anders kriegt aus seinem Gerät, dann kann man die Eyebox nämlich vorhin erwähnt haben und aus dem unsymmetrischen Symmetrisches machen. Voll gut.
Und plötzlich ist dann alles schön.
So, haben wir noch ein Thema.
Ja, wir haben noch so ein paar Kleinigkeiten. So, ich überlege gerade, wie man da hier am besten sich ran traut. Es ist alles so divers. Eigentlich müsste man immer so das Gespräch geschickt darauf leiten.
Ja, auch heute keine Übergänge.
Aber, ja, kommen wir jetzt zum Internet.
Mal wieder.
Was war das?
Das mit den Keksen.
Hast du da einen guten Übergang?
Wir brauchen heute keine Übergänge.
Vergiss es einfach.
Wir müssen mal mehr über DNS reden. Und vor allen Dingen, damit Clemens jetzt auch Spaß hat, da auf der Fähre, wenn er uns zuhört und sich schon mal ein paar Haare wieder raufen kann.
Hast du eine Tischkante, in die du beißen kannst?
Müsste der nicht irgendwie mittlerweile drüber sein?
Also kurz, ich kann ja mal einfach drauf losreden, zum Thema Public DNS Resolver. Also für alle, die sich mit DNS noch nicht befasst haben, da gibt es quasi so zwei Arten, wie man DNS spielen kann.
Also wovon reden wir jetzt genau? Wir reden jetzt von dem DNS-Server, den man gerne benutzen will oder auch nicht.
Ja, wir reden von dem einen Typen, nämlich dem Resolver, wo man halt nachguckt, welche IP-Adresse hinter google.com steht. Die man eigentlich von seinem Provider oder da, wo man gerade Netz bekommt, gleich mitgenommen bekommt.
Resolver würde ich ja jetzt erstmal als die Software, die bei mir lokal im Auftrag der Programme loszieht und anfängt, verschiedene Quellen zu befragen, übersetzen. Das ist der Resolver, der vielleicht auch erstmal in meiner ETC-Hosts-Datei nachschlägt oder sonst irgendwelchen. Du weißt, damals gab es noch so ein NetInfo und so. Aber du redest von einem DNS-Server. Du redest von etwas, was per DNS eine Frage kriegt und das per DNS beantwortet.
Genau. So ein Recursive Public Resolver, würde ich das jetzt mal nennen. Tischkante?
Oder Server?
Na, er surft ja nicht richtig. So ein DNS-Server, der halt Zonen hostet, ja, also so surft so, das ist ja dann schon eher... Die Begriffe sind für mich da auch so nicht so ganz klar. Da kann jetzt Clemens ja, wie gesagt, die Tischkante schon mal vornagen und nächstes Mal nochmal in den Spänen lesen. Aber, aber nicht, dass du trotzt. Also es geht um den DNS-Server, den man bekommt, wenn man hier so per DHCP eine IP-Adresse von seinem Provider oder von irgendwo, wo man sich gerade ins Netz einbucht, bekommt, wo der eigene Rechner nachfragt, ja bitte, was ist jetzt die IP-Adresse von www.google.com? So, erstmal, die erste Frage ist natürlich klar, warum macht denn das jetzt mein Rechner nicht einfach gleich selber? Warum muss der den Server fragen? Es hat so Vorteile, weil diese Server halt auch cashen und wenn da so ganz viele Leute die ganze Zeit Anfragen stellen, dann gehen die babbeln die halt nicht durchs ganze Internet und durchs ganze DNS-System, sondern die bleiben dann erstmal so eine Weile einfach nur auf dem einen Knoten und füttern, werden aus dem so einen Cash gefüttert sozusagen. Und damit das immer, wenn der Cash halt voll ist, dann gehen diese Anfragen auch sehr viel schneller, als wenn der eigene Rechner bei jeder einzelnen Domain das ganze DNS-System abklappern müsste nach den Antworten. So, und ich hab halt so einen Public Resolver quasi betrieben, lange Zeit. Und den haben auch einige genutzt, weil ich hab auch nix gelockt und der war halt unzensiert. Wir erinnern uns an die Stoppschilder, die irgendwie hier mal eingeführt wurden, die auf DNS ja auch basiert waren.
Gibt's die eigentlich noch?
Keine Ahnung. Auf jeden Fall war es ein unabhängiger Resolver. Das war so das Einzige, was ich gesagt habe, hatte ich auf dem Blog und war auch irgendwie im Internet so ein bisschen bekannt und den muss ich jetzt ausmachen. Denn der wurde jetzt für DNS-Amplification-Attacken benutzt. Wie das halt leider mit sehr vielen Public Resolvern, die halt unrestriktiv sind, alle Netze zulassen, von überall auf der Welt kann man ihn halt fragen. Und die sind halt beliebtes Ziel für diese DNS-Amplification-Attacks.
Was ist das?
Im Wesentlichen. Also ich glaube, das übliche Szenario, es gibt glaube ich auch andere Wege, wie das funktioniert ist. Irgendjemand hackt so einen autoritären, hätte ich beinahe gesagt, aber einen, der Zonen hostet, also der sagt hier, wir sind google.com und es gibt diese Subdomains und so weiter. So ein DNS-Server wird halt gehackt. Dann machen die da so einen Rekord rein, der wahnsinnig groß ist, also maximale Größe von so einem DNS-Paket auf UDP. Dann kommt so ein Botnetz daher und macht auf diesen Public Resolver Anfragen auf diesen Rekord. Sie bufen uns die IP-Adresse und schreiben in die Empfänger, also die anfragende IP-Adresse, zum Beispiel whitehouse.gov, die IP-Adresse rein. Jetzt passiert halt Folgendes. Die ganzen Anfragen trommeln jetzt bei diesem Resolver ein aus dem Botnet. Der fragt beim autoritären Nameserver, was ist jetzt der Rekord, der hier abgefragt werden soll. Er kriegt diese riesige Antwort zurück und weil die IP-Adresse auf UDP gespufft ist und immer auf das gleiche Target zeigt, kommen dann die Responses von diesen ganzen Public Resolvern auf der ganzen Welt. Die trommeln dann alle auf diesem einen Punkt ein und machen halt DDoS quasi.
Du schickst eine Anfrage hin mit einer gespufften Antwort und dein Resolver antwortet an die gespuffte...
Genau, attackiert quasi dann...
Du schickst eben eine Antwort. Auf welcher Frage?
Wie gesagt, UDP. Also du schickst dem ein Paket, gib mir mal die Information.
Also ich fahre nochmal.
Der Angreifer.
Ganz ruhig. Angenommen, wir wollen jetzt mal metaebene.fm, ist die Adresse?
Jetzt bringen wir hier die Leute nicht auf schlechte Ideen.
Angenommen, man wollte jetzt nsa.gov, DDoSen. Den Host. Den Host, der unter NSA, GOV ist. Was auch immer da ist, genau.
Also nicht die DNS-Infrastruktur.
Irgendein IP, irgendein Host.
A-Rekord.
Irgendwas willst du DDoSen mit DNS-Paketen. So, jetzt hackst du dir irgendeinen DNS-Server, der irgendeine Zone hostet. Irgendein Typ, der halt gedacht hat, ich mach jetzt mein eigenes DNS, ich hab jetzt mydomain.com, ich mach meinen eigenen autoritativen, wie sagt man das in Deutsch? Authoritative Nameserver. Weißt du, wie in der Uni, wo wir halt digitaludkberlin.de und so selber verwaltet haben. Wir betreiben unseren eigenen DNS-Server. So, jetzt würde der Angreifer halt einen dieser Server hacken und da in den Zonen an einem mega großen Rekord, maximale DNS-Paketgröße einen Rekord platzieren. Na, das ist halt so Hack-Sport, irgendwelche Büchsen aufmachen, ach, hier ist so ein DNS-Server offen, super, kann ich ja für so eine DNS-Amplification-Attacke benutzen.
Also das ist sozusagen die Voraussetzung. Das ist jetzt nichts, was allein over the wire stattfinden kann.
So, also das ist die Voraussetzung. Du hast den, du hast eine bekannte URL, du hast den Nameserver dafür gehackt, du packst da einen riesen Record rein.
Also wir müssen jetzt irgendwie, um mal beim Beispiel zu bleiben, der NSA irgendwie einen DNSer war?
Nee, irgendeinen.
Achso, irgendeinen?
Irgendein, irgendein Domain.
Den von gmx.de zum Beispiel.
Ja, irgendwas. So, hacken wir jetzt, packen diesen ewig langen DNS...
Gut, dass wir noch keine Transkription haben.
Jetzt lass mich mal hier... Packen diesen Record rein. So, jetzt hast du ein Bot-Netzwerk. Und in diesem Bot-Netzwerk sagst du Public Resolver, so wie ich ihn betrieben hab, auf der ganzen Welt gibt es eben so eine Liste. Alle, die du im Internet finden kannst, kompilierst du dann halt so eine Liste mal von Public Resolvern, die offen sind und aus der ganzen Welt Anfragen annehmen. Gib mir mal die Adresse von meinegeiledomain.de, ja? Die dann Recursive sozusagen im Internet durchspülen, wenn sie es nicht im Cache haben und halt überall mal nachfragen. Und dann geben sie ja die Antwort zurück sozusagen. So, dieses Bot-Netzwerk, erkennt jetzt also diese Public Resolver, und schickt jetzt eine Anfrage für diesen mega großen Rekord auf dem gehackten Nameserver. Und spooft die Absenderadresse, wo sozusagen die Antwort zurückkommen würde von den Resolvern.
Ja, also Bot fragt Resolver, gib mir mal den Rekord.
Und schreibt nicht seine IP-Adresse rein.
Den großen Rekord. Und ach, übrigens, aber ich bin der und dir dabei.
Das gibt sich aus, als die zu attackierende Maschine.
So, und jetzt kommt halt von diesen ganzen Public Resolvern so schön distributed, kommen halt diese ewig langen DMS-Rekords. Genau, und ballert halt einfach so die ganzen DMS-Rekorden. Und es ist schon ganz pfiffig, weil DMS ja, also es geht ja auch in TCP, aber so der übliche Pfad ist eigentlich UDP. Und da nutzt man halt aus, dass eben keine Connection ist, sondern so stateless und du kannst halt IP spoofen und es ist halt eher schwer bis aufwendig oder unmöglich, das im großen Maßstab zu validieren, dass die auch wirklich die richtigen IPs sind. Dieser ganze Käse ist halt alles so, es geht schon irgendwie, aber es ist auch nicht so trivial. Und wenn man sich nicht damit auskennt und einfach so einen Public Resolver da erstmal so hinhängt und sagt ja, Internet, frei, Liebe.
Dein Server, der für die Liebe war, hat den ganzen Tag irgendwie NSA-Golf gedetost und du wusstest nichts davon.
Und das fiese ist halt, dadurch, dass es so viele Resolver gibt und die dir im Zweifel auch nur eine Anfrage schicken, weil dann, also, sagen wir mal so, wenn sie halt genug Public Resolver haben, dann kann der Traffic für den einzelnen Resolver relativ klein ausfallen, dass es dir nicht mal in irgendwelchen Graphen auffällt, dass du an einem DDoS teilnimmst, weil du halt immer nur so, was weiß ich, 4 Kilobytes oder so mal hier so und da so raus pustest, so über den Tag verteilt. Weißt du, wenn da so viel Traffic auf so einem Public Resolver ist, dann fällt so dieser DDoS-Traffic da gar nicht sozusagen groß ins Gewicht. Das ist halt auch noch so das Fiese dabei. Die hämmern jetzt gar nicht so auf die Public Resolver auf, damit die das gar nicht checken und immer schön bereit sind, um mal hier und da so ein paar Pakete abzugeben. So und jetzt hab ich sozusagen von dem vom Provider jetzt erstmal gesagt, du bräuchst es doch jetzt, um das Ganze laufen zu lassen, bräuchst du ja eigentlich noch nicht mal in den Server hacken.
Vielleicht ein bisschen zu einfach, um dann selbst sich zu verraten, aber rein technisch würde das auch gehen.
Genau.
Das Wichtige ist halt nur, dass es eben eine ordentlich registrierte Domain ist.
Also zur Not macht das Botnetz halt auch mal schnell DNS-Server auf.
So viele offene Resolver?
Na, es werden jetzt weniger. Ganz stark. Der größte Public Resolver ist halt Google, ne? Die haben einen Blogpost geschrieben, pack ich mal aus meiner Reading List auch rein. Was sie alles so tun und wie sie so für ihre Sicherheit sorgen. Oh Gott, wo ist es denn jetzt? Meine Reading List ist doch gar nicht so lang.
Ich hab's doch da reingepackt, ich bin mir ziemlich sicher. Ach, dieses Reading List Feature ist auch eine Scheiße.
Genau, Security Benefits oder so. Da stehen auf jeden Fall einige Taktiken drin. Ich muss jetzt ja meinen Resolver erstmal vom Netz nehmen, weil der Provider gesagt hat, wir kriegen hier so viele Abuse-Mails für die IP, kannst du da mal irgendwas machen. Und ich hab's jetzt erstmal so auf bestimmte Netze restriktiert und werde jetzt so mal die Tage, wenn ich mal ein bisschen Zeit hab, mal dieses Google-Ding durchlesen und gucken, was ich so alles davon umsetzen kann, um sozusagen diese DDoS oder diese Amplification-Attacke möglichst klein zu halten. Ja, du knisterst und schmatzt.
Du knisterst und schmatzt, deswegen hab ich dir dein Mikrofon ausgeschaltet, Roddy.
Boah, bist du gemein, ich möchte weiterhin knistern und schmatzen.
Ja, deswegen, falls jemand den 194.95.202.198 als Fabrik Uesolver irgendwo eingetragen hatte, das müsst ihr jetzt mal sein lassen für eine Zeit lang und ich sag auf Twitter Bescheid, wenn ich ein neues Setup am Start hab mit schlauen Taktiken, um da möglichst wenig andere Leute mitzustehen kann. Steht zum Beispiel auf ccc.de im DNS-How-To als...
Ja, aber meinst du, das würde ich Leute manuell zusammensammeln?
Ich hab's auf meiner Webseite, ich hab's hier im Podcast schon...
Ja, aber ich meine, bitte, wenn du ein Botnetz... Du fängst doch nicht an, dir alle Webseiten durchzulesen, um nach DNS-Reservaten zu suchen. Die scannen die doch.
Das gibt, ja, scannen oder es gibt halt irgendwann irgendwie so zusammen, weißt du schon, so Listen, die dann immer so wachsen und keine Ahnung. Ich weiß es nicht, wie sie die finden, aber meiner ist auf jeden Fall einer dieser Listen mit dabei. So viel kann ich sagen. Also es gibt zum Beispiel eine Taktik, dass du halt sagst, dass du die Paketgröße auf UDP halt aufs Minimum reduzierst sozusagen und dann muss der Client halt auf TCP wechseln. Also du gibst ihm sozusagen den Anfang der Antwort und dann gibst du noch mit Truncated. Und wenn er dann mehr will, muss er sozusagen auf TCP wechseln. Und dann kannst du halt Rate Limiten und IP spoofen geht dann nicht mehr und so viel, so ein Krimpel. Muss ich halt mal so ein bisschen rumprobieren. Jetzt fragt ja einer, welche DNS-Server fände ich denn? Fürs Hosten benutze ich NSD, heißt der. Glaub ich, doch, NSD. Und der andere, der fürs Resolven, der ist Unbound und die sind alle von diesem, wie heißen die in Holland, die da Unbound DNS, wie heißen die doch gleich? Die halt, verdammt, wie heißen die? NL Labs, genau. Die betreiben, glaube ich, auch einen Route Name Server. Auf jeden Fall sind die auch so ganz aktiv in der Internetinfrastruktur involviert. Ja, die machen beide, glaube ich. Und die verwende ich und die sind eigentlich auch ganz toll, aber ich muss halt auch ein bisschen so als Packet-Filter und mir diesen Blog-Poster mal durchlesen und mich ein bisschen schlau machen, was man da eigentlich überhaupt tun kann, alles genau. Na, wie gesagt, das ist halt auch relativ hintergründlich, so diese Amplification-Attacks, aber die wohnen, glaube ich, zum Beispiel bei diesem einen Spam-Haus, genau. Da haben sie das unter anderem benutzt und diesen Spam-Blacklist-Provider, was auch immer, wegzudehdossen.
So, wo wir bei Kleinigkeiten aus dem Internet sind, fällt mir dabei gerade ein, dass ja up.net ein Jahr alt geworden ist.
Was?
up.net? Gibt's noch?
Ich könnte mal wieder so einen kleinen starten.
Wir hatten da, glaube ich, schon länger nichts mehr zu. Ja, gibt da auch nicht so mega viel zu berichten. Auf jeden Fall haben sie jetzt sozusagen genau ein Jahr des Betriebs hinter sich. Sie meinen, dass sie ganz gut dastehen. Das ist sicherlich Ansichtssache, aber man kann schon sagen, dass in dem Jahr eigentlich eine ganze Menge passiert ist. Sie haben jetzt vor allem auch mit der Jahresverkündung hier ein paar neue Marschruten und Erinnerungen gegeben. Zum Beispiel werden sie für Messages und für Petaroms, also sozusagen in ihrer Message-AP, also sozusagen Privatnachrichten schicken oder eben so Chat-Räume befüllen. Wollen sie einfach das Message-Limit auf 2048 hochsetzen? Also das sind so knapp achtfache von dem senden können pro Nachricht, was jetzt ist, wo ich sagen würde, okay so zwei Kilobyte, mehr schreibt man nicht, bis man einmal Return drückt. 256 Zeichen.
Bevor man einmal Send drückt, Return kannst du relativ oft drücken. Sogar 2048 mal. Ja nicht, dass die Leute in den Kommentaren wieder sagen.
Wir hätten ja nicht alle Rosinen gepickt.
Genau.
Ja und dann haben sie vor kurzem auch dieses Search-RP eingeführt, die jetzt so in zunehmendem Maße in die Clients einfließt. Also man kann jetzt sozusagen auf diesem ganzen Kram auch suchen. Also derzeit nur die Posts, aber für den Rest kommt das wohl auch. Naja und so etwas ominös reden sie eben von weiteren Apis, die irgendwie da noch kommen sollen. Ich meine eins steht auf jeden Fall noch aus, was sie nicht gebracht haben bisher, ist halt diese Billing-Api. Die haben sich vor Monaten angekündigt, aber da tut sie irgendwie wenig. Keine Ahnung, ob das so die Intention war, dass es so lange dauert, aber ich bin nicht so ein bisschen überrascht, weil wenn es um Geld geht, ist immer so so eine Sache. Man muss mal mal gucken, wie es weitergeht, aber meine Twitter-Absilenz ist mittlerweile extrem geworden.
Ich weiß nicht, wie das bei euch so ist. Twitter?
Jetzt mal ganz ehrlich.
Also ich bin uns gerade tatsächlich so gut wie gar nicht mehr abdeutet und gelegentlich Twitter.
Aber du reagierst noch auf Nachrichten.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher.
Du bist dir nicht sicher.
Warte mal, ich muss mal gerade gucken. Das Problem ist nämlich, dass Kiwi irgendwann gesagt hat, so jetzt gibt es hier keine ewig lange Trial, so jetzt musst du mal kaufen und dann dachte ich mir, weiß jetzt nicht und dieser Wedge, den ich sonst benutzt habe, der ist mir halt zu hässlich und dann habe ich es jetzt irgendwie so ein bisschen in der Ecke stauben lassen.
Ja, ja, Mac-Klines sind irgendwie generell ein Problem und ich frage mich auch ehrlich gesagt so ein bisschen, woran das liegt. Ich meine, das ist ja bei Twitter auch nicht so sehr viel anders. Ich benutze auf dem Desktop gar Twitter oder app.net mehr, ich mache das nur noch über iOS.
Auch interessant.
Da kann ich irgendwie nicht so gut tippen.
Nee, da kann ich auch nicht so gut tippen. So für den schnellen Brainfahrt zwischendurch?
Das Problem habe ich nicht. Meine Brainfahrts sind relativ langsam. Ich komme da mit einem Tippen hinterher.
19 Notifications, zeig sie mir doch, wo sind sie denn?
Da ich sowieso im Kopf erstmal eine Runde rumformuliere, bis das irgendwie, also nicht im Mund, aber gerne mal, ja, bis das so rund ist und so die Fakten in der Reihenfolge ausgepackt werden, dass es einen maximalen Gag hat, ist es dann egal, wie schnell ich das dann hinterher tippe.
Gut, das war es eigentlich zu dem Thema.
Das war ja kurz und schmerzlos.
Das war kurz und schmerzlos, genau, so soll es ja auch immer sein. Meine Themenliste schlecht sortiert.
Oder auch gar nicht.
Wir haben ja noch was von dir, Muckel.
Shameless Pluck the Second.
Weil Trotti nicht mal noch mal irgendwas beitragen möchte.
Wie gesagt, nur Kleinkram. Wir hatten so lange nichts mehr über ZFS. Dann bringe ich jetzt mal ein kleines, ein ganz kleines Titbit zum Thema ZFS. Und zwar hat sich doch jemand mal die Mühe gemacht und mal so ein Google Doc-Teil angelegt, wo sämtliche draußen verfügbaren ZFS-Versionen verglichen werden mit Features. Und zwar relativ ausführlich, wenn ich das mal so sagen darf. Und zwar gibt es ja dieses Mac ZFS Stable, was hier ganz links die erste Spalte gleich ist, was irgendwie noch auf einer Zpool-Version 9 oder 8 oder so ist, also richtig alt. Und es gibt halt seit einiger Zeit diesen, hier in der dritten Spalte Mac ZFS Prototype genannt, wo halt jemand ZFS on Linux zurück nach Mac portiert. Ich hatte ja vor Monaten schon mal davon geredet, dass da irgendwie ein Mensch, der sich Lundmann nennt, sich da hervortut. Ich krieg da ab und zu immer mal wieder eine Mail, wo der auf GitHub mal wieder einen Bug schließt, den er gefixt hat. Und also wenn der so in der Geschwindigkeit weiter macht, dann wird das auch noch was. Also der ist da sehr emsig. Allerdings, ja, keine Ahnung.
Cool, Version 5000.
Ja, die haben doch, wenn ich das richtig in Erinnerung hab, haben sie doch nachdem jetzt Oracle gesagt hat, ist jetzt hier alles nicht mehr so, haben sie ja sozusagen die Revision halt oder die Versionen richtig weit nach oben gesetzt, damit es auf keinen Fall mehr Konflikte gibt mit dem Oracle-Branche, sollten die noch mal jemals was open sourcen sozusagen.
Ah, verstehe, die fangen jetzt bei 5000 neu an, oder was?
Ja, beziehungsweise sie haben sich dann ein anderes Konzept überlegt, wie man die Features, die ein Zpool oder das ZFS bietet, irgendwie auf die Version mappt. Also dieses 5000, es wird dann wohl auch keine 5001 mehr geben, sondern 5000 und dann gibt es halt irgendwie eine Möglichkeit, halt Features zu sagen, das kann ich und das kann ich nicht. So richtig verstanden habe ich das nicht, aber ich habe da irgendwann mal das Proposal zu gelesen.
Das bleibt jetzt einfach bei 5000 sozusagen.
So habe ich das verstanden, vielleicht habe ich das falsch verstanden, aber ja.
Es war auf jeden Fall mit diesem, sozusagen dem Fog da, um den Fog Ausdruck zu verleihen.
Ja, genau, ZFS Feature Flags, genau, die Dinge. Die haben dann diese 5000er-Versionen, haben die dann und damit ist die Sache dann gegessen. Na ja, es ist doch so, dass der Rasenmäher hat ja dazu geführt, dass jetzt irgendwie Sun beziehungsweise Oracle, die Entwickler, weggelaufen sind und die bisherigen Kernel-Entwickler machen ja dieses Elumos, was halt nur der Kernel ist und was, aber der Kernel und ZFS und so weiter ist, also da haben wir letztes Mal schon so uns auf dünnem Eis bewegt. Ich will da eigentlich nicht weiter rumrennen in der Gegend, aber deswegen die haben halt diesen Schritt angekündigt zu sagen, wir machen jetzt das mit den Feature Flags und dann ist gut. Ich habe irgendwann auch mal versucht, das irgendwie zu installieren und zu kompilieren und dann auch zu installieren und damit das kein Unglück gibt in der VM. Das ist mir aber nicht gelungen, aber es ist auch schon ein paar Monate her, vielleicht ist es inzwischen so weit, dass man das tatsächlich auch mal, also zumindest mal in der VM zum Laufen kriegt. Ich habe das jetzt nicht versucht in letzter Zeit, aber ich fand zumindest dieses Spreadsheet doch sehr interessant.
Da steht irgendwie für NFS 4 ACLs. Für Exzess-Kontrolllisten von NSF 4 bräuchte man NetArt-Talk.
Ja, vielleicht ist in NetArt-Talk irgendeine Art von Mapping eingebaut, wenn da was steht von... was ist denn da? Achso, nee, es ist nur, wo man NetArt-Talk hinkommt. Keine Ahnung, was das bedeutet. Das ist bestimmt nur so ein Mapping-Layer, der halt dann nur damit funktioniert, wenn man das NetArt-Talk hat. Weil die das in NetArt-Talk das Problem auch hatten und da mal gelöst haben. Irgendwie sowas. Ich bin jetzt doch auch noch im Nebel.
Ich starre nur gerade so ein bisschen auf diese...
Nebel-Matrix.
Aber ich das richtig sehe, ist so diese Freebase-Diversion von ZDF ganz schön okay so.
Die sind ja schon seit eh und je relativ fit dabei.
Das ist ein Desk 9 Stable. Ja, 9 Stable hab ich ja auch.
Alles außer Encryption.
Das ist ganz witzig, weil auf diesem FreeNAS läuft ja auch quasi auf einem FreeBSD 9. Da gibt es Encryption, aber da packen sie die Encryption einmal unter das ZFS drunter, was ich ein wenig komisch fand und deswegen nie ausprobiert hab.
Ist nicht der Hubbard? Wer war denn das? Der Darwin Hubbard? Ist der nicht irgendwie jetzt von Apple weg und?
Ja, ja, der ist zu der Firma, die dieses Freenas macht. Dieses, oh Gott, wie hießen die?
Hab ich auch vergessen. Aber das fand ich ja irgendwie bemerkenswert.
Naja, wenn er keinen Bock mehr auf Apple hatte. Ich kann mir vorstellen, dass wenn man da lange genug ist, dass man dann halt keinen Bock mehr hat. Also, das ist, EX Systems heißen die. Genau, EX Systems, die machen da, TrueNas heißt irgendwie ihre kommerzielle Version und die andere heißt Freenas.
Ja, wir blicken nicht durch.
Also ich habe das Freenas neulich mal ausprobiert. Das ist irgendwie, das ist merkwürdig schmerzfrei. Also das ist so, man wirft es einfach an und es tut und irgendwie denkt man sich, das kann doch nicht sein. Was habe ich falsch gemacht?
Das war nicht so ganz meine Experience. Vielleicht werde ich es irgendwann nochmal ausprobieren.
Das einzige, was Freenas überhaupt nicht hinkriegt, ist, dass du, wenn du sagst, okay ich will diesen Pool jetzt aber nicht mehr haben, mach ihn weg, das geht nicht. Der bleibt da ewig auf dem Pool sitzen. Du fragst nach mir? Ja, ich hätte gern noch eins.
Ja, gleich. Ich nehme einen Saft.
Einen Saft? Vielleicht noch, was ist das hier, Gesundheits...
Nee, hat schon heute einen langen Tag hinter mir und wenn ich jetzt noch ein Bierchen trinke, dann falle ich hier gleich vom Stuhl.
Okay, das wollen wir ja nicht. Du könntest uns ja mal deinen Blogpost näherbringen, den du da verfasst hast. Der ist ja mal wieder in so einer epischen Länge, dass man das ja jetzt überhaupt nicht...
begreifen kann.
Ich finde, Blogposts sind auch wide only heutzutage. Man schreibt die und weil sie dann keiner lesen kann, weil sie zu lang sind, erklärt man sie dann auch in einem Podcast.
Ja, also es geht um den Podcast, den Podcast, das Blog und den Blogpost so rum, den ihr jetzt im Chat und später in den Show Note zu finden ist, der da heißt Why Not Pay for Music? Warum habe ich den geschrieben? Weil ich mich jetzt, wo ich selber Musik mache und auch schon ein paar Musiker, Freunde habe und so, und durch das Podcast mit Flatter und so, Geld verdienen im Internet, alles schon so ein bisschen in Kontakt gekommen bin und ich mit der Materie jetzt ein bisschen beschäftigt habe und die Leiden von meinen Musikerfreunden mit Plattenfirmen und so weiter alles sozusagen direkt erfahren habe, habe ich mich so mehr und mehr damit beschäftigt. Ich habe ja auch schon mal zwei Bücher zu dem Thema da empfohlen in einer vorherigen Folge, Appetite for Self-Destruction und All You Need to Know About the Music Business. Die sind beide schon sehr lehrreich und desillusionierend und wenn irgendeiner von euch da draußen denkt, ach ja, hier so ein Plattenvertrag und Album und so weiter, tut's nicht. Das wär jetzt quasi die denkbar schlechteste Zeit dafür und in dem Blogpost schreibe ich eigentlich so im Wesentlichen, wie es früher so war und wie es jetzt so ist und was man da machen kann. Das ist so die Super Executive Summary und ich hab auch mit Leuten schon gesprochen, die bei Universal gearbeitet haben oder auch bei einem Indie-Label und mit Musikern, wie gesagt, also jetzt nicht so irgendwelches Zeug, was ich mir aus den Fingern gesogen hab, sondern es hat jetzt so schon über Monate alles zusammengesammelt und die eine Frau, die bei Universal digital mal gearbeitet hat, die hat sich das auch so durchgelesen oder sich das mal angehört und meinte, ja, das trifft's eigentlich ziemlich gut. Von daher war ich dann irgendwann auch bereit, das einfach mal online zu posten und das ist jetzt schon ein paar Tage her, ich weiß nicht, 14. Juli und ich glaube, ich hab's hier noch nicht erwähnt. Und genau, für alle die, die das vielleicht so ein bisschen interessiert und auch so mit der Frage sich plagen, wie kann man denn im Internet Geld verdienen? Da sind auf jeden Fall auch so ein, zwei Anhaltspunkte drin, weil, was wir ja am Anfang schon gesagt haben, es gibt echt schreckend viele Leute, die sich mit dem Internet halt noch nicht so auseinandergesetzt haben, geschweige denn, wie man da Geld verdient. Und die Musiker sind davon ganz besonders betroffen, weil die halt die ganze Zeit so da sind, so, ja, Plattenvertrag ist scheiße, aber dieses Internet, ich hab ja gar keine Ahnung, was man da machen kann. Und das ist wirklich schlimm. Genauso wie die Leute nicht wissen, was Cookies sind oder wie sie getrackt werden, wissen sie nicht, was Flatter ist, die wissen nicht, was Bandcamp ist, die wissen nicht, was Paypal ist, die wissen nicht, wie man sich selber im Internet promoted, die wissen nicht, dass Leute so wie Tim von Content ins Internet stecken leben können, mehr oder weniger, ja, also und sich eine Fanbase quasi organisch zulegen, das kennen die alles nicht. Und das ist sozusagen auch eine Funktion dieses Blog-Postes, die Leute ein bisschen zu motivieren, mal sich selber zu kümmern, weil diese Platten-Labels und alle auch Publisher für Bücher oder so, die früher quasi diesen Job gemacht haben, die machen das halt heutzutage nicht mehr. Das macht keiner mehr für euch. Ihr müsst das selber machen. Und wie gesagt, da sind eben so ein paar Anhaltspunkte auch am Ende dazu drin und ja, eigentlich müsste man das schon dann am Ende doch mal sich selber durchlesen. Aber was wir jetzt hier vielleicht noch an der Stelle ein bisschen besprechen könnten, ich habe mich ja auch so ein bisschen damit beschäftigt, was es eigentlich so für Dienstag jetzt außer Flatter zum Beispiel gibt, um sozusagen Geld zu verdienen. Ich habe mir, da bin ich auch auf Cent abgestoßen. Cent ab.
Wie Eurocent?
Wie Dollarcent, aber zusammengeschrieben centup.org. Das war jetzt mal so aus der Hüfte geschossen. Das ist halt wie Flatter mit Dollars und mit Facebook Connect sign up, wenn man nicht per E-Mail signen will. Hat aber so ein paar interessante Unterschiede. Der größte Unterschied ist, die nehmen halt nicht alles. Bei Flatter kannst du ja dein Foto von einem Fußnagel machen und einen Flatter-Button drunterkleben. Das kannst du da nicht. Ich glaube, als Publisher muss man hier seinen Content einreichen, wie beim App Store quasi. Und dann wird da drüber gerichtet, ob das denn jetzt sowas ist, was sie da haben wollen oder nicht. Die sind noch relativ frisch, wenn ich das mitbekommen habe. Und sind jetzt in dieser Phase, wo sie darum bemüht sind, viel guten Content zu haben. Deswegen filtern sie da relativ stark noch. Ist halt nicht so der ganze hippieske Ansatz wie bei Flatter.
Wie funktioniert das Modell?
Im Prinzip auch so. Du meldest dich als User an, überweist deine Funds dahin. Also Fund ist dein Account und dann kannst du halt Sachen, die es da reingeschafft haben, als Content senden. Aber auch nur innerhalb dieser Plattform. Ja, ich glaube nicht, dass sie das irgendwie schaffen. Die haben schon Flatter als Inspiration genommen, aber sie haben irgendwie die falschen Schlüsse aus dem nicht weltumspannenden Erfolg von Flatter geschlossen und es irgendwie schlimmer gemacht. Also ich meine, wenn du nicht jeden Content akzeptierst, dann ist das halt schon wieder so eine Einstiegshürde, die einfach...
Also es gibt da noch so ein ähnliches Ding, was mir auch so ein bisschen Spanisch vorkommt, und das heißt Pling It.
Wieso Spanisch? Italienisch?
Kommt dir das so italienisch vor?
Und es hat Punkt IT, also als Top-Level domain.
Ja, okay, sorry, mein Hirn ist leider nicht mehr schnell genug für diese Sendung. Auf jeden Fall Pling It würde ich jetzt mal, so wenig ich darüber weiß, ich hab das mir so ein bisschen angeschaut, ein ähnliches Modell. Also auch hier wird so ein Katalog kuratiert und dann soll man dann darüber irgendwie, keine Ahnung, wie die das machen. Also ich hab das Modell auch noch überhaupt nicht verstanden. Die haben mich auch irgendwie angespammt. Also ich hab irgendwie so eine Mail bekommen, keine Ahnung, ob die dabei fletter, erstmal den Katalog ausgelesen haben und alles angeschrieben haben. Das Gute daran, finde ich, ist, mehr Leute beschäftigen sich jetzt mit diesem Thema.
Stimmt, ich glaube, ich hab auch eine gekriegt.
Ja, und sie haben ja auch einen Pling-Button, der hochzählt. Also so richtig... Ja, ich finde, anders scheint es nicht zu sein, aber dieses eigentliche Verteilungsmodell von Flutter, das ist so jetzt erstmal noch nirgendwo zu sehen, oder?
Ja, und ich finde halt, wenn man sich halt anguckt, wie zum Beispiel jetzt am Beispiel der Musikindustrie, wie die das machen, jetzt auch mit diesen neuen Diensten, so mit Spotify, hatte ich das schon auch hier mal erwähnt? Ich bin mir gerade nicht sicher, weil da gibt es jetzt Duplizitäten mit meinem anderen Podcast, aber das Spotify-Modell ist ja nochmal kurz abgerissen. Ich höre jetzt zehnmal Tim Pritloffs Italiasong und nur den und hab zehn Euro im Monat eingezahlt, aber Rihanna kriegt trotzdem einmal mein Geld. Und du kriegst vielleicht einen Cent. Das ist das Modell. Alle schmeißen einen großen Topf und die Big Players kriegen das meiste.
Ach so wie GEMA oder was?
Also das GEMA-Modell.
Und es ist halt bei den, soweit ich weiß, bei allen Streaming-Diensten so. Und warum ist das so? Weil die ganzen Streaming-Dienste, die irgendeine signifikante Userzahl haben von Plattenlabels, schon geowned sind. Also Spotify ist ja komplett Plattenlabel infested. Das heißt, die haben da quasi total den Traum drauf, deswegen kommt man halt auch nicht einfach, bei Spotify kommt man ja auch nicht als du und ich da einfach so rein. Du musst ja auch eine rechte Verwertungsproxy-Firma sozusagen beauftragen, dich da bei Spotify zu vertreten. Und das heißt halt, das ist für kleine Künstler Spotify total unnütz. Also wenn ihr 10.000 Plays hinbekommt, dann könnt ihr froh sein, wenn ihr euch eine Flasche Bier vielleicht mal kaufen könnt. Also da kommt halt wirklich so wenig rum, dass es sich halt für kleine Artes selbst bei Indie-Labels oder so lohnt, nicht lohnt im Prinzip. Also es ist nur da, um den Leuten die Möglichkeit zu geben, die Band zu hören. Aber Geld verdient man da als kleine Band nicht. Das ist auch wieder nur ein System, was so die Großen supportet.
Was ist denn deine Empfehlung an die Musiker? Oder wendest du dich jetzt eigentlich mit dem Blogpost mehr an die Konsumenten?
Beides im Prinzip. Deswegen erzähl ich das auch, weil ich dachte, vielleicht weißt du eben auch noch so ein paar Dienste, sowas wie Flatter oder Send Up. Aber im Prinzip, das Problem bei Flatter ist ja eigentlich, also jetzt für Musiker zum Beispiel, Flatter funktioniert halt in der Blogger- und Podcasterszene in Deutschland sehr gut. Und dann hört es aber auch schon fast gleich wieder auf, wo es funktioniert. Und also Musiker, wenn die halt jetzt so einen Flatter-Button auf ihre Bandseite machen, dann kann man nicht, die kriegen da halt nichts. Weil die Konsumenten oder ihr Publikum halt einfach mit Flatter auch nichts am Hut hat bisher.
Es hat auch ein bisschen was mit dem Content und mit der Art der Darreichung zu tun. Also Flatter funktioniert halt vor allem für Sachen, die eben kontinuierlich sind. Deswegen funktioniert das gut mit Podcasts. Weil du da einfach eine ganz klare Verbindung hast mit einem mehr oder weniger regelmäßigen Erscheinen bzw. einer kontinuierlichen Arbeit, die permanent Ergebnisse erzielt, die du auch permanent regelmäßig konsumierst. Und umso regelmäßiger du hörst, und umso regelmäßiger das, was du hörst, auch kommt, umso höher ist natürlich der Incentive, da auch Teil der Unterstützerfront zu werden. Ist ja vollkommen klar. Aber das haben halt Musiker irgendwie so nicht.
Ja genau, das ist zum Beispiel einer der Punkte, dass ich denen dann halt, dass ich da auch schon sag, irgendwie, wenn das mit dem Geldverdienen im Internet klappen soll, dann muss man halt auch die ganze Zeit irgendwie nah am Hörer oder am Fan sein, irgendwie Content produzieren, sei es irgendwelche Videoschnipsel, irgendwelche Fotos irgendwie halt die ganze Zeit rausschieben, weil sonst hätte ja das Plattenlabel oder der Promoter halt sozusagen die Bandkommunikation mehr oder weniger für dich übernommen, ja? Und du hast halt den Plattenvertrag und du hast den Promoter und der ist dafür da, irgendwie für dich da Welle zu machen. Machen sie aber heutzutage nicht mehr, weil es gibt halt keine Radioplätze mehr und keine Fernsehslots mehr für alles, was nicht Mainstream ist. Deswegen muss man das halt selber machen und das funktioniert eben genau. Das Plattenmodell funktioniert nur, wenn man die ganze Zeit so eine Bindung und eine Kommunikation halt mit dem Konsumenten...
Ja, wenn die Musiker mal eine Bindung mit der Podcast-Szene eingehen würden, dann würden sie sich mal ganz interessante neue Kanäle erschließen. Tu sie aber auch nicht.
Genau, das ist halt deswegen dieser Blogpost, weil halt ganz viele Musiker, mit denen ich mich eben unterhalte, wie gesagt, wie auch diese Studenten in der UDK. Sorry, falls jemand von den Studenten hört, ich hab euch alle total gern und es war sehr schön, dass ihr bei meinem Kurs wart. Aber, und jetzt wisst ihr auch was, aber es ist trotzdem halt immer wieder erschreckend, dann zu sehen, ja, hey, es gibt diesen ganzen Kram, Flatter und was nicht noch alles, niemand.
Also ich hab überhaupt gar kein Problem damit, wenn irgendjemand was nicht weiß, aber ich hab ein Problem damit, wenn die Leute jung sind, jammern und nicht bereit sind, sich dann auch mal reinzustürzen und einfach so im Schicksal hingeben. Weil das Flatter so in der aktuellen Form nicht für alles funktionieren kann, ist klar, nichts funktioniert für alles. Ich hab jetzt diese neuen Modelle noch nicht begriffen, ich hab überhaupt nicht klar, was da jetzt irgendwie anders sein soll. Irgendwie scheinen sie total davon beseelt zu sein, die Leute alle auf ihre Webseite zu kriegen und da in irgendwelchen Katalogen rumzuklicken. Aber meiner Meinung nach funktioniert Community Support so nicht. Community Support funktioniert über eine Community. Und die musst du dir halt aufbauen, bzw. sie musst du auch pflegen. Und das ist natürlich beim Musiker was anderes. Das hängt jetzt auch nochmal sehr von der Art Musiker ab. Das hängt von der Musik ab. Das hängt von deinem Reach, den du natürlich schon hast, auch ab. Das hängt davon ab, wie sehr du so konzertauglich bist, also wie viel Präsenzarbeit du hast. Das hängt davon ab, wie schnell du produzierst. Man, es gibt ja auch so, was weiß ich, hier so Jim-Avignon-Style Musiker, die irgendwie jeden Abend einen neuen Song raushauen können. songaday.com, ja, bestes Beispiel. Gut, das ist dann nicht immer so der heiße Kram, aber darüber baut man sich tatsächlich eine Community auf, weil man sich auf einmal auch ganz anders vernetzt. Und weil man sich vielleicht auch so ein bisschen trennt von diesem doch auch schon, ich will das jetzt nicht so negativ darstellen, mir fallen bloß jetzt gerade nicht die richtigen Worte ein. Ich bin jetzt Musiker und mein Ding ist, meine Kunst maximal ausleben zu können, indem ich mich jetzt drei Monate in Keller sperre und alle acht Monate habe ich dann ein Album fertig. Und dieses Album, das ist dann die Basis aller meiner Refinanzierung. Und ich glaube, das kann funktionieren, ist aber eher ein Ziel als ein Mittel. Das ist so ein schöner Zustand, den man dann irgendwann mal haben kann, dass man sich diese Zeit freikauft. Aber bis dahin muss man sich einfach bewähren und präsent sein und dann muss man vielleicht auch mal darüber nachdenken, wie man sich mit seinen musikalischen Fähigkeiten auch besser einbringen kann.
Ich glaube, dieses Album ist aber halt so ein Bundling-Problem. Also du hast genauso wie wir das letzte Mal über die Zeitung gesprochen haben und wo weiß ich nicht, der Internetnutzer keine ganze Zeitung mehr kauft, sondern nur noch die Artikel liest, die ihn interessieren und sich da direkt reinklickt, ist es glaube ich heutzutage auch schwierig, zumindest nicht dann, wenn du halt nicht eine Major Band bei einem Major Label bist, tatsächlich ein richtiges Album zu stricken, was die Leute dann auch als Album wahrnehmen, sondern du machst halt dann einzelne Songs. Und ich glaube, dass Bands vielleicht auch mehr zu diesem Modell hinkommen müssen, dass sie sagen, sie machen halt alle drei Wochen, alle vier Wochen machen sie halt einen Song.
Und auch halt, was auch noch dazukommt, dass sie sich halt auch sowieso mal alle selber ein bisschen schlau machen, was es so für Plattformen gibt und dann auch nicht nur bei einer da sitzen, sondern halt auch einfach alles ausprobieren. Das kostet ja in den meisten Fällen auch nichts. Zum Beispiel Flatterbutton kann man ja trotzdem raufmachen, auch wenn jetzt da vielleicht im Monat irgendwie drei Klicks zusammenkommen, aber drauf geschissen. Im Prinzip, jeder Send, den man da verdient, ist mehr, als ein gesignter Artist nach 1000 Downloads auf iTunes verdient hätte. Weil beim ersten Album verdienst du ja da, kriegst ja kein Geld. Du bezahlst ja mit den Einnahmen deines Albums sozusagen.
Das kommt drauf an, also es gibt inzwischen quasi so Proxy-Labels, die dir im Prinzip eigentlich nur noch ein Webfrontend zu iTunes sind, wo du quasi zu einem festen Share bekommst vom ersten Sale ab. Aber da musst du dann wirklich auch alles selber machen.
Ich hab ja gesagt, gesignter Artist. So, gesignter Artist, der kriegt halt einfach kein Geld fürs erste Album.
Ich hab mir das mal angeguckt nachdem David hier mit dem Song über die Telekom so einen Erfolg hatte. Hab ich mir das halt auch mal angeguckt, was muss man eigentlich machen, um bei iTunes irgendwie einen Song unterzubringen. Und es gibt halt so eine Hand voll von diesen, ich nenne sie mal Proxy Labels.
Gibt's auch bei Spotify und so.
Wo du im Prinzip halt eine Web-Oberfläche hast, wo du wirklich dann deinen MP3 hoch lädst und dann lädst du deine Cover Art hoch und dann tippst du deine Metadaten ein und dann sagst du, dass sie hier verkaufen. Und dann kriegst du aber halt auch pro Verkauf wirklich einen festen Prozentsatz.
Und was ich jetzt bisher eigentlich immer noch mit am besten finde, ist Bandcamp. Die machen halt, also alle diese Dienste, die machen halt immer nur so eine Sache richtig gut und der Rest ist halt eher schlecht. Bei Bandcamp, da machen sie es halt im Prinzip gut. Du lädst deine Files hoch, sagst, was es kosten soll, kannst sagen, dass die Leute auch mehr bezahlen können, wenn sie wollen und kannst lossless-Files in allen möglichen Formaten hochladen und dann können die Leute das da einfach direkt kaufen. Und ich habe da auch von meiner Band in Anführungsstrichen sozusagen jetzt auch mal schon ein paar Songs hochgeladen und tatsächlich hat auch einer der Twitter-Follower direkt oder zwei oder drei haben tatsächlich das direkt gekauft. Das heißt, ich habe da sechs oder sieben Euro schon verdient. Ich habe meinem anderen Podcast-Kollegen davon erzählt und der hat auch gleich mal so ein Bandcamp-Ding eingerichtet und hat...
Wonach muss ich da suchen?
Nee, oder weiß nicht, doch mein Account könnte das sein, aber es heißt White Volcano. Ich kann das ja mal hier reinpacken, warte mal, in den Chat.
Das ist auch Instant Gratification.
Was heißt das? Ja, genau das da.
Rock. Ich meine, abspielen können.
Klar. Geht gleich los. Na, und da beim ersten, den ersten Song, den ich hochgeladen hab, da hat einer gleich statt einem Euro drei Euro bezahlt. War so geil. Ich hab's hochgeladen, gezwittert und dann so kam so gleich Ka-Ching, irgendwie so eine Mail mit dem Topic Ka-Ching. Boah, da dachte mir, geil, irgendwie, die ersten drei Mark hier verdient. Und wie gesagt, mein Podcast-Kollege, der hat das auch gemacht und der meinte auch, hätte auch gleich Verkaufserfolge gehabt. Und die nehmen halt Bandcamp, nimmt glaube ich zehn oder zwölf Prozent. Und das ist halt nochmal deutlich besser, als iTunes, die 30 nehmen, plus dein Proxy-Label, was sozusagen auch nochmal zehn oder so nimmt. Ich glaube, bei Bandcamp bleibt schon mit am meisten hängen für den Künstler-Lehrer.
Ist das alles instrumental oder singt auch jemand?
Da singt keiner.
In dem Track oder im ganzen Album nicht?
Das ist ja Album, also in dieser EP, wenn man so will, da singt keiner. So ein bisschen wie die Surfen-Musik, die lebt ja auch ohne Gesang. Da machen die Gitarren die Musik ab.
Da ist so ein schönen, patchenden Spiral-Hall drauf.
Wir sind ja auch erst am Anfang unserer Reise. Wir haben ja auch noch kein Konzert gespielt, aber trotzdem habe ich schon Musik verkauft. Es ist so einfach, einfach mal ins Internet rein zu stehen. Schon dieser Schritt, da scheitert es ja schon mal ganz vielen. Und auch diese Angst, es ist ja noch nicht fertig, und es ist ja nicht professionell produziert und ohne Label. Das kann man ja nicht machen. Das geht ja nicht. Doch, das geht, Jungs. Und Mädels, auch die Mädels ganz besonders. Kauft euch ein Audio-Interface für 100, 200 Euro. Kauft euch ein SM57, kostet auch 90 Euro oder so was. Ich habe lange keins mehr gekauft. Aber das ist so das Standard Mikrofon, um Verstärker und was auch immer aufzunehmen. Kauft euch einen Reaper für 45 Euro und recordet den Scheiß, legt noch ein Buch dazu und dann schiebt das Zeug raus. Und wenn es gute Musik ist, die ganzen Bands aus den 60ern, die hatten vier Spur oder acht Spur-Geräte maximal, also das war ja schon Luxus, ich würde mal sagen, die meisten eher mit vier Spuren, haben irgendwie, hört euch den Sound an, die Beatles irgendwie, das Schlagzeug komplett auf eine Seite gemixed, also alles, wo professionelle, zwei-Kanal-Mono, wie man es so schön nannte. Genau, irgendwie professionelle Musikproduzenten heute sagen, oh Gott, oh Gott, totes Sünde, hört euch das an, es ist nicht perfekt High-Fidelity aufgenommen, aber es groovt und wenn eure Musik gut ist, dann funktioniert die auch nicht so gut aufgenommen. Das wichtige ist, würde ich sagen, einfach rausschieben und nicht darauf warten, dass ihr in der Lotterie gewinnt, ein Plattenlabel-Deal bekommt, wo ihr nicht komplett die Hosen ausgezogen bekommt, wo ihr nicht irgendwie das Label die ganze Zeit reinschreitet. Genau, wo man reinschreit, macht es einfach selber.
Ja, vor allen Dingen angeblich ist es ja so, dass die Labels heutzutage ja auch nur noch Bands nehmen, die schon einen gewissen Erfolg haben und eine gewisse Community mitbringen. Und wenn du natürlich sagen kannst, hier bei Bandcamp habe ich irgendwie schon meine ersten vierstelligen Beträge verdient, dann hast du halt auch einen anderen Stand bei einem Plattenlabel, wenn du den Weg wirklich gehen möchtest. Also ich meine, das muss man sich halt auch nochmal gut überlegen.
Also eine Freundin von mir, die hat, hatte ich glaube ich hier schon mal erwähnt, eine Band, die heißt Kadaver, der Name klingt jetzt erstmal ein bisschen brontal, aber die machen so Black Sabbaths 70er Jahre, also frühes Black Sabbaths Rock heutzutage, haben mit ihrem zweiten Album die Top 40 Albumcharts in Deutschland erreicht, was für diese Art von Musik jetzt schon eher speziell ist. Und der Typ hat halt Tonmann oder so Studiotoningenieur gelernt, eine Ausbildung und hat halt das ganze Recording für die Band, haben die alles selber gemacht, haben schon zig Konzerte gespielt und haben dann Plattenlabel-Deal quasi unterschrieben und hatten da ganz andere Standing, weil die ganze Produktion und alles war halt schon gemacht sozusagen. Also die haben jetzt einen viel besseren Deal und kriegen tatsächlich so ein bisschen Geld raus und kriegen ein bisschen Promotion und die waren damit auch sehr erfolgreich sozusagen ganz, ganz viel selber zu machen. Ich glaube, das ist auch ein ganz entscheidender Weg, heutzutage als Musiker irgendwie Erfolg zu haben, so viel wie möglich selber machen. Erstens, weil sich niemand mehr um eure Musik schert, als ihr selber. Und dementsprechend halt diese ganze Promotion, dieses ganze Recording und Mixen und was auch immer alles selber machen, so viel wie es geht. Und wenn ihr dann damit Erfolg habt, wenn das halt coole Musik ist und ihr ankommt und dann so ein Plattenlabel, die in der Schwebe steht, dann hat man halt einen ganz anderen Verhandlungshebel, weil man hat schon alles gemacht, wofür sonst das Label zehn, hunderttausende von Euro einfach ausgibt für semi motivierte Leute, die irgendwie tagtäglich irgendwelche Bands untergeschoben bekommen zum Mixen und Mastern und was auch immer, die auch nur yet another Band seid, die es nicht schaffen werden.
Ja, und seid alle nicht in der GEMA und dann könnt ihr irgendwie auch einfach, weiß ich nicht, mit einem zugekniffenen Arsch an diese ganze Kopiersache wandeln.
C3S sage ich nur.
Ja, kommen wir gleich nochmal was zu sagen, aber ich wollte jetzt vor allem erstmal so diesen generellen, also was du ja eigentlich da beschreibst, ich würde das mal mit mangelndem Mut beschreiben. Ja, also ich höre das ja auch manchmal hier immer so, ja hier mit deinem Podcast und so, du machst das ja jetzt irgendwie Vollzeit. Ja, aber bei mir würde das ja nicht funktionieren, weil bei dir ist das ja was anderes. Dann frage ich mich bitte, welches Gen jetzt bei mir vorherrschen soll, dass das was anderes ist. Das ist nichts anderes. Das ist immer wieder dieselbe Geschichte. Es ist diese, man muss einfach dranbleiben. Genau, man muss einfach dranbleiben und das mögen. Und ich denke, dass auch gerade jetzt im Bereich Podcast und Musik, das ist so ein ungenutzter Link. Warum gibt es nicht mehr Podcasts, die Musik vorstellen? Klar, das ist mal dieses Abspielproblem, wenn man sich aber einfach auf Musik, wenn man so ein Promo-Radio aufmacht, wo man nur so Sachen diskutiert und wenn man so halbwegs Musiksachverstand dann die Dinge auch so ein bisschen auseinandern. Ja, hier irgendwie neues Album, White Volcano, haben wir mal reingehört, viel Bling Bling, alles instrumental, haben wohl Angst vor Mikrofon, aber schöne Flächen irgendwie, klingt gut, hier ich spiele das mal an, zack, hier ist der Link. Ja, so ein lustiger Kommentar, unterhaltsames Radio draus machen, warum nicht? Leute, die irgendwie Bock haben auf so ein bisschen Musikreview, fühlen sich dabei gleichzeitig unterhalten und werden eben auch automatisch an Sachen rangeführt, Gewinn für alle Leute. Oder wenn man sowieso in der Lage ist, einfach mal schöne Klänge zusammenzustellen, es muss ja auch nicht unbedingt immer ein Song sein. Also man kann ja auch mal kurze Clips machen, man kann mal den Podcaster irgendwie Intros bauen oder nur sonstige lustige Effekte oder irgendwie Craziness einspielen. Da findet sich immer irgendwie ein Abnehmer für und das ist natürlich nichts, was jetzt unmittelbar Geld bringt. Aber es schafft Vernetzungen, es schafft eine Community, es ist einfach ein Mindshare bei Leuten, denen man einfach bekannt ist. Und nur darüber kann das funktionieren letzten Endes.
Und es ist halt auch so, genauso wie, das ist auch immer so ein Vergleich, zum Beispiel in der UDK, da ist es manchmal so, die Kunststellen wollen jetzt irgendwie eine Webseite machen und wollen jetzt ganz schnell eine Webseite machen und dann fragen sie mich, kannst du mir schnell HTML beibringen? Und dann bin ich so... Nee, und wahrscheinlich, wenn du HTML und CSS selber machen willst, in einem Jahr wirst du so an dem Punkt sein, wo du das selber so machen kannst und alles gecheckt hast und alles verstanden hast.
Und dann weißt du, warum du es nicht selber machen möchtest.
Ja, egal, selbst wenn. Aber zum Beispiel bei diesem Community-Aufbauen, ganz viele Leute denken dann halt auch so, ja, wenn ich jetzt was mache, das hört ja keiner. Ja, das hört jetzt keiner. Das muss man halt auch mindestens wahrscheinlich ein Jahr oder so einfach kontinuierlich machen und sich halt auch drum kümmern und alle Kanäle nutzen, um das halt bekannt zu machen, dass man halt irgendwann mal so auf einem Level ist und das ist halt auch Arbeit. Muss man halt sich drum kümmern und machen. Und wenn man halt die ganze Zeit da sitzt und nichts macht und die ganze Zeit nur Angst hat, dann passiert es auf jeden Fall nicht.
Unsere Botschaft an die Künstler, ihr müsst jetzt auch arbeiten.
Mehr Kontinuität.
Also ich meine, wirklich dieser, der eine Freund von mir, die haben jetzt halt es geschafft, ein Album rauszukriegen, aber das hat Jahre gedauert und die haben so viel Nerven, das hat denen so viel Nerven gekostet, wie diesen ganzen Labeltypen und der eine sagt was und der andere sagt was anderes und dann soll das Album schon dreizehnmal rauskommen und immer wird es verschoben, weil ja, aber da müsst ihr halt mal ne Single machen, da müsst ihr jetzt mal ne Tour machen, hier und da und der andere hat gesagt, geht jetzt nicht und...
Man muss ja Dinge immer so machen, wie man sie schonmal gemacht hat.
Und diese Zeit, die ihr da sozusagen auch verbrennt mit diesem Nachdenken, wie man es richtig machen könnte und wie kriegen wir jetzt unsere CD produziert. Das hat nämlich auch einer gefragt, letztens bei uns im Podcast, wie kriegen wir denn unsere eigene CD gemacht und wie macht man das dann so? Und dann hat der Felix erzählt, ja, so würde man das machen und so könnte man hier unter die Leute bringen und den CD-Läden, den kann man auch sagen, hier, oder die Musikläden hier auf Kommissionskauf und so weiter und so fort. Und jetzt ist schon alle so, aah, nein, tu es nicht, mach es digital, nutzt das Internet. Ich kann es nur wiederholen, das ist das erste Massenmedium, wo jeder reinschreiben kann, also versucht es einfach. Es tut nicht.
Ja, ich kann es schon verstehen, dass wenn man dann so eine CD in der Hand hat, die selber gemacht ist, die ordentlich geprintet ist mit einem ordentlichen Label, das ist schon was.
Das ist schon toll. Aber ich habe zum Beispiel den Kollegen hier beim Podcast gefragt, wo hat er seine meisten CDs verkauft? Weil er hat das Ganze gemacht, weil er das schon vor ein paar Jahren gemacht hat, da war das noch mit dem Internet vielleicht noch nicht so weit. Der ist in Läden gegangen, er hat irgendwie Posts aufgehangen, er hat das sonst wo, wo hat er die meisten CDs verkauft? Mit Abstand, 95 Prozent, Konzert. Und beim Konzert ist ein CD nicht, weil die das jetzt unbedingt haben wollen und sofort im Autoradio auf dem Weg nach Hause, sondern es ist ein Token für Support. So du weißt, okay, ich geh jetzt zu diesem Merchstand und ich kauf jetzt diese CD den Leuten ab und die stehen auch selber dahinter und die behalten einfach das meiste Geld von dieser CD.
Ja, du weißt, du gehst hin, du legst deine 20 auf den Tisch und die kriegt nicht einen Euro, sondern die kriegt 10 oder so. Deswegen kaufst du da die CD und nicht woanders.
Es ist halt ein Support-Token, genauso wie ein T-Shirt oder ein Poster oder was auch immer. Du willst halt schon was haben, du willst nicht einfach so hier, sondern es gibt so ein kleiner Interaktionspunkt und man hat dann halt so einen Token einfach in der Hand. Ah ja, ich habe was gekauft, aber eigentlich habe ich euch supportet.
Jim Avignon, sagt euch das was?
Ich habe schon mal gehört.
Ganz bekannter Berliner Künstler, Maler, der schnellste Maler der Welt, wie er immer bezeichnet wird, der diese verrückten, crazy Figuren malt. Kennst du bestimmt.
Ja, ich habe es schon gesehen, aber schon wieder vergessen.
Naja, ich mache mal hier Jim Avignon Bilder und dann wirst du sofort wissen, worum es sich bei Jim Avignon...
Naja, sein Gesicht kommt mir auch sehr bekannt vor.
Sein Gesicht und vor allem auch seine Bildsprache, seine Figuren und so weiter. Der Typ ist super, der ist wirklich unglaublich. Wahrscheinlich einer der großartigsten Künstler, die hier in Berlin rumlaufen. Und der malt verdammt schnell. Also so richtig verdammt schnell. Der kündigt so, der hat so irgendwie mal, kann ich noch mal ein bisschen besser kennenlernen, der hat so einen, was war das? Ein Musical angekündigt über die Geschichte von dem Typen, der Tetris programmiert hat. Und Musical heißt, er steht auf der Bühne, performt irgendwie 4, 5, 6, 7, 8 Songs und hat dazu so selbstgemalte Bühnenhintergründe. Die Bühnenhintergründe hat er irgendwie einen Tag vorher gemalt und die Songs hat er wahrscheinlich auch irgendwie in der Woche erst komponiert, so ist er drauf. Und er macht dann irgendwie auch seinen Schrammelsound, den er da irgendwie macht, auch auf CDs. Und die CDs hat er natürlich dann auch auf den Konzerten verkauft, für 6 Euro. Um 6 Euro denkt man so, 6 Euro, ist doch irgendwie nicht so der Preis, weil du meinst vorhin so 20, das ist so eine normale Erwartungszeitung, wo aber wahrscheinlich 14 Euro sowieso nur für die anderen sind. Aber in dem Moment, wo du das auch für 6 Euro anbietest, da denkst du noch nicht mal drüber nach, dass du das mitnimmst. Du meinst so, damit hätte er irgendwie super Erfolg. Er wird alles los, also es liegt nichts im Keller. Du schleppst nicht immer wieder 100 Kilo Leer-CDs da durch die Gegend und ja klar, so funktioniert das und da kannst du ja dann auch immer noch das Konzept-Album fahren. Album ist ja auch nichts anderes als eine Zusammenstellung von irgendwie Related Art. Also ich denke auch, dass da für Geyama ist eigentlich kein Platz und man muss einfach da die Arschbacken zusammen kneifen und einfach nach vorne marschieren. Es gibt da sowieso keine andere Option.
Bevor das Internet ganz zugemacht wird, nutzt die Zeit jetzt noch.
Posten sie im Internet, solange es das noch gibt. Wer weiß, was ist.
Ah, zu C3S. Ja, gründet sich demnächst.
Warte mal, ganz kurze Sache, weil du vorhin meintest, die Beatles haben ja auch nur geschrammelt aufgenommen. Da gibt es eine schöne Webseite, in der die Anomalien in ihren Aufnahmen zu jedem Album, zu jedem Song genau mit Zeitmarke festgehalten ist, was in der Originalaufnahme falsch ist. Falsche Noten, ob irgendwas klickt, ob irgendwas falsch links, rechts verteilt ist. Ob irgendeinem Hintergrund einen Ton von sich gibt oder so. Sag mal einen beliebten Song, den jeder kennt.
Baby, you can drive my car. Heißt der nur drive my car?
Was heißt denn der eigentlich? Drive my car, 16 Sekunden, rechter Kanal, es klickt nicht hörbar in der Mono-Version, 20 Sekunden, harsh edit, ride channel as piano comes in, also irgendwie...
Krächzter was?
Harsh, also wie so ein kantiger Schnitt.
Fret, squeak, sound, das heißt, dass jemand auf den Seiten gequitscht hat. Naja, es ist mehr dieses... Also du hast es bei der akustischen Gitarre sehr stark dadurch, dass die Seiten etwas dicker sind und so umwickelt sind, also die oberen.
Ja, das ist immer so quietscht.
Wenn du da drauf drückst und dann löst du den Finger, aber nicht vollständig und fährst dann entlang der Seite, quietscht es halt so.
Ah, wenn man den Finger nicht richtig unter dem Chor setzt. Hier, 1,20. Paul singst, you can drive my car along to the last few notes of Guitarsillo. Listen carefully, the last three notes of the solo are on top of the words drive my car. Very hard to hear on CD version.
This needs the vinyl version.
Das ist mal so richtig durchgenerdet hier.
Also das ist mal absolut Hardcore. Also ich hab ja schon in dieser Sendung schon viele nerdy Webseiten gesehen, die vorhin diesen ZFS Vergleich oder irgendwie Podcast, Clients oder was nicht, noch alles, aber das ist ja mal echt...
Alter Schwede.
Alter Schwede, ja pack mal, also den Link...
Ja, der Link ist schon im Chat hier. So, jetzt nochmal C3S, genau, das kann man durchaus nochmal erwähnen.
Also dazu muss ich sagen, ich hatte mich ursprünglich auf dieser Mailing-Liste mal gemeldet, oder was heißt Mailing-Liste? Irgendwann ging mal die Frage rum, wer möchte denn Gründer sein?
Also wir sollten vielleicht kurz erläutern, worüber wir jetzt reden wollen, C3S.
Gema-Alternative auf Basis von Creative Commons.
Oder sagen wir mal generell eine Gema-Alternative, also eine Verwertungsgesellschaft, die sich eben Musikern und Komponisten anbietet und die eben für neue Modelle steht, die Creative Commons lizenziertes Material ermöglichen will. Sicherlich nicht nur. Also ich geh mal zumindest davon oder hoffe mal zumindest, dass sie generell innovativ aufgeschlossen sind. Da habe ich auch wenig Zweifel dran.
Naja, es geht vor allen Dingen auch darum, dass du dich halt nicht mit Mann und Maus irgendwie einem Dings verschreibst und sämtlicher künstlerischer Output ist dann, also ich meine, wenn du bei der GEMA Mitglied wirst, dann bist du bei der GEMA, dann bist du Leib-Eigener und alles, wo du jemals Piep machst, das läuft dann unter GEMA. Und ich glaube, bei der C3S zumindest ist es wohl so geplant, kannst du halt sagen, ja, dieses Stück wird einzeln abgelöst. Dieses Stück möchte ich jetzt über die C3S vertreten wissen und dieses Stück eben nicht. Und ja, die, wie heißt sie, Open Music Initiative oder so ähnlich heißen die, glaube ich. Was war das jetzt? Die haben das ja mal angefangen, genau das Open Music Projekt. Die haben angefangen, irgendwie freie Musik dann zu Alben zusammenzuführen und da Musikwettbewerbe zu machen. Und aus denen ging dann diese ganze Gründungsbewegung der C3S hervor. Und die hat jetzt einen Termin angeraumt für Ende September, wo sie dann tatsächlich gründen wollen. Ich weiß jetzt nicht genau, ob der Termin tatsächlich schon öffentlich ist.
Es gibt ja noch eine andere Bewegung da in der ganzen Sache.
Lass mich mal mit der C3S fertig erzählen. Also ich hatte mich ursprünglich mal gemeldet, ich würde als Gründer auch gerne zur Verfügung stehen und würde als Gründer da mitmachen. Aber die haben jetzt den Gründungstermin irgendwie auf einen Mittwochnachmittag in Hamburg gelegt. Und da war mir das dann doch irgendwie zu viel Aufwand, irgendwie nur für so eine Gründung jetzt da irgendwie in eine andere Stadt zu fahren, mitten in der Woche, und da zwei Urlaubstage zu spendieren. Und hab dann gesagt, also Leute, wenn es jetzt hart auf hart kommt und es daran scheitert, dann fahr ich da noch hin. Aber ich bin jetzt erstmal draußen. Das ist mir dann doch so heftig. Aber wie gesagt, also Ende...
Aber für die Revolution.
Für die Revolution, ja. Aber solange genug Revoluzzer da sind. Ne, so als Backup halt. Also wenn es wirklich nicht reicht, dann fahr ich da auch noch hin. So ist es nicht.
Also C3S, ihr habt gehört, wenn es hart auf hart kommt, wir schicken zu Not Roddy.
Ja, ich fahr dann noch hin.
Und dann geht die Sache klar.
Auch wenn man abends aus Hamburg nicht mehr mit dem Zug wegkommt, weil irgendwie der Letzte um halb zehn fährt.
Drauf geschissen.
Drauf geschissen, da muss man halt...
Steht sich an der Autobahn und trimpst.
Ja, oder auf die Reeperbahn oder so. Uuuuh, ich hab da schon mal gewohnt, ich kenn mich aus. Ist aber so.
Ja, willst du jetzt noch mehr über die C3S erzählen? Da gibt's ja noch ein wichtiges Detail. Das ist jetzt nicht ganz neu, aber das sollte man im Zusammenhang auch noch erwähnen. Und zwar, die machen ja gerade diese Crowdfunding. Genau. Und das lief soweit schon mal ganz gut, weil sie haben ihre Mindestanforderungen von 50.000 Euro dann doch relativ zügig auch eingenommen oder zugesagt bekommen, wie man vielleicht in Crowdfunding-Deutsch sagen sollte. Wir schauen gerade mal, sie sind bei 72.938 Euro. Das wird jetzt hier mit 126 Prozent angegeben. Wieso eigentlich?
Bei 50.000, die 100 Prozent wären, oder?
Richtig, genau, Entschuldigung. Aber trotzdem gibt es ein Funding-Ziel von 200.000. Im Sinne von hätten wir gern.
Ja, und zwar weil?
Ja, das war schon vorher so. Und jetzt gibt es noch einen besonderen Grund. Nämlich NRW, das Land NRW, hat wohl zugesagt, dass in dem Moment, wo sie diese 200.000 erreichen, und ich vermute mal, da ist die Deadline, letztlich die Deadline dieses Crowdfundings hier, dass sie das dann doppeln. Also wenn 200.000 von Leuten kommen, dann legt NRW nochmal 200.000 drauf. Und das ist dann natürlich schon mal deutlich mehr als...
Schon mal eine amtliche Summe.
Ja, so kann man auch schnell verbrauchen, wenn man die falschen Maßnahmen greift. Aber es ist jetzt auf jeden Fall schon mal auch eine Basis, um ein kleines Team nennenswerte Zeit lang da intensiv arbeiten zu lassen, vor allem auch an Software zu arbeiten, weil hier muss ja sicherlich eine ganze Menge programmiert werden. Und ja, ich halte dieses Projekt nach wie vor für hochgradig, unterstützungswürdig, nicht nur wegen der Leute, die dort aktiv sind. Also es sind schon wirklich sehr interessante Typen hier allen voran. Der Meinhard Starostik, der ja auch hier in Berlin wegen der Piraten Verfassungsrichter geworden ist, der sich ja auch schon sehr bemüht hat, hat so Verfassungslagen mit Vorratsdatenspeicherung etc. und der auch das hier juristisch begleitet. Und ich finde auch vor allem, dass es jetzt mal so das Projekt glaube ich, an dem man es mal festmachen sollte, diese ganze GEMA-Kritik dann auch mal in konkrete Maßnahmen umzulessen. Also selbst wenn das irgendwie scheitern sollte, dann wissen wir wenigstens, woran wir sind. Piraten haben wir ja auch mal ausprobiert, dann können wir auch mal C3S machen. So, also überlegt euch mal, ob ihr da nicht noch mal ein paar Euro reinlegen sollt.
Das Interessante an dem Funding davon ist, dass man also nicht nur, wie man das normalerweise immer so bei so Crowdfunding-Projekten macht, man schmeißt da irgendwie Geld ein und kriegt irgendwie eine Namensnennung dafür oder so. Oder kriegt irgendwie, wie das jetzt bei Homebrew war, ein paar Gläser. Sondern man kann da tatsächlich unter dem Tab Investition sagen, ich zeichne Anteile. Und wenn ich dann da meine Anteile gezeichnet habe und das Geld geflossen ist und das Ding gefundet ist, dann halte ich Anteile an der Gesellschaft. Was jetzt eigentlich für Crowdfunding nicht üblich ist.
Aber was ich mir zum Beispiel auch schon vor langer Zeit gedacht habe, dass das ja ultimativ, also wenn es wirklich um so ein richtig großes Projekt geht und du brauchst halt ordentlich Asche, dann wäre das ja total großartig, wenn du da halt so einen bestimmten Prozentsatz deine Anteile halt auch wirklich da eben veräußern könntest.
Die Frage jetzt, was man mit diesen Anteilen dann macht.
Da bist du wahrscheinlich bei irgendwelchen...
Du bist dein Genosse, bist du halt.
Du bist dein Genosse. Ich weiß nicht, ob du, ob die Gesellschaft Gewinn macht und eine Gewinnausschüttung macht. Wahrscheinlich eher nicht.
Stimmrecht doch nur oder sowas.
Vielleicht eine bestimmte Art von Stimmrecht, aber vielleicht ist es halt auch einfach nur ein Anteil, den du halt auch weiterverkaufen kannst. Wenn du irgendwann sagst, der Laden ist jetzt nicht so mein Ding und das will jemand anders haben.
Hier geht es einfach nur darum, Mitglied zu werden der Genossenschaft, die ja insofern was Neues ist, als dass sie ja das juristische Modell einer europäischen Genossenschaft ausprobieren. Das heißt, das ist quasi sofort ein ganz europagültiger juristischer Körper, der dann eben auch gegebenenfalls sollte sich die Idee viral verbreiten in Europa, auch in anderen Ländern schon her sein kann für weitere lokale Instanzen einer C3S. Wenn jetzt in Frankreich auf einmal alle auch der Meinung sind, sie müssten das jetzt mal auch mal machen, dann müssten sie nicht von Null anfangen, sondern auch da könnte man dann eben mit diesemselben juristischen Körper arbeiten. Aber das ist jetzt nicht investieren im Sinne von, dass du da eine Dividende bekommst oder eine Ausschüttung oder so weiter.
Nee, das hatte ich jetzt so auch nicht gesagt, aber ich finde es insofern spannend, als dass du wirklich Anteile eigentlich im Crowdfunding selten bekommst. Also ich hab's bisher noch nicht gesehen. Ja, das schon. Du kriegst halt mal ein Gadget oder...
Bist du jetzt schon Genosse geworden?
Nee, noch nicht.
Ja, ich will einen Anteil nehmen.
Das Ding ist, wenn ich jetzt Gründungsmitglied geworden wäre, dann hätte ich die Anteile, die man als Gründungsmitglied zeichnet, nicht über diesen Mechanismus kaufen können, sondern hätte die dann über die quasi die Gründung... Ja, es ist so, dass die Gründer, die Gründer zeichnen auch Anteile, aber nicht über diese Plattform.
Verstehe.
Und alle Anteile, die du über diese Plattform zeichnest, kannst du nicht als Gründer reklamieren, sondern die sind halt... Ja, die sind nur geplätscht, aber sind nicht als Gründer gezeigt. Wie auch immer.
Ist doch scheißegal.
Ist ja egal, aber es ist halt so. Ist so.
Auf jeden Fall, du könntest jetzt die 50 Euro, die du sonst in die Fahrt nach Hamburg stecken müsstest, kannst dir sozusagen gleich in Anteile umsetzen. Ist ja auch was.
Ja, das werd ich auch tun.
Und was war jetzt die Alternative? Hat nicht gerade irgendjemand gesagt, es gibt ja noch was anderes, außer CS?
Er war es, er war es.
Irgendjemand hat es. Also ich weiß nicht und Roddy scheinbar auch nicht. Na gut, dann haben wir das. Gut.
Vielleicht hab ich mich undeutlich ausgedrückt, aber ich...
Nein, die Alternative zu Gründungsmitglied werden ist...
Nee, nee, irgendwie so. Du hattest mit...
Danke schön.
Du hast ja gesagt irgendwie, hier lass mich doch mal erstmal mit C3S fertig machen. Da wollen wir Tim dir irgendwie ins Wort gerätchen mit irgendwie, es gibt ja noch irgendwie ein anderes Projekt oder irgendwie sowas.
Na, das war diese 200.000 Euro Dopplone von NRW. Man kann ja hier auch bei den Dankeschöns machen. Hier gibt es ganz schöne Sachen. Zum Beispiel 300 Euro gibt es einen Songwriting-Workshop mit Lucy van Org. Da hab ich mein Leben schon aufgewartet. Oder für 300 Euro gibt es auch einen Ableton-Push-Workshop bei Ableton, aber der ist schon weg. Da gab es nur einen. Mehr wollten sie nicht machen.
Zoe Lila singt Lied-Vocals für deinen Song.
Zoe Lila? Wer ist denn Zoe Lila?
Woll ich das wissen.
1500 Euro.
Nee, wenn, dann den Fight for Your Right to Party River Cruise.
C3S Wohnzimmerparty bei dir zu Hause für 3000 Euro. Dann müsst ihr ja wohl 3000 Euro für bekommen, wenn ich in meinem Wohnzimmer die ganze Party...
Aber ich finde dieses 1111, das C3S-Team singt für dich oder versucht es.
Ja, da muss man schon nochmal 11 Cent drauflegen.
Also da müssten sie vor allen Dingen auch mal ein bisschen was besseres auf den Tisch legen als so ein...
Ja, scheint nicht so populär zu sein. Das ist eigentlich ein schlechtes Zeichen, wenn diese ganzen teuren Optionen, die sind wahrscheinlich nicht wirklich toll. 750 Euro hat sich einer zumindest eine individuelle Mitgliedsnummer gesichert.
Also ich muss mal sagen, die Rewards sind ein bisschen mau. Da sind die Amerikaner doch ein bisschen kreativer. Also es gibt ja niemanden T-Shirt hier oder was?
Doch, da oben.
Ja, da oben. Warum gibt es denn die da unten nicht? Oder kriegt man da unten auch alle Benefits von denen? Weil normalerweise bei Kickstarter ist ja so, je höher du kommst, dann kriegst du halt alle Benefits, die die anderen auch bekommen haben, plus noch was dazu. Und hier sieht es ja so aus, du kriegst jetzt nur bei 3.000 Euro so eine Partie in deinem eigenen Wohnzimmer.
Ach, das ist aber auch schon so viel einzelnes Zeug hier irgendwie. Mit 200 Euro gibt es eine Rechtsberatung für Musiker durch Rechtsanwälte aus der Musikindustrie.
Ja, aber auf der anderen Seite, wenn du dir anguckst, wie viel Geld sie eingesammelt haben und wie viel von diesen Dankeschöns weggegangen sind, dann lässt es für mich nur den Schluss zu, dass schon verdammt viele Leute dann auch Anteile haben wollten. Müsste man mal ausrechnen, ja.
Man kann ja auch einfach spenden ohne irgendwie. Also ehrlich gesagt, mir sind die ganzen Dankeschöns ziemlich egal.
Ja, mir auch.
Ich hab jetzt einfach auch Mitglied geklickt, weil ich irgendwie keinen Bock hatte, jetzt wieder auf irgendeinen Prüll, der bei mir auf dem Tisch rumliegt und so. Was hab ich mit so komischen T-Shirts? Da ist am Ende noch eine URL drauf.
Tim Renner, ein QR-Code oder sowas. So, meine Ohren fallen gleich ab.
Ja, wir machen Schluss.
Mal jetzt Schluss, ne?
Ich glaub, das wars.
Also wir haben jetzt zu dritt hier so ne 4 Stunden noch was Sendung gerockt, oder was? Reicht.
Dann noch was Wichtiges zu erwähnen. Nächste Sendung ist in 2 Wochen.
Da gibt es noch so ein Apple-Patent. Audio-Hyperlinking in Podcasts.
Ja, das hab ich so dermaßen nicht verstanden, dass ich es mir gleich aufgeschrieben hatte, hier als Thema. Aber wir lassen noch ein paar Sachen übrig fürs nächste Mal. Ihr könnt uns ja auch mal ein paar Themen, die ihr gerne besprochen wissen möchtet, gerne mal hereinreichen.
Wir ignorieren die dann geflissentlich.
Das klang jetzt fast schon nach Versprechen, aber wir versprechen nichts.
Es ist auf jeden Fall sinnvoll, uns mal auf ein paar Sachen hinzuweisen. Nicht immer kriegt man alles mit und lebt ja auch vom Feedback so eine Veranstaltung. Ansonsten denke ich, machen wir jetzt hier mal den Sack zu. Huckel, Roddy, Tim, wir warn's. Clemens und Denis nehmen wir nächstes Mal wieder in die Pflicht.
Aber so was vornehmlich.
Wenn die sich in die Pflicht nehmen lassen.
Nicht, dass wir der Kalender dazwischen kommen. Bis bald.